EVERYONE TO THE WEDNESDAY JUNE
NINETEENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE -- AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT I KNOW
THAT THEIR NUMBER SENATORS THAT
HAVE.
MEETINGS TO CHAIR SO WE WILL
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND I'M
GONNA CALL FOR ALL MEMBERS AND
ASK THE SERGEANTS TO PLEASE CALL
MEMBERS DOWN TO ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX BUT IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND WITH THAT
LIKE TO CALL UP SENATOR HILL.
FILE ITEM SIX SB.
THREE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THEIR THAT DEDICATED WORK HARD
WORK ON THIS MEASURE AND I
GLADLY ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
WHICH FURTHER CLARIFY THAT SB
THREE TWENTY SIX DOES NOT
PRECLUDE AN H. O. A BOARD FROM
FULFILLING THEIR OBLIGATIONS
UNDER SB.
EIGHT HUNDRED I HAVE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO FIND LANGUAGE THAT IS
ACCEPTABLE TO ALL PARTIES AND
HOPE THIS AMENDMENT BRINGS US TO
A FINAL CONSENSUS.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX BUILDS UPON
LAST YEAR'S SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH I AUTHORED TO ADDRESS
BALCONY EXPERT INSPECTIONS AND
REPAIRS FOR APARTMENT BUILDINGS
FOLLOWING THE DEADLY. TWENTY
FIFTEEN BERKELEY BALCONY
COLLAPSE THAT KILLED SIX AND
INJURED.
SEVEN SB THREE TWENTY SIX
REQUIRES AN EXISTING CONDOMINIUM
BUILDINGS GOVERNED BY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE INSPECTIONS AT
LEAST ONCE EVERY NINE YEARS ON A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
BALCONIES.
STAIR WELLS AND OTHER EXTERIOR
ELEVATED L. ELEMENTS TO ENSURE
THEY ARE SAFE.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX ALSO
PREVENTS BUILDERS FROM PLACING
LANGUAGE IN AN H. ALWAYS
COVENANTS CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS RCC AND HOURS.
THAT WOULD LIMIT THE ABILITY OF
THE H. AWAY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
TO SUE THE DEVELOPER IF THERE
ARE CONSTRUCTION DEFECT.
THIS IS NOT A HYPOTHETICAL
SITUATION THE CASES CURRENTLY
BEING LITIGATED IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE A ROUTINE WATER LEAK
REVEALED THAT A MAIN WALKWAY ON
THE THIRD FLOOR.
WAS ABOUT TO COLLAPSE DUE TO
WOOD ROT WITH THE H. AWAY
ATTEMPTED TO FILE A CIVIL SUIT
AGAINST THE DEVELOPER THEY FOUND
REQUIREMENTS IN THERE SHE SHE IN
OURS.
PLACE THERE BY THE DEVELOPER
THAT REQUIRED A FULL MEMBER VOTE
BEFORE THEY COULD LEGALLY SEEK
DAMAGES A TOOK THE BOARD MONTHS
TO CONDUCT THE MEMBER VOTE.
AND THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
ON CONSTRUCTION DEFECT DEFECT
LAWSUIT NEARLY RAN OUT.
THE SITUATION IS BECOMING ALL
TOO COMMON THESE DEVELOPER
AUTHORED PROVISIONS CAN REQUIRE
AS MUCH AS AN 80% MAJORITY VOTE
BEFORE THEY CAN BE SUED FOR
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS.
INCONVENIENTLY THESE PROVISIONS
ARE OFTEN PRECLUDED FROM BEING
REMOVED WITHOUT THE DEVELOPERS
CONSENT SB THREE TWENTY SIX
PRESERVE EACH H. ALWAYS RIGHT TO
DECIDE HOW THEY WANT THEIR
ASSOCIATION GOVERNED.
BY KEEPING DEVELOPERS FROM
INSERTING POISON PILL
REQUIREMENTS THIS MEASURE PLACES
THE DECISION MAKING POWER
SQUARELY IN THE HANDS OF THE
HOMEOWNERS.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MISTER THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES.
YOUR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION'S
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I WANT TO ECHO THE AUTHORS
STATEMENTS AND IN APPRECIATION
TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US IN AND
HOPEFULLY FINDING A RESOLUTION
TODAY.
A TO THIS BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
AS WAS MENTIONED SB SEVEN TWENTY
ONE WAS A BILL THAT WE OPPOSE
LAST YEAR.
I WAS A BILL THAT SIMPLY DIDN'T
FIT THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OR
THE WAY COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS.
ARE RUN AND DEAL WITH THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES WE
COMMITTED AT THE TIME TO COME
BACK TO SENATOR HILL AND WORK
WITH HIM ON A BILL THAT WOULD.
REALLY ADDRESSED HIS ISSUES AND
OUR CONCERNS WITH GOVERNANCE AND
WE BELIEVE THAT SB THREE TWENTY
SIX HAS DONE THAT -- BY FINDING
A VERY COMMON SENSE PRACTICAL
APPROACH FOR COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS TO DEAL WITH --
ELEVATED STRUCTURES AND IN A
TIMELY FASHION ADDRESS THOSE --
THAT -- POSE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUE SO HOW WITH
THOSE WERE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY [inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND IN MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK
CAN TRIGGER A I'VE BEEN.
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS THAT I'VE
REPRESENTED BOTH PLAINTIFFS AND
DEFENDANTS IN CONSTRUCTION
DEFECT.
LITIGATION OVER THAT TIME FRAME.
AS A PRACTITIONER I FEEL THIS
LEGISLATION IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR TWO REASONS NUMBER.
ONE IT PROTECTS HOME BUYERS FROM
DANGEROUS AND LATENT
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS IN ELEVATED
STRUCTURES.
AND NUMBER TWO IT PROMOTES
COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE PRE LITIGATION DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCEDURES.
THAT ALREADY EXIST UNDER CIVIL
CODE SECTION.
EIGHT NINE FIVE AT SAC ALSO
NOTICE TITLE.
SEVEN OR THE RIGHT TO REPAIR Là
WE GENERICALLY REFER TO IT AS SB
EIGHT HUNDRED SENATE BILL.
EIGHT HUNDRED REGULAR AND
PERIODIC INSPECTIONS OF ELEVATED
STRUCTURES.
BY PROPERLY LICENSED AND TRAINED
EXPERTS IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
BECAUSE THESE CONDITIONS ARE NOT
APPARENT TO HOMEOWNERS.
WHO DON'T KNOW?
WHAT IT IS THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
OR LOOKING AT?
WE'VE HANDLED MANY CASES OVER --
THE LAST TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS.
WERE ELEVATED WALKWAYS AND
BALCONIES WERE DANGEROUSLY
DEFECTIVE.
BUT WE'RE NOT DISCOVERED UNTIL
EXPERT THE RIGHT KIND OF EXPERT.
WERE CALLED IN TO INVESTIGATE
THE CONDITION -- THE SECOND
PIECE OF THIS LEGISLATION IS THE
THE PROVISION THAT.
INVALIDATE WHAT WE CALL THESE
POISON PILL PROCEDURES -- SB
EIGHT HUNDRED WAS DESIGNED AND
INTENDED. TO PROMOTE A PRE
LITIGATION DISPUTE RESOLUTION
PROCESS IN ORDER TO EFFECTUATE
AN EARLY DISCUSSION AND AN EARLY
RESOLUTION.
OF CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS IN ORDER
TO EFFECTUATE REPAIRS SOONER
THAN LATER.
THE POISON PILL PROVISIONS ARE
DESIGNED TO THWART THAT PROCESS
THAT THEY ACTUALLY UNDERMINE THE
INTENT OF SB.
EIGHT HUNDRED BECAUSE IF YOU
CAN'T.
PAST THE VOTE OR YOU PASS THE
VOTE TOO LATE YOU LOSE YOUR
RIGHTS.
SO.
THAT DECISION SHOULD BE VESTED
IN THE BOARD.
NOT THE MEMBERSHIP -- AND I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT THESE
PROVISIONS ARE INTENTIONALLY
DESIGNED AND USED IMPRESSIVELY
IN LITIGATION. TO WIN THE CASE
ON BEHALF OF THE DEVELOPERS
BEFORE THE CASE CAN EVEN GET
STARTED SO THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT -- PROVISION AS WELL
AND WE APPRECIATE SENATOR HEROES
SENATOR HILLS EFFORTS.
ON THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY ISSUE
AND THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION TO
THE MATTER AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
OR TWO WINNERS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- NICK
CAMERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
BEFORE I START MY COMMENTS -- I
I I I WANNA BE CLEAR ON WHAT IT
IS THAT'S BEFORE US -- AND I
WANNA I WANNA SAYING FIRST OF
ALL THE CHAIR AND IS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AT AND THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
WORKING ON THIS.
HOWEVER I DID NOTICE THAT THE
VERSION OF THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS
GOING TO BE AMENDED INTO THE
BILL WAS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT IN
THE IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
FROM WHAT I THINK WE AGREED TELL
AND I JUST WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WHICH ONE IS IT.
I BELIEVE THERE WAS AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT WAS REACHED
BETWEEN THE AUTHOR AND SEE I A
AND R. COMMITTEE ON A SLIGHTLY
AMENDED VERSION BUT I WILL LET
THE AUTHOR -- IT DESCRIBE THAT
IF THAT MAKES SENSE.
I I HAVE THE LANGUAGE THAT I
THOUGHT WAS THE LANGUAGE THAT IS
BEFORE US AND I MEAN WE CAN READ
IT BUT WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
THAT YET IF YOU MAYBE YOU THINK
WHAT'S THE DISTRIBUTED PART.
MAYBE WHAT I SHOULD JUST AS READ
BUT I THINK WE HAVE IT'S ONE
SENTENCE AND AND IT'S IN THE SUB
DIVISION II.
OF SECTION TWO OF THE BILL.
AND IT ELIMINATES THE SECOND
SEXY THE SECOND SET SENS IN THAT
SECTION.
AND IT REPLACES IT WITH.
NOTHING IN THIS SECTION SHALL
AFFECT ANY OTHER OBLIGATIONS OF
AN ASSOCIATION CONTAINED IN
TITLE.
SEVEN COMMENCING WITH SECTION
EIGHT NINETY FIVE OF PART TWO
DIVISION.
TWO OR OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE
ASSOCIATION CCAR'S RELATED TO
ARBITRATION OR OTHER ALTERNATIVE
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCEDURES
THAT'S MY UNDERSTAND A LANGUAGE
THAT I THINK ALL THE PARTIES
INCLUDING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WRITER.
TO THANK YOU GREAT -- AT AS
PROMISED IN OUR IN OUR LETTER TO
THE COMMITTEE A WE WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN PLANT I AM THE MANAGING
PARTNER OF PLANT Là PHOBIC L.
L. P..
WERE A LITIGATION LAW FIRM WITH
OFFICES IN IRVINE SAN FRANCISCO
AND PHOENIX.
I'VE BEEN REPRESENTING HOME
BUILDERS THANK YOU AND
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LITIGATION.
EXCUSE ME FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION ONLY
TO SECTION TWO OF THE BILL.
I'VE GOT THREE POINTS THAT I'D
LIKE TO MAKE.
FIRST I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM -- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT SECTION TWO OF THE
BILL IS ABOUT HOMEOWNERS I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S ABOUT BUILDERS.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER ENTRY AREA I
BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT.
PLAINTIFFS LAWYERS WANTING TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO GET THESE
CASES INTO LITIGATION BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW THEY MAKE THEIR MONEY.
AS THE COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
THOUGHT LONG AND HARD ABOT HOW
TO CURB CONSTRUCTION DEFECT
LITIGATION OVER THE YEARS.
AND THE ENACTMENT OF SB EIGHT
HUNDRED WAS ONE OF THOSE EFFORTS.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE YEARS
IS THAT IT HASN'T HAD THE EFFECT
THAT EVERYBODY INTENDED?
AND THE PROBLEM IS WHEN REPAIRS
ARE ACTUATED PLAINTIFFS
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LAWYERS
DON'T MAKE ANY MONEY.
THEY WORK ON A CONTINGENCY FEE
BASIS AND THEY ONLY MAKE MONEY
IF THESE CASES GOING TO
LITIGATION AND THERE'S A CASH
SETTLEMENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THE A THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT VOTING PROVISIONS
SUCH AS THESE HAVE BEEN AROUND
pFOR DECADES.
AND THEY'RE ENTIRELY CONSISTENT
WITH EXISTING LAW IN FACT LAST
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA COURT OF
APPEAL IN THE BRANCHES CASE
CONSIDERED THE EXACT VOTING
PROVISION THAT SECTION TWO OF
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ABOUT.
H. O. A. LAWYERS IN THAT CASE
MADE ALL THE SAME ARGUMENTS THAT
THE PROPONENTS OF SECTION TWO OF
THIS BILL ARE MAKING HERE.
AND THE COURT REJECTED THOSE
ARGUMENTS THE COURT FOUND THAT
THE PUBLIC POLICY UNDERLYING
HOMEOWNER INTERESTS AND
HOMEOWNERRIGHTS.
AND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LITIGATION
JUSTIFIED THESE VOTING
REQUIREMENTS THE COURT WENT ON
TO ADD THAT THE MINIMAL
INCONVENIENCE TO AN H. O. WAY OF
HAVING TO CONDUCT A VOTE BEFORE
EMBARKING.
ON WHAT IS A HUGE STEP IN FILING
A CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LAWSUIT IS
OUTWEIGHED BY THE BENEFITS THAT
IS A FORTY TO THE HOMEOWNERS OF
THESE VOTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT TAKES IN MY THIRD POINT
THIS REALLY IS ABOUT THE
HOMEOWNERS AND I KNOW YOU'RE
PROBABLY ALL LOOKING AT ME
SAYING YOU'RE A BUILDER ATTORNEY
WHAT DO YOU CARE ABOUT THE
HOMEOWNERS WELL I'LL TELL YOU.
BUILDERS DO CARE ABOUT THEIR
HOMEOWNERS AND BUILDERS CARE
ABOUT PROTECTING THEIR
HOMEOWNERS FROM ROW BOARDS AND
FROM AMBITIOUS PLAINTIFFS
LAWYERS.
BUILDERS DON'T WANT THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO GOING TO
LITIGATION BUILDER BUILDERS
DON'T WANT THEIR HOMES TO GO
INTO LITIGATION LITIGATION
DOESN'T HELP ANYBODY BUT THE
ATTORNEYS.
ANY RESULTS IF AN INCREASE
HOUSING COSTS IN AND ALL READY.
ON AFFORDABLE ENVIRONMENT IN
MARYLAND THE VOTE PROVISION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL IT DOES
IS PROVIDE CHECKS AND BALANCES
ON IT H. O. WAYS OF FORTY TO ACT
WHEN IT PERTAINS TO THINGS THAT
THAT AFFECT THE MEMBERS AND THAT
AFFECT THE MEMBERS SEPARATE
INTERESTS.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS PROVISIONS
AND PROJECTS CCAR'S THEIR
RESTRICTED NATURE WAYS ABILITY
TO ACT.
AND JUST BECAUSE THESE DOCUMENTS
ARE PREPARED BY THE HOME
BUILDERS DOESN'T MEAN HE'S
PROVISIONS ARE BAD IT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY'RE ON FAIR AND IT
CERTAINLY DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
DON'T BENEFIT THE HOMEOWNERS
BECAUSE THEY DO.
AND WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES WHY
ARE WE SINGLING OUT VOTING
REQUIREMENTS ONLY FOR
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LITIGATION
NOT FOR ANY OTHER KIND OF
LITIGATION NOT FOR ANY OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON A MAJOR WAYS
ABILITY TO ACT PARTICULARLY WHEN
IT PERTAINS TO SEPARATE
INTERESTS MATTERS. FOR DOING IT
BECAUSE THE LAWYERS ARE TRYING
TO MAKE IT EASIER TO GET THESE
CASES INTO LITIGATION.
THERE'S NOTHING PRO BUILDER
ABOUT THE VOTING REQUIREMENTS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE HAS SCRUTINIZE THESE
PROVISIONS FOR YEARS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE FAIR.
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO PUT
PROVISIONS IN THAT REQUIRE MORE
THAN A SIMPLE MAJORITY THE 80%
FIGURE WHICH I HEARD I'VE NOT
SEEN IN MY ENTIRE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF PRACTICE.
THE D. R. E. WILL NOT LET WILL
NOT ALLOW VOTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT EXCEED A 51% SIMPLE
MAJORITY THE D. R. A. WILL NOT
LEAD BUILDER REPRESENTATIVES
PARTICIPATE IN THE VOTE.
THE G. R. E. WILL NOT LET VOTE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY TO PRE
LITIGATION PROCEDURES THEY ONLY
APPLY TO LITIGATION ALL OF THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THE PROPONENTS
OF SECTION TWO OF THIS BILLS
SEEK.
ARE ALREADY IN EXISTENCE AND THE
BILL GOES TOO FAR.
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LITIGATION
IS A HUGE DEAL FOR HOMEOWNERS IT
HAS.
IT HAS TREMENDOUS NEGATIVE
IMPACTS IT CREATES DIMINUTION IN
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY.
THEY HAVE DISCLOSURE OBLIGATIONS
BUYERS CAN'T GET FINANCING
EXISTING HOME OWNERS CAN'T GET
REFINANCING IT'S A HUGE DEAL FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND THEY DESERVE TO
HAVE A SAY.
BEFORE WHAT IS IN MOST CASES
THEIR SINGLE LARGEST ASSET IS
THROWN INTO LITIGATION.
BY SOMEONE ON THEIR BEHALF
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
I KNOW IT'S A LAWSUIT CLAIMING
THAT THEIR PROPERTY IS DEFECTIVE
THEY DESERVE TO HAVE A SAY IN
THIS AND THAT'S ALL THE VOTING
REQUIREMENT DOES A AND I'LL
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS THOUGHT.
IN THIS.
DAY AND AGE OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SECTION TWO OF
THIS BILL TAKES A HUGE STEP
BACKWARDS.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT ALLOWS A
SELECT FEW THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS? TO IN AN EXECUTIVE
SESSION.
IN SECRECY OUTSIDE THE PRESENCE
OF THE MEMBERSHIP. TO MAKE A
DECISION TO INITIATE
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LITIGATION A
DECISION WHICH IS GOING TO HAVE
HUGE RAMIFICATIONS AS OUR COURT
OF APPEAL NOTED IN THE BRANCHES
CASE.
ON THE INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS AND
BEAR IN MIND THAT THE THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS IS DOING THIS UNDER
THE AUSPICES MISTER BEFORE WE
LOSE A QUORUM I LIKE TO JUST
TAKE A MOMENT ESTABLISH A QUORUM
[inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
CHIU HERE TO HEAR DEEP DEEP HERE
GABRIELLE.
GLORIA GLORIA HERE KILEY KILEY
HERE THE MONTH.
THE MONTH HERE MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA WE HAVE A QUORUM AND SIR
IT LIKE TO ASK IF YOU COULD WRAP
UP SHORTLY IF YOU CAN YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WELL.
WHAT SECTION TWO OF THIS BILL
DOES IS IT ALLOWS A SELECT GROUP
OF INDIVIDUALS IN AN EXECUTIVE
SESSION IN SECRECY OUTSIDE THE
PRESENCE OF THE HOMEOWNERS? TO
MAKE A DECISION UNILATERALLY
THAT WILL IMPACT THOSE
HOMEOWNERS AND THEIR INVESTMENT
FOR YEARS TO COME.
AND BEAR IN MIND THAT THEY'RE
MAKING THAT DECISION UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF ADVICE OF COUNSEL.
COUNSEL WHO DOESN'T REPRESENT
THE HOMEOWNERS WHO ONLY
REPRESENTS THE H. AWAY AND ITS
BOARD MEMBERS.
THE ONLY PROTECTION TO
HOMEOWNERS HAVE IS THE VOTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC --
ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SEEN ON LET'S BRING BACK TO
DISCUSSION -- COLLEAGUES ANY
[inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR -- FOR ENGAGING
IN THIS CONVERSATION I KNOW THIS
IS BEEN A PASSION OF YOURS
CERTAINLY AFTER THE TRAGEDY.
IN RECENT YEARS AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND AND
MOVING -- WHAT YOU DID A FEW
YEARS AGO IN THE CONTEXT OF --
THE APARTMENT BUILDINGS THAT
REQUIRED INSPECTIONS ABOUT
KINNEY'S TO PROTECTIONS AND
COMMON INTERESTS DEVELOPMENTS.
I ALSO DO THINK.
THAT YOU HAVE STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE -- HERE WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING WHAT HAS BEEN A BIT
OF A POISON PILL I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT OF THE
AUTHOR WITH C. B. I A AND OTHERS
IN OUR OFFICE -- I KNOW IT TOOK
A BIT OF TIME BUT I THINK THAT
THE CONCLUSION POLITICALLY TO
PROTECT -- THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEDIATION AND ALTERNATIVE
DISPUTE RESOLUTION MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE -- CERTAINLY HERE --
AND APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE OPPONENT -- BUT WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT -- EVERY RESIDENT
IN ONE OF THESE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS WILL RECEIVE NOTICE
OF THE DECISION MADE BY THE
BOARD -- AND SO WITH THAT I AM
PREPARED -- TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY -- ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION WITH THE
BILLS ARE SECOND.
THERE'S BEEN A SECOND.
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
FINAL AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND OUR THANKS
TO BE A FOR WORKING.
DILIGENTLY HARD FEE AND IT
SOMETIMES -- IN A VERY DIFFICULT --
MANNER AND IT -- A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING FOR I THINK ALL OF
US AND BUT IT WORKED AT THE END
IN AND THEY'VE DONE A GREAT JOB
AND THEY DO REPRESENT -- THE
BUILDERS OF THE STATE AND I I
RESPECT THEM FOR THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
AS WELL THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY TO HI CHIU I DEEP.
I GABRIELLE GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY NO LIMóN.
LIMóN I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES YOU NEED ONE
MORE TO GET IT OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN UNTIL OTHER MEMBERS AWRY
FEATURED THANK YOU CALLING.
IT VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER.
OUR NEXT ITEMS WILL BE.
PRESENTED BY CENTERS WHITE HOUSE
SKI ODDS ITEMS TWO AND FIVE I'LL
SOON MAYBE I'LL TAKE FILE ITEM
TO FIRST IN THE FOLLOWER SB
THIRTEEN S. [inaudible]
SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS -- MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING TO PROPOSE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS -- THIS IS SIDE SB
THIRTEEN WHICH IS ADDRESSES SOME
OF THE TOP EREADERS -- TO EIGHTY
YOU DEVELOPMENTS WHICH HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING A TO INCLUDE -- REDUCING
IMPACT FEES -- STRENGTHENING --
THE HOUSING COMING DEVELOPMENT
OVERSIGHT ELIMINATING OWNER
OCCUPANCY AND PROVIDING A SAFE
PATH FOR ALLOWING I'M PERMITTED
EIGHTY USE BROUGHT UP TO CODE.
I WANT TO ASSURE EVERYBODY ON
THE COMMITTEE THAT THESE THAT
THE CHECKS AND THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL IS NOT MADE UP IN A
VACUUM IT'S PART OF THE HEARINGS
THAT WERE HELD BETWEEN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND THE
HOUSING BETWEEN DEVELOPMENT.
IDENTIFYING SPECIFICALLY WHAT
ARE THE BARRIERS THAT STILL
EXIST -- TO EIGHTY YOU
DEVELOPMENT WE HAVESIGNIFICANT
STUDIES THAT IT FROM PLACES LIKE
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ AND UC
BERKELEY TO TURN A REPORT THAT'S
QUOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT HAVE
SHOWN THAT DEVELOPMENT FEES.
ARE EXCESSIVELY HIGH FOR EIGHTY
USE FOR INSTANCE UC BERKELEY
FOUND THAT SOME LOCALITIES ARE
CHARGING AS MUCH AS FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PR UNIT.
AND THAT NUMBER DOESN'T EVEN
INCLUDE THE IMPACT FEES CHARGED
BY UTILITY COMPANIES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OTHER DISTRICTS.
SO MANY HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO
BILL NEEDY YOU ARE SIMPLY
STOPPED IN THEIR TRACKS WHEN
THEY'RE HANDED THESE -- THESE
FEE REQUEST EIGHTY USER BUILT ON
LOTS THAT HAVE ALREADY PAID
THEIR DEVELOPMENT FEES WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN A SERIES OF FORTY
YEARS WE HAVE THEIR CALL
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES.
AND WHEN WE HAD LANGUAGE THAT
USES SECONDARY UNIT CITIES AND
COUNTIES SAID -- THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS A NEW
STRUCTURE SO WE'RE GONNA CHARTS
AND THE WHOLE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
FEE AND WE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
AND CITIES ALLOWED OUT WERE
ALLOWED TO DO IT.
WILL.
THE CITY OF LIVERMORE IT'S TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
IMPACT FEE AND WE WONDER WHY
WE'RE HAVING PROBLEMS BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO THEY JUST
PASS IT ON AND PART OF THE
DEFINITIONAL CHANGED EXCESS READ
WALLING UNITS WAS.
TO REMIND PEOPLE AND CLARIFY
THAT THESE ARE EXCESS RE TO THE
HOUSE THAT IS ALREADY PAID THEIR
IMPACT FEES -- HOMEOWNER SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO PAY THEM AGAIN SINCE
THEY PAID WHEN THEY BOUGHT THE
HOUSE A LITTLE ON PAY THE AMOUNT
THAT'S BEING CHARGED ON THE
PRIMARY UNIT.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN THE
FACT THAT A HOMEOWNER CAN EXPAND
THEIR HOUSE FOR A BEDROOM A
KITCHEN A BATHROOM AND THEY
WOULD PAY NO.
IMPACT FEES I THINK I TESTIFIED
LAST YEAR MY WIFE AND I BUILT A
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOOT ADDITION
TO OUR HOUSE IT WAS A ONE DAY
PERMIT.
WOULD PUT IN ANOTHER KITCHEN
ANOTHER -- SINK IN THE KITCHEN A
SECOND STOVE A BRAND NEW
BATHROOM AND EXPANDED.
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FEET NO
IMPACT FEES MINISTERIAL IN THE
APPROVAL.
THE OPTION OPPOSITION WILL SAY
AND I WANT TO ADDRESS THIS THAT
WE SHOULD WAIT FOR THE STUDY ON
THE GRAYSON LEGISLATION THAT IS
DUE LATER ON THIS MONTH.
BUT I'VE CALLED -- THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THEY
HAVE TOLD ME.
THAT EIGHTY USE ARE NOT WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THE SURVEY SO EVEN
IF THEY ARE YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT I'VE TALKED TO THE
CHAIR -- AND THE OTHER EIGHTY
YOU BILLS THAT ARE PROGRESSING
IN THE THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE
LOOK FOR A RECONCILIATION AND IF
THERE'S IS LANGUAGE IN THERE
WHICH I DON'T EXPECT THAT I WILL.
I WILL YOU KNOW -- COOPERATE
WITH A RECONCILIATION OF THOSE
NUMBERS WITH THE CHAIRS
ASSISTANCE.
ANOTHER ELEMENT OF THIS BILL IS
THAT.
SB THIRTEEN PROHIBITS OWNER
OCCUPANCY ORDINANCES WHICH
REQUIRED THAT THE OWNER LIVE
EITHER ON THE EIGHTY YOU OR IN
THE PRIMARY UNIT.
BUT THERE'S THIS UNFOUNDED FEAR
THAT INVESTORS ARE BUYING HOUSES
JUST TO BUILD EIGHTY USED TO
RENT THEM OUT.
AND IN REALITY STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT THE MAJORITY OF
EIGHTY USE ARE BUILT BY
HOMEOWNERS TO HOUSE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS THE CITY OF PORTLAND DID
THE DID A SURVEY OF ONE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY USE.
AND FOUND THAT ONLY 10% OF THEM
WERE BUILT BY INVESTORS.
OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIRES
REQUIREMENTS LIMIT THE MARKET
BILL DVD USE AND PREVENTS THE
CONSTRUCTIONS OF THEM THE BANKS
OPPOSE THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
BECAUSE IF THE HOUSE GOES INTO
FORECLOSURE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
MECHANISM TO TAKE OCCUPANCY IN
ORDER TO OWN THE HOUSE -- DO WE
WE DEVELOP REAL PROPERTY LOSS
THAT WE HAVE TRANSFER BUILDING
IT'S EASY IT'S WE WANT TO HAVE
CLEAR TITLE AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THE TRANSFER ABILITY OF PROPERTY.
THERE'S NO OTHER TYPE OF
RESIDENTIAL UNITS THAT HAVE
RESTRICTIONS ON ON OUR OCCUPANCY
FOUR PLEX APARTMENT COMPLEXES
NONE.
SO -- WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
REMAINING -- BARRIERS TO EIGHTY
YOU CONSTRUCTIONS EIGHTY USER
SMALL.
BUT THEY PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN -- A TRIP ALLEVIATING THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN WITH ME I HAVE.
NEWS BURKE WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL AND I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
HERE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL REPRESENT THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS.
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
REGION.
AND IF YOU TALK TO OUR SEALS
HOUSING AND THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS IS THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM
WE HAVE IN THE REGION FOR
TRACKING RETAINING WORKERS.
THIS HOUSING CRISIS IS CAUSED BY
THE LACK OF SUPPLY.
WE NEED EIGHTY USE TO HELP FILL
THAT GAP SB THIRTEEN IS
IMPORTANT BILL TO HELP EXPEDITE
EIGHTY USE THESE ARE HOUSING
UNITS FOR TEACHERS.
STUDENTS NURSES GRANDPARENTS.
AND OTHERS NUMBER.
TWO WE TALK ABOUT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND HOW WE WANT TO DO
BETTER FOR THE CLIMATE WE NEED
TO REALLY EXPAND UPON INFILL
HOUSING.
SB THIRTEEN WILL HELP US DO THAT.
AND LASTLY GOING HERE TODAY
ABOUT FOR ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL.
SB THIRTEEN AS A LOW CONTROL
BILL IT GIVES THE CONTROL BACK
TO THE PROPERTY OWNER OF LOCAL
YOU CAN GET.
SO GIVE HOMEOWNERS BACK CONTROL
OF THEIR PROPERTY PLEASE SUPPORT
SB THRTEEN TODAY.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
MR CHEN MEMBERS AARON EVANS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA A AND B.
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SPECTRUM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SYLVIA OFFERING
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
BETTER CALL VOTE WITH THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION AND SUPPORT.
DOES SOMEONE ELSE GIVE THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CORNISH CHAIR MEMBERS CHASE
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES.
WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY POSE LESS
AMENDED WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SENATOR AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE IT -- ARE STICKING
POINT REALLY REMAINS THAT THE
FEES AND I ON CALL LISTEN IN AND
YOU KNOW I CAN KERR WITH A LOT
OF WHAT THE SENATOR SAID AROUND
THE FEES IN THAT THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW HIGH IN SOME SITUATIONS
AND AND REALLY IT'S A FUNCTION
OF MITIGATION FEE ACTS SO -- THE
FEE ISN'T OR EXCUSE ME THE THE
REPORT IS IMPORTANT AND WHILE
THE REPORT DOES NOT DIRECTLY
ADDRESS EIGHTY USE -- I DON'T IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT IT THAT IT
WOULD SINCE IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT AND HOW WE
APPLY THAT WHEN WE IMPOSE A FEE
AND THOSE FEES ARE PRIDE BROADLY
TO ANY TYPE OF CONSTRUCTION --
SO IT IS A LITTLE UNNECESSARY TO
FOCUS ON A SINGLE FAMILY AND
MULTI FAMILY -- EIGHTY USE IT'LL
ALL BE CAPTURED IN THAT SO --
YOU KNOW IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD HOW MANY WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO CONTAIN THE CONVERSATION
ON FEES THAT WE CAN HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE FEE STRUCTURE -- IF
WE ARE ANY PEOPLE TO THE
COMMUNITY THERE WILL BE IMPACTS
AND WE AS AN APPROPRIATE WAY TO
TO ADDRESSES IMPACTS WITH THAT
WE REQUEST TO A NOBLE.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THEM JUST GO GAGA
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SANITATION AGENCIES HERE
TODAY WITH AN OPPOSE AND LAST
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL.
OUR ISSUE IS VERY NARROW AND IT
RELATES TO CONNECTION AND
CAPACITY FEES FOR WATER AND
SEWER SERVICE -- WE'RE
REQUESTING AN AMENDMENT TO
CLARIFY THAT THE IMPACT FEE
LIMITATIONS DO NOT APPLY TO
CONNECTION CAPACITY CHARGES FOR
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE.
THESE CHARGES ARE REQUIRED TO BE
ASSESSED PROPORTIONATELY BY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION ANDERS --
PROP TWO EIGHTEEN AND PROP
TWENTY SIX THEY ARE ALREADY
THERE ARE ALREADY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE CAN
ASSESS THESE FEES -- THAT
FORMULA WAS DECIDED BY SB TEN
SIXTY NINE IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE MOMENT WE'RE
SEEKING WOULD CLARIFY THAT ARE
FEES REMAIN SUBJECT TO THAT%
FORMULA ESTABLISHED UNDER SB
SIXTY NINE SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AS THE BILL
MOVES INTO THE NEXT MANY.
ME ASK IF THERE IS OTHER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
HAVE YOU GOT TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES SENSATION
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE SIKASSO JUST ADD WE
WOULD AGREE WITH THE CENTER THAT
RECONCILIATION OF THE OTHER
EIGHTY YOU BILLS IS.
A GOOD IDEA WE HAVE COME TO
AGREEMENT WITH MISTER TEEING ON
AB SIXTY EIGHT THAT AMENDS THE
SAME EXACT CODE SECTION ON
CONNECTION FEES.
AND WOULD URGE THE WORKING ON
THIS BILL IN THE SUMMER FASHION
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES CAUCUS I WILL ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THAT FROM THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES LOOK
FOR TO THE EACH CITY REPORT
COMING OUT LATER THIS MONTH I
HAVE AN OPPOSED LAST MINUTE
POSITION AT THIS.
TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DAVID JONES OF
HALF OF BURBANK IN SAN MARCOS IN
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS ALL THIS TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
CAMERA AT THOUSAND OAKS RANCHO
CUCAMONGA AND TORRANCE IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING BROWN'S ROSS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY POST
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES I JUST LIKE TO
REFLECT THE COMMENTS MADE BY.
COSTS AND SEEM YOU A AND LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF THANK YOU.
HUSSEIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RUSSELL NOVAK ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA --
RELUCTANTLY ENDS OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
KAREN LYING ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THEIR OPPOSITION OF
WAS ACUTELY FOCUSED ON THE
CONCERNS ABOUT CODE ENFORCEMENT
BEING ABLE -- TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST EIGHTY USE THAT WERE
LIFE AND SAFETY THREATS AND IT'S
BASED ON HOW THEIR LOCAL
ORDINANCES CONSTRUCTED SO THERE
OPPOSE FOR THIS REASON THANK YOU
[inaudible]
REGULAR.
REGULATE YELLOW WITH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF ELDORADO THE REGRESSION
DISTRICT AND THAT'S OUR WATER
AGENCY -- OR CLIENTS HAVE IN A
POST ON THE SUMMIT THAT. TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU -- TWENTY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO
SHOULD NOT MISS THE SUPPORT LINE
BUT JUST ONE CLEAR FOR THE WORD
SUPPORT SB.
THIRTEEN LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
MISTER GORE I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE THE AUTHOR FOR THE COMMENT
THAT DON'T QUESTION I HAD WAS TO
BE EXTENDED THIS IS A DYNAMIC
SITUATION THERE'S COMPETE
LEGISLATION AND THERE'S THIS
STUDY THAT.
YOU'RE NOT HELPFUL FOR I'VE BEEN
IN THAT SAME BOAT TOO BUT YOU
KNOW HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL RIGHT --
BUT YOUR OVERALL COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO SORT OF GRIND OUT
THIS ISSUE AND MAKE SURE WE TAKE
SOME DECISIVE ACTION IS
PERSONALLY MEANINGFUL TO ME.
KNOWLEDGE I'M A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL WHICH I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH YOU
ON THIS -- EIGHTY IS NOT GONNA
BE THIS -- THE CURE ALL FOR
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
I THINK THE FEES THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING ARE ABSOLUTELY
IMPACTFUL WHETHER NOT PEOPLE
CHOOSE TO PROCEED WITH A NOT.
A NOT A MAN TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE SIDEWALK IS THE BILL THE
VOTE HAS BEEN LAID -- THE POWER
LINES HAVE BEEN INSTALLED -- YOU
KNOW IS SHERRY WITH MY COLLEAGUE
YOU KNOW MY GRANDMOTHER LIVES IN
A SINGLE FAMILY HOME WAS BUILT
SEVENTY YEARS AGO BY HERSELF SHE
MOVED OUT TOMORROW.
AT A LOCAL FAMILY MOVED IN THE
NEXT DAY THEY WOULD NOT BE
ASSESSED ANYTHING EXTRA FOR THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE TO AND
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES TAKE ACTIONS THAT
WILL PUT MORE AND MORE ROOFS
OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS AT PRICES
THEY CAN AFFORD WELL MISTER
RIGHT WITH SENATORS DOING IS A
NATURALLY AFFORDABLE PRODUCT.
I'M BY NATURE OF ITS DESIGN AND
LOCATION -- THIS IS WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE PUSHING TO
DO -- AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS AGAIN TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE RAISED -- IN THE DYNAMIC
NATURE THE SITUATION BUT OVERALL
I THINK THIS IS A NO BRAINER I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
MR MEASURE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THEIR WORK HOURS HE IN IN IN IN
IN YOUR COMMENT YOU KNOW -- AND
THAT WAS ALSO A JUST REWRITE --
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER GLORIA THE
YOU SAID THAT.
DE THE ORIGINAL HOMEOWNER.
ALREADY PAVE ALL THE THE LOCAL
IMPACT FEES SIDEWALKS OF THE
STREET LAMPS.
OF MY MY MY CONCERN OF COMING
FROM A SPECIAL DISTRICT UP
BACKGROUND IS THE CONNECTION
FEES ON WHEN.
WHEN?
YOU HAVE NEW TENANTS -- IT'S
ASSUME THAT -- INCREASING VOLUME
OF TO SEE WHICH CONNECTIONS WILL
WILL WILL WILL GO UP AND AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT A TO
BE FAIR FOR THE EFFORT SANITARY
DISTRICT OR SOMETHING THAT YOU
SHOULD REALLY CONSIDER.
IN ALLOWING THEM TO AT LEAST BE
ABLE TO RECOVER -- THAT -- THAT
COSTS -- MINIMALLY JUST JUST TO
BE ABLE TO A CONNECTS OF THAT
EIGHTY USED TO THE TO THE SEWAGE
LATERAL -- AND AT THE LAST BUT
MY COUNTY -- VICE CHAIR THROUGH
THE THROUGH THE CHAIR IS --
CLEARLY I WILL WORK WITH THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS SO WITH THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS WHEN
THERE'S THERE'S AN IMPACT FEE
AND THEN THERE'S CONNECTION FEE
CURRENTLY AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING WE WROTE TEN SIXTY
NINE AND WE SAID.
CAN BE THE FEE COULD BE
PROPORTIONAL TO WHAT THE THE
MOTHER HOUSE IS IF RIGHT NOW IF
THE IF YOU'RE CONNECTING TO THE
MAIN LINE IN THE SIDEWALK THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT.
TO CHARGE FOR THAT CONNECTION
FEE IF I'M RUNNING A LINE FROM
THE EIGHTY YOU TO MY HOUSE
THAT'S A PLUMBER I PAY I PAY THE
THE PLUMBER FOR FOR THAT THING
THOSE.
ENVIRONMENTAL FEES AND ALL THOSE
OTHER FEES THAT YOU PAY TO THE
EVERY JURISDICTION THOSE I'M NOT
I'M JUST TALK TALKING ABOUT THE
THE LARGE IMPACT FEE THAT'S A NO
LOOK.
LOOK NO LOOK CHART SO -- I AGREE
WITH YOU AND AGREE WITH THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA IS THAT
AS THIS SHOULD.
EARN YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND THE
BILL PROCEEDS THAT I'M ABLE TO
CONTINUE HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOUR HI.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO HAVE BILLS
IN THE SENATE TO TO WORK ON
RECONCILING -- SELLING IT BUT I
AM SENSITIVE TO THE THE ACTUAL
FEES FOR WORK VERSUS JUST THE
IMPACT THAT'S A SORT OF A NO
LOOK ABOVE THE LINE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
GREAT LET ME -- IT PROVIDE A FEW
OF MY OWN THOUGHTS FOR SOME MAY
THINK THE SENATOR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON EIGHTY YOU POLICY
YOU'VE BEEN.
TOILING AWAY AT THIS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND AND REALLY
HELPING TO MOVE EIGHTY USED TO
THE FOREFRONT OF BEING A MAJOR
SOLUTION FOR HOUSING CRISIS AND
THEIR MANY ASPECTS OF THIS BILL
THAT I THINK ARE VERY NON
CONTROVERSIAL.
BUT TAKE SIGNIFICANT STEPS
AROUND OWNER OCCUPANCY PARKING
THE SIZE LOCATIONS OF EIGHTY IS
SO WHEN I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AS I THINK WE ALL KNOW THERE IS
ONE MAJOR ISSUE IN THIS BILL
THAT.
CREATES A LOT OF HEARTBURN AND
THAT IS AROUND FEES -- AND LET
ME SAY THIS -- TWO THOUGHTS
WHICH IS I HAVE PUBLICLY STATED
THAT I DO THINK WE NEED TO DO
SIGNIFICANTLY REFORM ACROSS THE
BOARD INCLUDING IN THE AREAS OF
EIGHTY USE OF DIRECTIONALLY I AM
SUPPORTIVE -- THAT BEING SAID I
A AS WE'VE DISCUSSED I AM NOT
YET CONVINCED THAT WHAT YOU HAVE
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL AROUND
EIGHTY YOU FEE REDUCTION IS
EXACT LEE RIGHT FORMULA -- I
THINK THEIR NUMBER POTENTIAL
NUANCES THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
CREATE AND THINK ABOUT DEPENDING
ON THE DISTRICTS DEPENDING ON
THE TYPES OF JURISDICTION --
WHETHER 25% IS THE RIGHT NUMBER
MAYBE IT SHOULD BE LARGER -- BUT
ALL THAT BEING SAID -- LAST YEAR
IN THIS COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THE
SAME BILL AND I'D ASK YOU TO
TAKE THOSE PROVISIONS OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE DID REMOVE THOSE
PROVISIONS.
IN PART BECAUSE WE WERE AWAITING
THE RESULTS OF A STUDY THAT IS
GOING TO COME OUT IN A WEEK.
THIS YEAR I FEEL A BIT
DIFFERENTLY I DO THINK IT IS
RIGHT FOR US TO TACKLE THIS THIS
YEAR I THINK WE NEED TO ADDRESS
AT THIS YEAR -- RATHER THAN
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
AMENDMENTS MAKES SENSE HERE AND
THEN HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
REPLICATE ITSELF IN A FEW WEEKS
IN THE LOCAL GOV COMMITTEE --
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
YOU AND I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH THE TWO OF US.
AS WELL AS OTHER AUTHORS OF A DO
YOU BILLS TO REALLY WANTS THAT
REPORT COMES OUT -- TO PROVIDE A
RATIONAL STRUCTURE ACROSS ALL OF
THE VARIOUS FEE REDUCTION
PROPOSALS -- TO ADDRESSES SO MY
SUPPORT THIS BILL TO DAY -- I I
WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY IT IS
CONDITIONAL ARE BASED ON ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AND AND I KNOW WE
WILL HAVE MANY OF THOSE AROUND
HOW WE ENSURE.
THAT WE PRODUCE EIGHTY YEARS BUT
ALSO PROVIDING RESIDENTS THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED SO --
APPRECIATE THE SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS UNITE HAD ON THIS
AND THE WORK WILL CONTINUE BUT
AT LEAST I THINK FOR PURPOSES OF
THIS COMMITTEE IT DOES MAKE
SENSE FOR THIS BILL TO CONTINUE
ON SO LISTENING TO OTHER
QUESTIONS.
I'LL RETURN IT BACK TO THE
CENTER I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE GREAT -- THERE
HAS BEEN A MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
TO ME THIS FORTY SECOND.
THERE'S BEEN A SECOND AND THAT
WITH THAT MADAM.
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHIU HI.
HI DAVE HI I GABRIELLE GLORIA
AYE GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY IDEALLY MON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA AYE QUIRK SILVA I
YOU HAVE VOTES GET OUT WILL WAIT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND
WITHOUT CENTER YOU HAVE FILE
ITEM.
FIVE SB.
THREE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU A
FIVE IF [inaudible]
MEMBERS COULD.
TURN TO PAGE SEVEN OF THE STAFF
ANALYSIS MAY BE HELPFUL BECAUSE
MOST OF MY COMMENTS WILL BE --
GEARED TOWARDS THE S. COMMITTEE
SECOND AMENDMENT BUT FIRST OFF
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M AGREE
TO ACCEPT THE FIRST AMENDMENT IT
CONTAINS THE ANALYSIS.
I'M UNABLE -- TO EXCEPT THE
SECOND COMMITTEE AMENDMENT --
NOT ONLY BECAUSE I'M TO LOSE THE
SUPPORT OF THE THE ADVOCATES
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING IN THIS
AREA FOR FOR YEARS -- BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THE BILL
WILL BE LEFT OVER -- TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE NOW A PROPERTY MANAGER
IS THE RIGHT ARM OF A OF THE
BOARD AND I'VE HEARD TOO MANY
STORIES FROM THE FROM THE
ADVOCATES OF INSTANCES -- WHICH
THE PROPERTY OWNER HAS COLLUDED
WITH A CORRUPT AND DYSFUNCTIONAL
BOARD AND LET'S.
JUST THROW IT OUT THERE THERE'S
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT THOUSANDS OF THESE THINGS
BUT ENOUGH OUR DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES HERS IMPORTANT ENOUGH
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO IMPROVE
THIS AND GET IT RIGHT -- THIS IS
PEOPLE THAT ARE EFFECTIVE ARE
OUR OUR RESIDENTS.
REQUIRING THAT THE INSPECTOR OF
ELECTIONS ONLY BE PAID FOR
ELECTION WERE IS ESSENTIAL FOR
MAINTAINING THE INTEGRITY OF
THESE ELECTIONS THE H. O. WAYS
NOW FUNCTION AS THE FACT THOUGH
CITY COUNCIL SAID WITH AFFECTING
PEOPLE'S.
RIGHTS IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
COSTS.
NOT ONLY THIS IS THE OPPOSITION
STATED.
BEFORE IN ANOTHER IT H. AWAY
LEGISLATION THAT THE COST OF AN
ELECTION IS ONE TO TWO DOLLARS
PER UNIT LET'S CALL IT THREE
UNITS THE STAFF REPORT CLEARLY
WALKS OUT THAT MOTION.
MOST OF THESE ARE LESS THAN
FIFTY UNITS SO IT'S NOT A BIG
CHUNK OF MONEY -- BUT THEY'RE
ALSO LOW COST ALTERNATIVE
PROVIDERS IF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS AND OTHER CIVIC MINDED
NONPROFITS AS POINTED OUT IN THE
ACTUAL TAX OF SECTION FIVE FIVE
ONE WHICH SAYS WHICH CALLS FOR
THE INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY --
MAYBE A MEMBER OF THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION SO YOU CAN HAVE A
MEMBER THAT WHAT WANT TO DO THE
ELECTION BUT NOT A DIRECTOR A
CANDIDATE -- FOR DIRECTOR AND OR
BE RELATED TO DIRECTOR
CANDIDATES DIRECTOR AND THE
AGAIN SECTION FIVE ONE ONE ZERO
SAYS THE INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY --
MAY NOT BE A PERSON BUSINESS
ENTITY OR SUB DIVISION OF THE
BUSINESS ENTITY WHO IS CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED -- UNDER CONTRACT TO
THE ASSOCIATION FOR ANY
COMPENSABLE SERVICES THEN THEY
HAVE THAT MAGIC UNLESS THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION.
OUR AGREES BY BOTH TO DO IT SO
SO THE BASIS OF THE LAW IS THAT
WE WANT TO HAVE THIS INDEPENDENT
WE PUT IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HOPING -- TO
REMOVE HERE.
HI.
I SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THIS
BILL IS NEARER THAN LAST YEAR'S
BILL I WHICH PASSED THE THIS
COMMITTEE AND I'LL JUST GO OVER
THEM I'VE REMOVED THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS FROM LAST YEAR'S BILL I
DELETED THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
VOTE COUNTING.
LOCATION BE ACCESSIBLE IN NEAR
THE H. AWAY PROPERTY AND I'VE
ALLEVIATED ALL CONCERNS FROM THE
BUILDING -- INDUSTRY WHO WAS
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION.
AND WITH ME IS -- JUDGE TOM SIR
WITH THE CENTER OF CALIFORNIA H.
AWAY LAW AND IT REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR AT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION LAW IS THE ONE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS.
ADVOCATES FOR THE RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS IN NATURE
WAYS -- THE CENTER HAS
PARTICIPATED IN THE PERSON OF
MARJORIE MURRAY OUR FOUNDING
PRESIDENT.
IN THE WRITING OF THE
LEGISLATION MUCH OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT PROTECTS THE
RIGHTS OF HOMEOWNERS INCLUDING
IN THE AREA OF ELECTIONS.
I BECAME A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE AND GOT
INVOLVED IN THIS KIND OF WORK.
AFTER I MOVED INTO RETIRED FROM
THE COURT AND MOVED INTO A LARGE
SENIOR.
A COMMUNITY GOVERNED BY AN H.
AWAY AND LEARNED. TO BY SURPRISE
THAT HI MY ASSUMPTION THAT I
WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THE SELF GOVERNANCE OF THAT
ORGANIZATION JUST LIKE I HAD THE
AND CITY GOVERNMENTS -- WHEREVER
I HAVE LIVED -- AND I QUICKLY
LEARNED THAT THAT WAS.
AN UNWARRANTED ASSUMPTION.
I'D NOTE THAT THE EXERCISE OF
THE RIGHT. TO ELECT A BOARD AND
TO RUN FOR THAT BOARD IS THOUGH
SINGLE.
SOVEREIGN ACT THAT A MEMBER IS
AVAIL HAS IS AVAILABLE TO IN A
TO AN INDIVIDUAL MEMBER
[inaudible]
EVERY.
OPPOSED CHANGE IN THE LAW IN
THIS BILL.
IS BASED UPON.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS THAT THE CENTER
RECEIVED FROM ALL AROUND THE
STATE WE HAVE MEMBERS FROM ALL
AROUND.
EVERY COUNTY.
AND WE TAKE THESE COMPLAINTS AND
ANALYZE THEM AND TRY TO WORK ON
FIXES. FOR THESE COMPLAINTS.
AND SO THAT IS THE ORIGIN OF THE
LEGISLATION IT'S COMPLAINTS FROM.
PEOPLE AROUND THE STATE WHO HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH.
OF THE ABUSE OF POWER BY THEIR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS THAT IS THE
ORIGIN.
AND SO THE QUESTION BEFORE YOU
IS REALLY.
UP.
MAY WE MOVE FORWARD TO FIX THE
FLAWS IN THE EXISTING LAW.
AND TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE ELECTION PROCESS.
AND SO I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIDGE THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE.
BUT TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- WE'VE WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE NOW FOR TWO YEARS -- WITH
SENATOR IN INTO APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE TO THE BILL SINCE LAST YEAR.
BUT WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS BILL
IS SIGNIFICANTLY SIMILAR TO THE
BILL THAT WAS GOT VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN LAST YEAR FOR
BEING A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH WHERE THE AUTHOR STATE
THAT.
HOW WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF ASSOCIATIONS?
THAT HAVE TROUBLE WITH THEIR
ELECTIONS THERE'S OVER FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND ASSOCIATIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THOSE ELECTIONS HAPPEN ON A
REGULAR BASIS THEIR FAIR THEIR
TRANSPARENT WE HAVE ONE OF THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE.
SET OF ELECTION LAWS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN THE
NATION IT'S IN THE DAVIS
STIRLING ACT AS WELL AS IN THE
CORPORATION'S CODE BECAUSE THESE
PUBLIC NOT FOR PROFIT
CORPORATIONS ARE GOVERNED BY
BOTH SECTIONS OF THE CODE.
SB TWELVE SIXTY FIVE WAS NEARBY
AS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL AS IT WAS
STATED.
WITH FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
ASSOCIATIONS AND STATE 70% OF
THEM ARE FIFTY UNITS WERE LESS
AND YET WE'RE MAKING.
NOT CHANGES TO DEAL WITH JUST
VOTER RIGHTS WERE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
ENTIRE PROCESS THAT IN MOST
CASES 70% OF THE TIME ARE
GENERALLY OVERSEEN.
BY VOLUNTEERS.
THOSE VOLUNTEERS IF THEY MAKE A
MISTAKE THIS BILL.
HAS CREATED THE GOTCHA AT THE
END OF IT I BY CHANGING THE
BURDEN OF PROOF THAT A A COURT
WOULD ACTUALLY LOOK AT IN
TODAY'S LAW.
IF THERE IS A MISTAKE IN AN
ELECTION AND IT HAPPENS TO GO TO
COURT IT IS UP TO THE JUDGE TO
BALANCE THE FACTS.
OF THE CASE TO DETERMINE IF IF A
MISTAKE WAS MADE WHETHER OR NOT
THAT MISTAKE ACTUALLY HAD.
A RESULT ON THE OUTCOME AND IF
THE JUDGE DECIDES THAT AFTER
BALANCING THE FACTS THEY CAN
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
SB THREE TWENTY THREE TURNS OUT
ON ITS HEAD BY NOW STATING THAT
IT THE ASSOCIATION HAS THE
BURDEN TO PROVE THAT A MISTAKE
THAT MIGHT HAVE OCCURRED DID NOT
HAVE AN OUTCOME ON THE ELECTION
IF THEY CANNOT PROVE THAT.
MEN THE JUDGE SHALL VOID THE
ELECTION SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IS ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF THE
SITUATIONS WHERE MISTAKE HAVE
OCCURRED THE ASSOCIATION CAN'T
PROVE IT DIDN'T HAVE A AN
OUTCOME RESULT ON THE OUTCOME.
YET ANOTHER ELECTION AND SB
THREE TWENTY THREE HAS EXTENDED
THE IT'S TIME FOR THE ELECTION
TO NOW OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DAYS.
THE OTHER ISSUE WITH THE BILL IS
THAT IT COVERS THE ELECTION
PROCESS.
WOULD HAVE WHICH HAPPENS WHEN A
SPECIAL ASSESSMENT TAKES PLACE
WHEN A CHANGE IN THE BYLAWS TAKE
PLACE WHEN A BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ELECTION TAKES PLACE.
BUT THE MAIN FOCUS BY THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL OR THE
BOARD OF ELECTION.
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS ELECTIONS
SO WE'VE NOW CHANGE THE PROCESS.
FOR ALL THESE OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT TAKE PLACE WE'VE INCREASED
HE COST OF THIS ELECTION FOR
ALL THESE OTHER ACTIVITIES TAKE
PLACE. FOR WHAT WE'RE SEEING
THEIR WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE AND PROBLEMS.
WITH THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ELECTIONS.
THE ONE AMENDMENT THAT THE
PROPONENTS THE AUTHOR ARE NOT
ACCEPTING HIS RATHER SIGNIFICANT --
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS GOES TO THE
ISSUE OF NOT ONLY DEALING WITH
BOARD OF A LOT DIRECTOR
ELECTIONS IT'S ALL ELECTIONS.
SO RIGHT NOW IN SOME CASES WHERE
THERE IS A COMMUNITY MANAGER
THAT COMMUNITY MANAGER AS PART
OF THEIR BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP
THEIR CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE ASSOCIATION MAY SERVICE
THAT.
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
[inaudible]
THE CPA.
OF THE ASSOCIATION MAY SERVE
THAT ROLE.
THE ATTORNEY MAY STATE SERVE
WITH THIS BILL AND THE CHANGES
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED NONE OF
THOSE ENTITIES EVEN THOSE WHO
ARE STATE LICENSE HAVE CODE OF
ETHICS.
REGARDING CERTAIN ISSUES LIKE
THIS COULD NOT SERVE IN THAT
ROLE THEREFORE THE ASSOCIATION
HAS NO OTHER RESPONSE OR ANOTHER
ROLE BUT ACTUALLY GOING OUT AND
FINDING A PROFESSIONAL.
NOW THERE MAY BE VOLUNTEERS TO
COULD DO THIS.
BUT UNDER THE CURRENT SITUATION
CURRENT ELECTION RULES IT'S
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT LET'S DOUBLE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THE
ELECTION IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE
LET'S ADD ADDITIONAL STEPS LET'S
ADD ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS BY
THIS INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY.
INVESTIGATOR OF ELECTIONS AND
NOW ASK OF ALL INTO YOUR TO DO
IT WE'RE ONLY GOING TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE MISTAKES
WHEN CREATE OPPORTUNITIES WERE
MORE ELECTIONS ARE GONNA BE
AVOIDED.
AND INCREASING COSTS.
FINALLY TO THE POINT OF THE
BUDGETS AGAIN. 70% SO STATION
STATE A CALIFORNIA FIFTY UNITS
FOR LESS 53% THE ASSOCIATION'S
CALIFORNIA HAVE BUDGETS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS
THOSE BUDGETS ARE PAID FOR BY
THE HOMEOWNERS.
THOSE BUDGETS ARE PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON THE OPERATION OF THE
ASSOCIATION THE MAINTENANCE OF
THE PROPERTY THE MAINTENANCE OF
PROPERTY VALUES SO EVERY
ADDITIONAL DOLLAR THAT GOES TO
SOME OTHER PROCESS.
THAT IS NOT WARRANTED ESPECIALLY
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS IMPACTING
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND ASSOCIATIONS
WHAT ULTIMATELY COST HOMEOWNERS
ADDITIONAL MONEY AND IN A TIME
IN A STATE WHERE WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT HOMEOWNERS AND HOMEOWNER
AFFORDABILITY.
WE JUST THINK THAT SB.
THREE TWENTY THREE IS THE WRONG
SOLUTION FOR THIS PERCY PROBLEM
ASK FOR NO VOTE.
WELL I'M SORRY.
THE MAN CLIP WE HAVE ANY TIME
LEFT FOR THE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY PLEASE.
MY OPPOSITION IS PRETTY MUCH
WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY STATED
JENNIFER WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS.
ALSO HERE OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY STATED WE DO FEEL WITH
THE AMOUNT OF AID TO WAYS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH IS PROBLEMATIC.
ESPECIALLY IN THIS INSTANCE
WHERE THERE ARE VOLUNTEER THESE
ARE VOLUNTEER BOARD MEMBERS WHO
ARE GIVING THEIR TIME -- AND IT
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT GIVEN
THE SCOPE OF AND SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE DECISIONS THAT THEY MAKE FOR
THE HOMEOWNERS IN THAT COMMUNITY
FOR EACH ASSOCIATION TO BE ABLE.
TO CUSTOMIZE WHATEVER --
ELECTION PROCEDURES ARE
NECESSARY TO SUIT THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY SO FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY STATED.
WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
OKAY -- EIGHTY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE IS THE BILL.
MY KNEES ARE SHOT A STEPHANO I I
AM FULLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SUPPORT [inaudible]
MY LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE LET ME JUST START BY
FIRST CLEAR FIND THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE CHAIR AND I HAD AGREED
TO I KNOW THERE WERE TWO MINUTES
THAT WERE DISCUSSED IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU WILL BE
TAKING THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AROUND SPECIAL ASSESSMENTS WHICH
I THINK IS A SIGNIFICANT MOMENT
TO REGAIN INSURE -- BOTH CLARITY
BUT BUT BUT MAKING SURE THAT
CANDIDATES -- ARE APPROPRIATELY
FOLLOWING UP WHAT WE NEED TO SEE
DONE IN THIS OP WITH REGARD TO
THE SECOND COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE AUTHOR AND I HAVE DISCUSSED
THIS I THINK THIS IS AN ISSUE WE
WILL CONTINUE. TO WORK ON I'M
NOT GOING TO ASK OR INSIST ON
NOT BEING TAKEN FOR THIS
COMMITTEE -- WE CAN OBVIOUSLY
HAVE MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
IF FOLKS SO CHOOSE BUT THAT IS
THE DISCUSSION THAT THE AUTHOR I
HAD OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS.
WITH THAT IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION BY THE COMMITTEE.
MR YEP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
ROOM MY MY CONCERN -- ABOUT THE
BUT THE BILL IS BEFORE IS IS
THAT -- I ALSO LIVE IN NAY -- IN
H. AWAY AND I'VE.
OF PARTICIPATED IN IN THE IN IN
IN THE LOCAL ELECTIONS ON IF I
GUESS IF YOU WANT TO CALL THAT.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO DO.
I'M A WE GET OFF THAT AT THAT
BOARD SOON BUT MY MY CONCERN
ABOUT IT THIS BILL IS THAT.
I'M OKAY WITH ALLOWING
INDIVIDUAL H. AWAY THE SAID
SANDERS FOR EXAMPLE.
SOME H. AWAY THIS HAVE ANY
REQUIREMENT AT ALL MEANING.
IF YOU'RE IF YOU IF YOU'RE A
HOMEOWNER.
ON WHETHER YOU LIVE ON SITE OR
OFFSITE.
YOU CAN STILL PARTICIPATE --
SOME H. AWAY THAT I THAT I KNOW
OF WOULD ALLOW OR IT WOULD WOULD
GO WOULD LIMIT.
ELIGIBILITY TO HOLD WATER THE
ACTUALLY LIVE.
IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- YOU KNOW HE OR SHE
IT'S A SIMILAR WITH THE MEDIA
AND THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO I'M NOT SURE IF IF -- IF
WE WANT.
TO PROHIBITS H. AWAY FROM THIS
FROM SETTING CERTAIN STANDARDS
OUR GUIDELINE ON ON HOW --
CANDIDATES OF FROM THESE THESE
HOME A SHOULD BE ALLOWED OR NOT
ALLOWED TO RUN ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU HAVE SUCH A DIVERSE.
GROUP OF OF H. AWAY HE'S A
HANNAH.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE SEEN ANY
ANY.
PROBLEMS OR WRONGDOING BUT
RELEASE FORM FROM FROM ORANGE
COUNTY -- I HAVEN'T SEEN A TO AB --
BECOMING A PROBLEM BECAUSE THE
THE THE GAME OR THE RIG THE
ELECTION IN A WAY WHERE ONLY
THEIR FRIENDS OR OR ALLOWED TO
RUN OR SEATED ON NEEDS A TO A
BOARDS.
RIGHT AT WITH REGARD TO THE
ELIGIBILITY I'VE BEEN TAKING THE
AMENDMENT ON ON THE SPECIAL
ASSESSMENTS I HAD ARGUED OF
BEFORE THAT YOU KNOW IF.
ANY MEMBERS ON THE DAY AS DON'T
PAY THEIR TAXES THAT'S AN ISSUE
OF THE OF THE OF THE CANDIDACY
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT DISQUALIFIED
FROM RUNNING FOR THAT THE
ASSEMBLY YOU JUST.
HAVE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND WHY
YOU DIDN'T PAY YOUR TAXES.
HI BUT I'M WITH THAT SAID I I
THINK THAT OKAY IF YOU DON'T PAY
YOUR SPECIAL ASSESSMENT OR
YOU'RE NOT IN A PAYMENT PLAN
WERE YOU HAVING GAVIN YOU'RE
RIGHT YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO YOU
KNOW OBJECTION THOSE HEARINGS.
THEN YOU'RE STILL ELIGIBLE IF
YOU PASS THOSE THINGS THEN I'VE
AGREED TO STEP AWAY FROM FROM
THAT ALGAE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
I'M IN THERE ARE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE YOU'RE CORRECT IN THAT
SOME.
H. AWAY HE'S SET DIFFERENT
STANDARDS ON WHO HOW LONG YOU
HAVE TO LIVE IN TO THE THE
EQUIRE ARE THE H. AWAY. TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE WE'RE LOOKING
HERE FOCUSING MOSTLY ON THE
PROCESS OF THAT OF THE ELECTION.
YOU KNOW IN IN IN THE ACTUAL
TIME THAT PEOPLE CAN BE A
CANDIDATE WHAT WOULD DISQUALIFY
THEM -- AND AND WHO CAN GET WHO
CAN GET ON THE LIST -- AND I
KNOW THAT THERE WERE THE OBJECT
THE OPPOSITION RAISE A LOT OF
POINTS THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO FOR
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON THE
ON AND THEIR PURVIEW WE ARE
WE'RE HERE IN HOUSING.
ON ON I THINK THE ASSESSMENTS IS
A BIG PART OF IT THE CONCERN AND
I'VE TAKEN THE STEP THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
I HOPE THAT CLARIFIES.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
LET ME -- THANK THE AUTHOR --
FOR FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD A
NOTE THIS IS A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE -- BILL AND WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF DISCUSSIONS
AROUND -- SAFEGUARDS TO THE C.
ID ELECTION PROCESS MY HOPE IS
WE MIGHT BE AT THE END OF THAT.
RELATIVELY SOON.
BUT AGAIN APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS ON SPECIAL
ASSESSMENTS AND UNLESS THERE IS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ANY FINAL
COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE.
I WOULD SAY AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT'S ABOUT DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNANCE AND WHAT THIS BILL
HOPES TO DO IS YOU KNOW I MAKE
THINGS MORE DEMOCRATIC IN THE
GOVERNANCE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THAT
LIVE IN A CHOICE IT'S JUST.
WE MANY OF THE THINGS WE'RE
ASKING FOR WOULD BE SECOND
NATURE IF SOMEBODY JUST LIVED IN
THE CITY AND WE'RE ASKING FOR
THEIR ELECTION TO THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKE THEIR THEIR DECISION
SO -- THESE ARE FOR THE ACTUAL --
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THERE WITH
THAT I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
AND THE ANSWER IS OUR MOTION
WITH THIS.
FOR IS OUR SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
TWO FIVE TWO I DEEP KILEY KNOW
THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES YOU
NEED TO MORE TO GET OUT AND
WITHOUT WE WILL PROCEED TO OTHER
MATTERS UNTIL OTHER MEMBERS
ARRIVE.
I THINK WE NEXT HAVE ON THE
LISTENER BELL APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN IN
AND OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE ROOM A
COUPLE TIMES THIS MORNING.
CENTRE BELL S. OF FILE ITEM ONE
SB. SIX TO GIVE CATHOLIC WOMAN
[inaudible]
SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- THANK YOU --
FOR CONSIDERATION SB SIX MEMBERS --
TODAY I PERCENT THIS BILL WHICH
WILL.
IN CALIFORNIA CENTRALIZED
DATABASE OF STATE AND LOCAL
KNOWN SURPLUS AND VACANT.
LAND AND PROPERTIES IDENTIFIED
FOR CONSTRUCTION.
AS WE ALL KNOW WHERE THERE'S NO
SILVER BULLET.
THAT'S GOING TO ADDRESS ARE
STAGGERING HOUSING CRISIS THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE PROPOSAL -- TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OBSTACLES TO
CONSTRUCTION.
NOW STAKEHOLDERS HAVE IDENTIFIED
LAND COSTS SPECIFICALLY.
AS A BARRIER TO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND FURTHER DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPERS OFTEN DO NOT KNOW
NGUYEN SITES ARE AVAILABLE TO
DEVELOP.
AND WHICH ENTITIES MANAGE THE
LAND -- SB -- SIX PROPOSALS TO
UTILIZE INFORMATION ARE REPORTED
BY CITIES.
COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
ANOTHER AGENCIES TO MAKE IT --
MORE READILY AVAILABLE.
AND EASY TO ACCESS -- TODAY IN
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE PAUL GONZALEZ A
REPRESENT -- RUN COMMITTEE LAND
TRUSTS -- PEDRO GAL THE ALL OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE OR
THE WITNESS.
YOUR WITNESS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE IRVINE
COMMITTEE LAND TRUST.
THEIR BY CHAMELEON TRUST IS A IS
ONE OF TWENTY TWO INTRO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT MAKE
UP THE CALIFORNIA INTEREST
NETWORK -- THE WIND TRUST MODEL
PROVIDES PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE
RENTAL AND HOME OWNERSHIP AND
SERVE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE TAKE A PROJECT FROM CONCEPT
TO CONSTRUCTION TO LEASING AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE HELP
FAMILIES REALIZE THE AMERICAN
DREAM OF OWNING A HOME.
WHAT'S THE FAMILY DECIDES TO
SELL THEIR INTEREST HOME.
THEY MUST SELL IT TO ANOTHER
INCOME QUALIFIED FAMILY WHICH
KEEPS OUR UNITS AFFORDABLE IN
PERPETUITY.
THE IRVINE CHAMELEON TRUST IN
THE CALIFORNIA INTEREST NETWORK
ARE EAGER TO GROW SERVE MORE
FAMILIES SB SIX CAN HELP US IN
OTHER DEVELOPERS IDENTIFY LAND
READY FOR DEVELOPMENT.
WE'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE MANY
BARRIERS AND TRYING TO COMPLETE
THESE DEVELOPMENTS IN A
CENTRALIZED DATABASE OF STATE
AND LOCALLY ON SURPLUS THEN
VACANT LAND AND PROPERTIES VERY
FOR DEVELOPMENT CAN HELP
EXPEDITE THIS PROCESS.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE OBSTACLES
TO BUILDING HOUSING IN THE STATE
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
CHECK -- GOOD MORNING CHAIR --
TO RECOVER WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIX AND BEFORE FOR US WE SAY
THAT THERE'S THREE CRITICAL
COMPONENTS TO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LAND MONEY
AND POLITICAL WILL AND THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE LAND ISSUE.
AS SENATOR BELL SAID WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH IN THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO
IDENTIFY.
HOUSING OPPORTUNITY SITES IN
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS AND
REPORT THAT INFORMATION TO THE
STATE THIS SIMPLY CREATES A
CENTRALIZED DATABASE OF THAT
INFORMATION AND AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT BUILDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THIS WOULD MAKE IT FAR
EASIER TO IDENTIFY SITES THAT
COULD BE.
READY TO HELP BUILD MORE HOMES
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS BONTA
BROUGH CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION
HERE IN SUPPORT.
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY AND SILICON VALLEY
AT HOME AND SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SPECTRUM OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT -- MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
BRAND MAR NUMBER HAVE THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AS HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
OUR THINK THE AUTHOR FOR A FOR
MOVING THIS FORD THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT I HAVE -- BEEN FRUSTRATED
WITH IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS --
A NUMBER OF US I THINK I SEE YOU
NODDING OF TRYING TO IDENTIFY
WHAT SURPLUS PROPERTIES EXIST IN
OUR DISTRICTS IN OUR REGIONS --
TRY TO GET THAT ANSWER FROM THE
BUREAUCRACY AND I THINK -- WHAT
YOU PROPOSED HERE IS -- VERY
MUCH A GOOD COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION AS WELL AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE A LITTLE BIT
OF TECHNOLOGY -- TO HELP THE
PUBLIC AND HELP US ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS SO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
UNLESS THERE'S ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND ANY FINAL COMMENTS
TO THE AUTHOR.
I JUST LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS -- THAT ARE
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE ALSO I
KNOW I KNOW IT'S BEEN A US TOPIC
IN THE ASSEMBLY AS WELL THE
SENATE.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE THANK YOU I'M
ALSO HAPPY TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
HELPFUL -- AND WITH THAT --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
TO SHOOT I DEEP.
GABRIELLE GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY I IN THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES YOU NEED ONE
MORE TO GET IT OUT APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATION [inaudible]
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
WELCOME.
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM NINE SB.
FIVE THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PROCEED.
WHENEVER YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SOB PRESENTING SB FIVE
THIRTY TWO I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS PRESENTED BY THE
COMMITTEE -- THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE GLENDALE TO USE THE
RAIN REMAINING BOND PROCEEDS
FROM THEIR TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
SUBORDINATE TAXABLE TAX
ALLOCATION BOND FOR THE PURPOSE.
OF INCREASING AND IMPROVING AND
PRESERVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHIN THE CITY I KNOW A SIMILAR
BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE I
WENT THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE AND
I BELIEVE PASSED THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR A SEVENTY TWO TO ZERO WHEN
THE CLOSURE OF REDEVELOPMENT
HAPPENED ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE
REMOVAL OF FINANCING FOR A ROLE
PORTABLE HOUSING -- REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF THE NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL -- I DON'T KNOW IF SOME OF
YOU KNOW BUT AT THE TIME I
ACTUALLY OPPOSED THE DISSOLUTION
OF REDEVELOPMENT AND HAVE THE
BATTLE SCARS. TO PROVE IT --
GLENDALE IS TRYING TO BE A GOOD
ACTOR HERE THEY HAVE TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF NON
HOUSING DOLLARS FROM THE CENTRAL
GLENDALE REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT
AREA.
THAT IT IT IS PREVENTED FROM
USING BY THE STATE BECAUSE IT'S
NOT ALLOWED UNDER THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT --
RATHER THAN -- CANCEL THIS BOND
GLENDALE REQUESTS TO DELEGATE IT
TOWARDS A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PURPOSES THIS WOULD
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
SOLE SOURCE OF FUNDS I'M TOLD
LANDALE HOPES TO LEVERAGE THIS
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
WITH ANOTHER I BELIEVE EIGHTY
MILLION AND PRODUCE CLOSE.
TO FOUR HUNDRED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP LOCAL TAX
DOLLARS LOCAL FOR A LAUDABLE
PURPOSE I DON'T BELIEVE IT WILL.
COSTS THE STATE ANYTHING AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR THIS DISTRICT SPECIFIC BILL.
THANK YOU BEFORE YOU PROCEED
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE INSTALLED
THAT I HAVE TO ADD ON ANOTHER
COMMITTEE OR ALSO ABOUT TO CLOSE
A ROLE BUT LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AT THE
RIGHT TIME WHEN IT IS TIME TO
VOTE I'M GONNA HAVE THE GAVEL
OVER TO ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE A WITNESS MR MILLER
MEMBERS DAVID JONES ABOUT THE
CITY OF GLENDALE LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB
PRESENTING WITH THE BILL WILL DO --
WE THINK PRODUCING FOUR HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL FOR DOUBLE HOUSING
UNITS FOR THE COMMUNITY AND FOR
THE REGION IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
BENEFIT BENEFIT -- WITH OTHER
RESOURCES THAT THE CITY HAS AND
WITH TAX CREDITS WE BELIEVE --
THAT THESE FOUR HUNDRED UNITS
WILL COME TO FRUITION AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
IN ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS ARE TESTS --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND WELCOME YOU HAVE A FEW
MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I DO WANT TO
STATE THAT WE ABSOLUTELY DON'T --
OPPOSE -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
ACTUALLY CAM AND THE CREATIVITY
THAT'S BEING UTILIZED TO TRY TO
ADDRESS AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THERE WE RECENTLY TOOK AN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE AS WELL
AS AB ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE AS IT'S COME TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT THIS COULD HAVE A
LONG TERM IMPACT ON LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THOSE AREAS THAT
RELY ON PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
HE COULD EITHER HINDER THE
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE THAT WOULD
GO TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
RELYING IN THOSE AREAS OR COULD
HAVE A LONG TERM IMPACT IN
DELAYING THE OVERALL REVENUES
THAT WOULD HAVE GONE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
OUR CONCERN IS MAKING SURE THAT
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PARTICULARLY A FOR IN IN TIME OF
ECONOMIC DECLINE OR WE HAVE
ANOTHER RECESSION THAT COULD
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PUT AT A COMPETITIVE
AT A DISADVANTAGE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION AND WE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN HERE NONE I WILL TURN BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBER COMMENTS QUESTIONS -- FOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MS Là MON -- WHICH I
WILL SECOND -- ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
MR POINT YOU KNOW JUDGE ECKELS
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL TO USE LOCAL
DOLLARS.
LOCALLY ON A VERY LAUDABLE
PROJECT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR A
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS THE MONA
SECOND I MYSELF QUICKLY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN GOVERNMENT
CHIU.
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I GLORIA AYE
GLORIA AYE KILEY.
KILEY IDEALLY MON.
WE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
THAT'S FOR VOTE SO YOU NEED ONE
MORE -- THICKNESS POINT HERE.
IT WILL LEAVE ALL OPEN
.
I MEMBERS WERE WAITING -- FOR A
FEW SENATE AUTHOR AS WATCHING A
TELEVISION PLEASE AND YOUR BOSS
ON DOWN -- TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
WILL MAKE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR SAN DIEGO VERY HAPPY -- SO
WE'LL SIT AND HOLD A POSITION TO
WE GET A A SENATE AUTHOR.
BEEN MADE MENTION TO ME THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TAKE UP THE
CONSENT AGENDA I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING EXCELLENT IDEA -- THE
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
I MUSEUM SAID.
THE MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KILEY SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE MON ON THE CONSENT AGENDA --
QUICKLY FOLLOW -- MOTION TO PASS --
AS AMENDED. TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN JUDICIARY
PERFECT IMITATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHIU [inaudible]
STATE.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA AYE
GLORIA AYE KILEY.
KILEY IDLY MON.
LIMóN NINE MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
GOOD.
FOR EFFICIENT USE OF INTERLUDE --
WHAT IS NOW A PERFECT TIME TO
BRING FORTUNATE A SKIN AND
PRESENTER BILL?
THERE'S GONNA YOU HAVE TO BUILD
THE ONE WAS SOME CONSENT SO --
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING SENATE BILL --
THREE THIRTY THREE THANK YOU ARE.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- I
WANT.
TO START FIRST BY INDICATING
THAT IN YOUR ANALYSIS THERE'S A
LIST OF COMMITTEE MEMINTA TIME
TAKING ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- ADDITIONALLY I
WILL BE TAKING SOME OTHER
AMENDMENTS WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT
IN JUST A FEW MINUTES THE BILL
NEXT GOES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND I'VE MET WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHAIR AND THEIR STAFF
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STAFF WORK TOGETHER.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL WHEN
IT -- KNOCK ON WOOD GETS OUT OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
IT REFLECTS -- BOTH THE
COMMITMENTS I'VE ADE HERE AND
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
ANALYSIS HERE AND THE ONES I
WILL BE DESCRIBING BUT BEFORE I
DESCRIBE THOSE I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST SAY.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF MYTHS OUT THERE?
AND THIS BILL IS.
HAS REALLY DESIGNED ON A VERY
SIMPLE PREMISE.
THAT IS IF WE WE'VE ALL ACCEPTED
THAT WE ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS
CALIFORNIA NEITHER HAS ENOUGH
HOUSING.
NOR.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO THOSE ARE
TWO REALITIES.
AND YET WHEN WE LOOK AT EACH OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEY HAVE
IN THEIR EXISTING GENERAL PLANS
ZONING RULES ALL.
THEY HAVE MORE HOUSING THAT IS
BEEN ALLOWED ON ON PAPER RIGHT
IN THEIR DOCUMENTS THEN AS YOU
HAVE BEEN BUILT.
SO.
WHAT I THOUGHT ABOUT IS IF WE'RE
IN A CRISIS?
AND WE WANT FAST ACTION.
THEN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
GET FAST ACTION IS TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DO THAT WHICH
THEY ARE ALREADY DOING.
AND JUST DO IT WITH A LITTLE
MORE EFFICIENCY AND MORE
CERTAINTY.
SO THIS BILL IS.
BASICALLY RESPECTS LOCAL ZONING.
IT SAYS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. FOR
THOSE HOUSING APPLICATIONS THAT
MEET YOUR EXISTING RULES.
ONCE THE APPLICANT HAS PROVIDED
YOU ALL THE INFORMATION YOU
REQUIRE AND THE BILL.
LISTS THE TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED THAT IS
TYPICALLY CONSIDERED A COMPLETE
APPLICATION.
AND SO LET'S SAY I'M THE HOUSING
APPLICANT AND I SUBMIT SOMETHING
BUT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LOOKS
AT IT AND SAYS YOU KNOW WE NEED
A IN A STRUCTURAL ENGINEER
ANALYSIS HERE WE CAN'T ANALYZE
THIS.
UNTIL WE HAVE -- SOME
INFORMATION FROM A STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER OR WE CAN ANALYZE THIS
YET UNTIL IT HAS YOU KNOW THIS
INFORMATION OR THAT INFORMATION
SO ONCE I HAVE.
GIVEN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY'VE
REQUIRED ME I'M THE HOUSING
APPLIQUE KIT.
AND MY IN THAT THING OF THAT I
AM SUBMITTING MY APPLICATION FOR
MEETS.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ZONING
RULES.
THEN AT THAT POINT THIS IS WHAT
THE BILL DOES AT THAT POINT.
FEES ARE LOCKED.
IN THE RULES ARE LOCKED SO THEN
IT GIVES ME THE APPLICANT THE
CERTAINTY.
THAT.
THINGS I'M NOT GOING TO BE IN
THE SHIFTING LANDSCAPE SO I CAN
GET THE FINANCING FOR MY PROJECT
OR FIVE ALREADY SECURED IT.
I CAN HAVE THE ASSURANCE THAT
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE AND
WHILE CONSTRUCTION COSTS MIGHT
GO UP AT LEAST THE FEES FROM
THIS CITY THAT'S I'VE APPLIED TO
THOSE WILL PULL UP.
IN THEIR DESIGN REVIEW STANDARDS
WHICH I'VE ALREADY UNDERSTAND
AND I'VE ALREADY MET THOSE WON'T
CHANGE SO THAT'S THE SIMPLE
PREMISE.
AND IT WAS BASED SANTA ROSA
AFTER THE COFFEE FIRE SO IN THE
COFFEE FIRE THE EXPERIENCED.
VERY SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF UNITS
OVER A THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS
WERE LOST.
IN THE REALIZED THEY NEEDED TO
HELP.
THEIR RESIDENTS GET THOSE
HOUSING UNITS BACK FAST AND
EFFICIENTLY.
SO THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
BASICALLY SPED UP THEIR PROCESS
HE STREAMLINED THERE.
THE THE PERMITTING PROCESS SO
AND GAVE SOME CERTAINTY TO THE
APPLICANTS TO GET THOSE UNITS
BACK AND MY STAFF WATCHING THAT
I ASKED MY STAFF.
IT WAS MORE THAN A YEAR AGO TO
CALL SANTA ROSA PLANNING
DEPARTMENT.
AND GET THERE I'M TO GET THE
ORDINANCE IS TO GET THE
MATERIALS THAT THEY DID WE BASED
THIS LAW.
ON WHAT SANTA ROSA DID TO
RESPOND TO A CRISIS WHICH IS WHY
WE CALL IT THE HOUSING CRISIS
ACT.
NOW THE BILL WHEN IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED MUCH OF THE
OPPOSITION IS BASED ON THE BILL
WHEN IT WAS FIRST INTRODUCED.
THE BILL HAS BEEN GREATLY
MODIFIED SINCE THEN SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF AMENDMENTS THIS IS A
LIST OF ALL THE WAYS THE BILL
HAS BEEN AMENDED SINCE IT WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED.
SO WHILE THERE ARE OPPONENTS
HERE I THINK IF THEY WERE TO
READ THE BILL TODAY AND
ESPECIALLY THE BILL.
ONCE THE IT HAS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT I'M TAKING.
THE BETTER IN YOUR ANALYSIS
BEFORE YOU.
AND ADDITIONALLY.
I AM SO NO LET ME BACK UP SO MY
PURPOSE WAS TO GIVE THAT
CERTAINTY TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING.
AND WHEN WE COMES TO
AFFORDABILITY A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAY WELL BUT IT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE FACT IS THAT.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS VERY
FREQUENTLY FINANCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THROUGH THE IN LIEU FEES
AND OTHER FEES IMPACT FEES THAT
THEY GET FROM THE MARKET RATE
HOUSING.
THIS DOES NOT REQUIRE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO MORE MARKET
RATE HOUSING THAN THEY WOULD
ALREADY HAVE SAID YES.
TO BUT IT ALLOWS THEM TO DO IT A
LITTLE MORE EFFICIENTLY.
AND THEN THEY GET THAT REVENUE
TO HELP THEM DO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND ADDITIONALLY OF COURSE IN
THE BUDGET WE JUST APPROVED WE
JUST GAVE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY TOWARDS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT LET ME GO FURTHER.
I'M SOMEONE WHO KNEW MY HISTORY.
IT WILL REVEAL TOO MUCH ABOUT MY
AGE BUT I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
WRITING OF BERKELEY'S RENT
CONTROL ORDINANCES IN THE
SEVENTIES.
I WAS INVOLVED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN AND THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE THE NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
BERKELEY RENT CONTROL ORDINANCES.
I HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT AND
LONG HISTORY WITH RENT CONTROL I
AM ONE OF THE FEW.
LEGISLATORS WHO SUPPORTED PROP.
TEN WHICH I REALIZE IS AN
ANATHEMA TO MANY PEOPLE.
AND I STILL SUPPORT RENT CONTROL
AND I STILL WANT THERE TO BE
EVICTION PROTECTIONS AND OTHER
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR TENANTS OF
EVERY SORT.
BUT RENT CONTROL IS NOT ENOUGH
MY OWN COMMUNITY BERKELEY HAS
HAD RENT CONTROL AS I JUST
DESCRIBED TO YOU SINCE THAT TIME
NO CERTAINLY THERE'S BEEN LOTS
OF STATE LAWS THAT HAVE.
INHIBITED SOME OF THE INTENTIONS
OF BERKELEY'S ORIGINAL RENT
CONTROL BUT RENT CONTROL DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE SUPPLY CRISIS SO
WHILE WE MUST PROTECT LOW INCOME
TENANTS AND I AM A VERY STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR PROTECTING LOW
INCOME TENANTS.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THIS BILL
YOU'LL SEE.
THAT THIS BILL CONTAINS
PROTECTIONS FOR LOW INCOME TO
TENANTS SO THAT IF THERE'S ANY
PROPOSAL TO DEMOLISH AND
AFFORDABLE UNITS.
THAT OCCURSDURING THE FIVE
YEARS THAT THIS BILL IS IN
EFFECT IN THIS BILL ONLY HAS.
PROVISIONS FOR FIVE YEARS IT
SUNSETS IN FIVE YEARS BUT THOSE
TENET PROTECTIONS ARE THAT IF
FOR ANY REASON A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WERE TO APPROVE A
DEMOLITION AND I'M NOT
ADVOCATING THAT THEY EVER DO.
BUT IF THEY WERE TO THEN AND IT
WAS A LOW INCOME UNITS.
THEN IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
GUARANTEED TO REPLACE AT LEAST
THAT MANY LOW INCOME UNITS THE
TENANTS IMPACTED WOULD HAVE TO
BE RELOCATED.
AND THEIR RELOCATION EXPENSES
PAID.
FOR AND THE A GUARANTEE THAT
THEY HAVE OUR FIRST RIGHT ON THE
UNITS THAT REPLACE AT THE SAME
RENT SO THERE IS STRONG STRONG
PROTECTIONS. FOR LOW INCOME
TENANTS IN THIS BILL.
BUT AGAIN WHAT IS THIS BILL
TRYING TO DO IT'S TRYING TO HELP
US.
GET THE HOUSING THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED BUT TO DO IT
EFFECTIVELY.
AND EFFICIENTLY TO RESPOND TO
THIS HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE ARE
IN NOW I MENTIONED THAT I WILL
TAKE ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
I AM ALSO COMMITTED TO FULLY
DELETING THE SECTIONS ON PARKING.
NOW.
THAT ONE JUST FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY DID I PUT THAT IN
THE BILL AND LET ME AND WHEN I
SAY HI.
THIS BILL IS MY BILL THIS IS A
BILL THAT MY STAFF AND I CRAFTED
YES WE HAVE SUPPORTERS YES WE
HAVE SPONSORS BUT WE CRAFTED
THIS BILL AND WE CRAFTED IT
BASED ON SANTA ROSA'S ACTION.
BUT THE REASON THAT WE INCLUDED
THE PARKING PORTION IS BECAUSE
PARKING ADDS COST.
AND WHILE MANY PEOPLE SAY THIS
DOES NOTHING FOR AFFORDABILITY
MY PURPOSE IS TO TRY TO EVEN
BRING DOWN THE COST OF MARKET
RATE.
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T CONTROL
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST COST OF CONSTRUCTION OF
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS SOMEWHAT OUT OF MY
CONTROL BUT AT LEAST BY REMOVING
THOSE COSTLY ELEMENTS THAT DO
COULD WE DO HAVE CONTROL OVER
AND THOSE COSTLY ELEMENTS ARE
THINGS LIKE TIME AND UNCERTAINTY.
BUT ALSO PARKING THAT WAS MY
MOTIVATION IT WAS TO REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT OF PARKING IT WAS
NOT TO PREVENT PARKING IF THE
APPLICANT FELT THAT THEY NEEDED
PARKING THIS BILL WOULD NOT OF
PROHIBITED.
BUT BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION HAS
TURNED THAT INTO SECTION.
YOU KNOW ENOUGH TO KILL THE
BASIC OTHER ESSENTIAL BENEFITS
OF THIS BILL I'M WILLING TO GET
RID OF IT.
SO I AM GONNA FULLY DELETE THE
REFERENCES TO THE PARKING.
SO THAT SECTION FIVE BE ONE THAT
WILL BE DONE IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
AND I'M GOING TO ALSO FULLY
ELIMINATE.
THE PART THAT'S AROUND THAT
WOULD HAVE RESTRICTED CHEST FOR
THE FIVE YEARS.
ANY VOTER -- REQUIREMENTS ON
APPROVING.
A CITIES.
SO WE HAVE SOME COMMUNITIES
WHERE IF THE CITY ACTS.
TO PROVE CERTAIN PROJECTS THAT
THEN HAS TO GO BEFORE THE VOTERS
WHICH OF COURSE GREAT LEAD
DELAYS THE PROJECT.
AND ADD SIGNIFICANT COST BUT
BECAUSE THE BILL IS ONLY IN
EFFECT FOR FIVE YEARS AND IT'S
HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT IN A FIVE
YEAR PROCESS YOU WOULD HAVE.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT ACTING AND
THEN THE ABILITY FOR THE VOTERS
TO ACT IT'S JUST BETTER TO GET
RID OF IT BECAUSE IT REMOVES
THAN THIS THING THAT SOME
OPPOSITION SEEMS TO HAVE LATCHED
ON TO AS THE POISON PILL OF THE
BILL.
SO FINE WE'LL GET RID OF IT WE
HAVE STILL PRESERVED THE
ESSENTIAL PURPOSE OF THE BILL
WHICH IS TO RESPECT EXISTING
ZONING BUT GIVE THE APPLICANT
CERTAINTY.
AND GIVE THEM A TIME LINE WHICH
EXISTING LAW UNDER THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING ACT ALLOWS.
FOR SO THAT'S IN EFFECT WITH THE
BILL DOES APOLOGIES FOR GIVING A
BENEFITTED BY DOING SO.
AND I WOULD NOW ALLOW MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU SENATOR TO YOUR
WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING CARE TO PRODUCT
ALTHOUGH WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT ONE CRITICAL THING
WE'RE HERE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
SB THREE THIRTY BECAUSE WHILE IT
IS NOT A BILL THAT'S EXCLUSIVELY
FOCUSED IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL HAVE MANY
BENEFITS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS LIKE
ANY DEVELOPMENT STILL MUST PAY --
IMPACT FEES AND STILL FACE THE
LACK OF CERTAINTY OVER ISSUES
THAT THIS BILL ADDRESSES LIKE.
CERTAIN LIKE FEES ZONING AND
EVEN HISTORIC STATUS.
AND SO -- WITH THAT WITHOUT
CERTAINTY THAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES WE BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FASTER.
THAT IS SO DESPERATELY NEEDED BY
BAY AREA RESIDENTS AND BY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS STATEWIDE --
TO GIVE YOU AN AN IDEA RIGHT NOW
IT TAKES A PROJECT ANYWHERE
BETWEEN FROM FOUR TO TEN YEARS
TO GO FROM CONCEPT TO REALITY.
IF THIS BILL CAN SHORTEN THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME EVEN BY A COUPLE
OF MONTHS OR IDEALLY A COUPLE OF
YEARS.
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT HOMES CAN
GET.
THAT THAT WOULD MEAN THAT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS CAN GET A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD FASTER AND
THAT WE CAN GET ALL THE BENEFITS
THAT COME WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUCH AS THE BETTER
EDUCATIONAL HEALTH.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES
SOONER -- FOR OUR STATE AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT SB THREE THIRTY AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD MORNING HOW THERE'S THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN CHIU MY NAME
IS DAVID GARCIA ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE TURNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING INNOVATION.
AT UC BERKELEY WE'RE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY I THINK IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING PARTICULARLY TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT.
WE ARE IN THE DPTHS OF A DEEP
AND WORSENING HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE OVER
HALF OF OUR RENTER'S PAYING MORE --
THAN -- 30% OF THEIR THEIR
INCOME ON RENT AND OF THOSE WE
HAVE ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
PAYING MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR
INCOME ON RENT AND SO.
ON TOP OF THAT'S WE ARE
EXPERIENCING OUR LOWEST LEVELS
OF HOMEOWNERSHIP SINCE THE
NINETEEN FORTY SO IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE SCALE OF THIS CHALLENGE
DEMANDS SOLUTIONS -- THAT MATCH
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM AND
THERE ARE FEW PROPOSALS -- LEFT
ON THE TABLE THIS SESSION THAT
ARE AS IMPORTANT AS SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY SO WE'RE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL FOR TWO SPECIFIC
REASONS THEY'RE SUPPORTED BY OUR
RESEARCH IN THE FIRST IS THAT.
THIS BILL LARGELY PROHIBITS
CITIES FROM ENACTING A DOWN
ZONING TO MORATORIUM'S THAT
WOULD LIMIT THE LIMIT THE
CAPACITY OF NEW HOUSING AND AS
OUR WORK HAS SHOWN THROUGH OUR
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU SURVEY.
MOST CITIES ARE DOING THEIR
PARTS TO REDUCE BARRIERS TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE STILL SOME PLACES THAT
ARE USING LAND USE POLICIES IN A
RESTRICTIVE MANNER. TO MAKE IT.
MORE DIFFICULT TO BUILD NEW
HOMES IN MANY TIMES THESE PLACES
ARE -- AREAS THAT THE STATE HAS
DEEMED HI OPPORTUNITY AND THAT
WE ARE WE WOULD LIKE TO
PRIORITIZE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THESE
LOCATIONS.
AND SO THE SECOND REASON WE'RE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IS THAT IT
WOULD HAVE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT
ON THE COST AND TIME THAT IT
TAKES TO DELIVER HOUSING
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE WORK FORCE
COMING NEXT MONTH.
ON THE COST TO BUILD A DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND OUR RESEARCH IS
SHOWING THAT THINGS LIKE PARKING
THINGS LIKE -- INCREASING FEES
UNCERTAIN TIME LINES THESE ARE
AT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNTS OF
COSTS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT NEW
RESOURCES THANKS TO LEADERSHIP
AT THE STATE LEVEL. TO BUILD
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT COSTS KEEP
RISING.
THOSE NEW RESOURCES WILL NOT BE
AS EFFICIENT AND AS EFFECTIVE AS
THEY COULD BE AND SO THIS BILL
BY LOCKING IN WHAT COULD BE
CHARGING FEES AND SIMPLY ASKING
CITIES.
TO BE A BIT MORE EXPEDITIOUS
WITH THE APPROVAL PROCESS THE
PROCESS IS ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE
THIS KIND OF A MEANINGFUL IMPACT
ON OUR ABILITY. TO QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY DELIVER -- HOMES
PARTICULARLY AFFORDABLE HOMES SO --
I WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT WHEN I
THINK SENATOR FOR WORK ON THIS
THINK COMMITTEE AS WELL AND I
LOOK FOR TO THE DISCUSSION.
OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON MISTER SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIS BURKE WITH THE BEAR
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JENNIFER SPECTRUM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MR TURN NUMBERS THEIR NAME ALLOW
REPRESENTING THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER BRIDGE HOUSING AND
ALSO SALES FORCE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY OF THE EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY.
TNG PARTNERS THE SAND HILL
PROPERTY COMPANY FIELD SITE AND
SO AND SILICON VALLEY AT HOME
ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
AUTHOR AND OUR STAFF FOR WORKING
EXTENSIVELY IN IN GOOD FAITH
WITH A WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS.
SO WE COULD REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SYLVIA PRIDE WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
HI DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARILYN CHECK CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
THE SHERMAN RECESS OR THE OTHER
WE HAVE A STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT.
ARE ON ALERT WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL YET BUT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS DONE TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
THROUGH AMENDMENTS AND LOOK.
FOR TO MAKE BE ABLE TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION AND FUTURE
COMMITTEE.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES CESSATION
ONE ONLINE MAKE COMMENTS WITH --
GERMAN FROM AUCKLAND APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH AUTHOR ANOTHER
HOUSE THANK YOU.
THE ONLY BE WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY THANKS.
GOOD MORNING NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIAN BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
REGGAE'S WITH UP FOR GROWTH
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY GEORGIA IS WHAT AGAIN BEFORE
THE OPPOSITION IT WE ACTUALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH US FOR THE LAST FIVE MONTHS%
STEADILY SO I APPRECIATE THAT WE
WANT TO LOOK AT THE NEW
AMENDMENTS WE'VE MOVED TO
NEUTRAL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO REASSESS IT
OUR POSITION AFTER WE SEE THEM
BUT THE REST THE MEMBERS THANK
YOU.
ME ASK IF THERE IS ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
.
PLEASE YES HELLO THANK YOU I AM.
MY NAME IS AVAILABLE AT THIS
TIME IN.
CO DIRECTOR WITH THE SAN DIEGO
TENANTS UNION.
I WE REPRESENT AND ORGANIZE
TENANTS THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THREE
THIRTY WEEK WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
DISPLACEMENT BILL.
WE BELIEVE IN A CITY LIKE SAN
DIEGO THAT'S PRO DEVELOPER --
THIS DOES VERY LITTLE TO PROTECT
TENANTS THIS ACTUALLY.
MAKES THE HOUSING CRISIS WORSE
BY.
POURING FOR MORE GASOLINE ON THE
FIRE.
THE SPOT ZONING IS A REAL
PROBLEM I DON'T ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU COMBINE IT WITH.
THE FACT THAT THERE'S AN
ENCOURAGING OF DEVELOPERS.
HAVING THE ABILITY TO SUE.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT IF THEY
DON'T APPROVE THEIR PROJECT.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA STRAIN I OUR
RESOURCES AT THE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
WE THINK THIS IS PART OF A
PATTERN.
OF POLICY MAKING THAT'S
SUPPORTIVE OF DEVELOPERS AND IS
NOT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THAT IT.
THESE ARE IN FACT -- BILLS LIKE
SB FIFTY THAT ARE DISPLACING
COMMUNITIES -- THESE ARE
ACCELERATING THE DISPLACEMENT OF
COMMUNITIES AND EXCELLING
ACCELERATING GENTRIFICATION.
WHAT WE'RE ALREADY SEEN IT
HAPPEN -- ANIME ON A MASS SCALE
WE'RE SEEING.
RENT INCREASES AND ABUSES BY A
OWNERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT.
THAT IS GOING ON CHECK --
BECAUSE IN CITIES LIKE SAN DIEGO
WITH THEIR NO RENTAL.
LIEUTENANT PROTECTIONS VERY
LIMITED TEN PROTECTIONS -- WE
NEED MORE PROTECTIONS BEFORE WE
NEED MORE DISPLACEMENT.
AND THESE BILLS ARE TAKING THE
WRONG APPROACH THEY'RE MAKING IT
SO THAT THERE IS MORE
DISPLACEMENT.
AT FASTER RATES [inaudible]
WITH.
NO PROTECTIONS ON RENT CONTROL
NO PROTECTIONS ON TEN AND JUST
BECAUSE YOU'VE ACTIONS THERE'S
NO PROTECTIONS ON YOU KNOW WHAT
WE TALK ABOUT RELOCATION BUT IN
SAN DIEGO THERE'S NO RIGHT
RELOCATION ASSISTANCE.
SO.
YOU KNOW THE COSTS ARE GETTING
OUT OF HAND THE RENTS ARE
ALREADY BEYOND REACH AND THIS IS
EXACERBATING A PROBLEM THAT --
WILL SOON.
TURN INTO A A MUCH.
THIS COULD BE A CATASTROPHE NOT
ONLY A CRISIS IS COULD BE A
CATASTROPHE.
AND BILLS LIKE THIS ARE LEADING
THAT.
CHARGE AGAINST A COMMUNITY.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WHEN WE'RE TAKING THE APPROACH
IN SOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS WE
DON'T?
YOU KNOW.
GIVE EVERYTHING TO THE VALOUR
BRIDGE WHO HAVE INTENTIONALLY
SURPRISE BUILDING.
I'D JUST SO THAT THEY CAN GET
THESE TYPES OF PERKS AND START
CONSTRUCTING AT DIFFERENT THINGS
IN DIFFERENT PLACES THAT WERE
NOT COMMON IN SOME OF THESE
THINGS ARE -- POINT TO
GENTRIFICATION AND SOME OF THESE
THINGS ARE RECOGNIZED AS A
CONTRIBUTING CSU DISPLACEMENT.
SO WE STRONGLY URGE OPPOSITION.
IF -- MEMBERS SAY THAT THEY ARE --
SUPPORTING THINGS LIKE RENT
CONTROL.
WE WANT TO SEE UNIVERSAL RENT
CONTROL WE WANT TO SEE A REPEAL
OF COSTA HAWKINS.
WE WANT TO SEE THE RIGHT TO
ORGANIZE WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
THESE TYPES OF DISPLACEMNT
BILLS THAT SHOW.
LIKE IN PLACES LIKE SAN DIEGO
THAT THINGS ARE.
BEING GRANTED TO DEVELOPERS AT
THERE WILL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE GOVERNMENT IS WORKING FOR
THE PEOPLE NOT FOR DEVELOPERS.
HI MY NAME IS AJMAL JONES -- I
MAY SHE WAS SOUTH SOUTH BOSSES
SAUSAGES SALT LOS ANGELES --
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL -- I LIKE
TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR ALL --
PUTTING EFFORTS AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS -- CRISIS THAT IS
AGAIN STATEWIDE AND WE'RE
EXPERIENCING IT.
IN LOS ANGELES AS WELL -- FEW
WEEKS AGO -- WE HAD A MEETING ON
SOUTH LOS ANGELES -- REGARDING A
PROPOSED LEGISLATION THAT MAY
POSSIBLY -- GIVE MORE UP HARD TO
DEVELOPERS IN THE PLANNING.
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND IT WAS A
REALLY STRONG POINT OF
CONTENTION.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT OVER A
DECADE -- COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND FOLKS --
HELP DEVELOP A COMMUNITY PLAN IT
MADE SENSE FOR THE COMMUNITY AND
AND THIS -- THIS POSSIBILITY
THERE'S A THERE'S A STRONG
POSSIBILITY THAT THE PACKAGE BE
WIPED AWAY.
AND AGAIN BACK.
TO THE EVENT I MEAN WE PLANTED
IN A WEEK A PRINTER FIFTY PEOPLE
CAME OUT SO IT'S IT'S A REALLY
STRONG POINT OF CONTENTION --
ONE OF MY OTHER CONCERNS IN
REGARD TO THIS BILL IS THE
ADDRESSING AFFORDABILITY -- JUST
IN OUR COMMUNITY -- THERE'S
THERE IS THERE IS HOUSING BEING
BUILT I MEAN YOU SEE IT ALL THE
TIME AND WE WERE WEIRD LOS
ANGELES IS MOVING FOR WITH THAT --
I'M I'VE GOT A QUESTION THAT BUT
THE ISSUE IS AFFORDABILITY --
YOU JUST TALK TO THE NEIGHBORS
AND IS OKAY THERE'S A NEW
BUILDING COMING OUT BUT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT.
SO HOUSING IS THERE SO IT'S JUST.
BUT THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT SO
THAT'S JUST THE BIG AGAIN A BIG
POINT OF CONTENTION WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY -- I KNOW THE CITY
AGAIN HAS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNITS THAT HAVE BEEN PROPOSED.
BUT AGAIN GOING BACK TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- THAT'S
JUST A BIG ISSUE -- BOB THE RISK
I WAS TALKING AGAIN I WAS
TALKING TO OUR OVER DRIVERS
RIDES I USE AS AN EXAMPLE AND
YOU SEE THIS IN A CITY IN MY
COMMUNITY WE GOT NEIGHBORS ARE
JUST -- RING AND FINDING WAYS TO
SUSTAIN THEMSELVES IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND IT'S JUST THEY NEED THIS
HOUSING AND THEIR THEIR MEMBERS
ARE COULD OF OUR COMMUNITY BUT
THEN YOU'RE BEING FORCED TO MOVE
OUT TO OTHER AREAS.
BUT THIS CHANGE IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE BEING FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
MY COMMUNITY IT JUST HAPPENED
AND PRICES ARE GOING UP AND
MILLION DOLLAR HOUSES AND PEOPLE
CAN'T LIVE IN NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY'VE BEEN IN.
FOR AGAIN THIRTY YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW WHO'S DOING
ANYTHING TO HELP THAT AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT WE WANT TO SEE WE
WANT TO PUSH.
YOU KNOW WE WANT DEVELOPMENT BUT
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE --
CONTROL AND PLANNING AN INPUT ON
THAT DEVELOPMENT.
ON ESPECIALLY IT'S ADDRESSING
THE ACTUAL NEEDS OF FOLKS AT
LIVING COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
LOS ANGELES.
AND NOT THE NEEDS OF FOLKS THAT.
CAN COME IN AND YOU KNOW -- WEB
JOBS AND JOBS BEING BUILT IN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
I HAVE A WORKING AT THESE JOBS.
AND THE BUILDING HOUSING ALONG
RAIL LINES FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE WORKING AT THESE NEW
BUSINESSES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
DON'T WORK AT SO I MEAN THIS IS
JUST.
AGAIN IT'S A PERVASIVE ISSUE --
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
ADDRESSING -- THERE IS AGAIN A
STRONG CONCERN REGARDS OR SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS THAT'S
COMING OUT AS WELL.
SO -- BUT AGAIN THE MAIN ISSUE I
COULD SAY THAT I'M HEARING
RESONATING WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
WOULD BE AFFORDABILITY WHICH I
DON'T REALLY SEE.
A STRONGLY ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL -- BUT AGAIN WE DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORTS
BECAUSE THIS IS A BIG
CONVERSATION INPUT FROM EVERYONE --
TO FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION -- BUT
AGAIN IT'S LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER OPPONENTS TO THE BILL
IF THERE ARE IF YOU WANT TO
PLEASE STEP UP AND STATE YOUR
NAME.
AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND SIMPLY
THE FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION --
DANNY HUGO CONCERNED CITIZEN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY -- IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE THIRTY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT BECOME.
IS ONE OF THE MARTINEZ FROM LOS
ANGELES IS MORE OF A IT'S LOS
ANGELES BELIEVE THAT THIRTY
YEARS I'M IN A POSITION TO AS SB
THREE THIRTY THANK.
MY NAME IS TOMMY BEST WILLOWS
EYES CALIFORNIA -- DISABLED AND
HIS PEERS HOMELESSNESS AND I
MEAN IT IN -- I'M I'M AGAINST --
IS BE THE THIRTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH MY NAME IS
JOSEPH FOR REVIEW AND I'M IN A
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST Và SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ON AND I ON IN A
POSITION OF SB -- THREE THIRTY
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT IT IS
THERE'S A CLEAR DISCONNECT
BETWEEN ON THE BILL ON THE
CONSTITUENTS IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STANLEY CHAT MEN I'M
A RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND
I'M OPPOSED SB THREE THIRTY
BECAUSE WHEN I HEAR THE PROPOSAL
THE BILL SAY THAT IF THAT THAT'S
IN FIVE YEARS IT MAKES ME THINK
OF A BILL THAT WAS PASSED.
IN WASHINGTON NOT TOO LONG AGO
WHERE IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
GREAT DEAL THAT WAS GOING TO
GIVE LOWER TAXES THE PEOPLE BUT
THE PORTION THAT HELP THE PEOPLE
SUNSETS IN FIVE YEARS.
SO THE OFFENSE THAT IN FIVE
YEARS MAKES ME THINK THAT IF
IT'S SO GREAT WHY IS THIS
SOMETHING WITH BOTH THE CURE --
HOMELESSNESS IN THE PORT TAKE
CARE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHY
DO SOMETHING A FIVE YEARS
BECAUSE IT AND NOT ONLY DO WHAT
IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU AGAIN IF
I COULD ASK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AT THIS TIME A PUBLIC
COMMENT TO SIMPLY STATE YOUR
NAME WHAT ORGANIZATION WITH AND
THE FACT THAT YOU POSSIBLE.
DOORS ALOOF I LIVE IN THE CITY
OF SAN PEDRO I OPPOSE SB.
THREE THIRTY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARSHA GILLIAM.
I POLLS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE
THREE THIRTY I'M ALSO RESIDENTS
OF SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
NANCY SURE FROM SANTA MONICA
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB.
THREE THIRTY MY NAME IS PLEASE
MONEY IF AYE OPPOSED.
THREE THIRTY MY NAME IS LETTER
VALEN AND I OPPOSE S. B..
THREE THIRTY MY NAME'S CHARLES
STATE I'M FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IN AYE OPPOSED THREE
THIRTY SB.
THREE THIRTY THANK YOU.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE HAVE OPPOSE
A POSITION AS BILL BUT WE DO
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL
OF THE PARKING LANGUAGE -- I
THINK THAT'S A VERY POSITIVE
STEP WE DO HAVE A COUPLE TWO
THREE REMAINING CONCERNS THEY
WERE HOPING I'M TO GET A DRESSED
ONE IS THE FREEZING OF OUR FEES
AT A TIME IN WHICH WE DON'T KNOW
THE TOTALITY OF THE PROJECT.
WHICH MEANS YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO CHARGE PROJECT SPECIFIC FEES
THOSE ARE THE FEES THAT ONLY
APPLIED TO THAT INDIVIDUAL
PROJECT BASED ON ITS -- IMPACTS
IN THE COMMUNITY SO THAT'S BEEN
FROZEN OUT AND THEN ALSO -- THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW THE DEVELOPER
TO PULL THAT -- GET THEIR
APPROVAL AND NOT HAVE TO
CONSTRUCT THAT YOU'D THOSE UNITS
FOR THREE YEARS.
HE'S FOR THREE YEARS.
WHEN I BELIEVE NOW THERE DOESN'T
THAT'S GONNA GO TO HALF YEARS --
BUT NONE THE LESS TWO AND A HALF
YEARS I WITHOUT ADDRESSING THOSE
FEES IT CAN BE AS SIMPLE AS A
CITY NOT HAVE AN INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCE -- BUT DURING
YOUR TWO OR TWO AND A HALF WE
WANT TO HAVE ONE WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO APPLY THAT TO THE
DEVELOPER
IF WE'RE IN A CRISIS AND WE LIKE
TO SEE DEVELOPERS BUILD THE THE
ABILITY TO RAISE FEES DURING
THAT PERIOD MIGHT SPUR THEM TO
CONSTRUCT AND NOT JUST ON THAT
PERMIT THANK YOU.
THE SHERMAN MEMBERS DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITIES OF BURBANK
GLENDALE THE CITIES IN MARIN AND
IN THE CITY OF SOLANA BEACH.
WE APPRECIATE THE PARKING A
REMOVAL AND THINK TO THE BILL
STILL TO COME TO CONFLICT WITH
COASTAL LACK SO WE ARE WILL
REVIEW THE MINUTES AND CONTINUE
TO POST.
SIX KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION APPRECIATE ALL THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO REVISING OUR RAM BRAD.
REVISING OUR POSITION ONCE WE
SEE THOSE IMPRINT THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS ALWAYS HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY'S A
BELLFLOWER CAMARENA Là MORADO
LAGUNA HILLS PARAMOUNT RANCHO
CUCAMONGA THOUSAND OAKS IN
TORRANCE WILL SIMPLY LINER COMES
WITH THE WEAK AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION.
JILL STEWART EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
COALITION TO PRESERVE LA SIX
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL ANGRY WITH THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO PLANNING DEPARTMENT
THAT SAYS IT SAY SPOT ZONING ON
STEROIDS BILL THAT IS GOING TO
DISRUPT ALL OF THE COMMUNITY
PLANS AND OTHER PLANS.
APPROVED IN THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF IN EVERY CITY TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY AFFECTED CITIES IT'S A
DISASTER PLEASE VOTE NO THANK
YOU.
ILANA WALKED TELL COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR COALITION TO
PRESERVE LA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND WE NEED TO DRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS NOT
MARKET RATE HOUSING THANK YOU.
HEY IS ON BEHALF OF STEVE OUR
HERITAGE ORGANIZATION AND CAN
DIEGO COUNTY NONPROFIT AND WE
OPPOSE SB -- THREE THIRTY ON
BEHALF OF THE DETRIMENTAL IMPACT
THAT IT WILL HAVE ON HISTORIC
RESOURCES AND SCENIC OR SENSE OF
PLACE THANK YOU.
RECALL PRESENT A LITTLE
CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
ALSO REPRESENTING CULTURAL
ACTION NETWORK A SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION EVERYBODY THAT WE
ARE ALLIED WITH ALSO OPPOSES DID
VERY DAMAGING BILL THANK YOU.
JORGE CASTANEDA -- COALITION TO
PRESERVE LA COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
ADVISER TO THE BOYLE HEIGHTS
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND A DUES
PAYING MEMBER OF LOS ANGELES
TENNIS UNION -- WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT -- BUT WE STILL SEE THIS
AS A STREAMLINING OF MARKET RATE
AND LUXURY -- NOT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS OUTLINED
BY THE LEAGUE OF CITIES EARLIER
WE ALSO WANT TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF AN AFFECTED COUNTY.
AND HOW THAT APPLIES TO THE AND
INCORPORATE AREA AS A WHOLE
VERSUS SPECIFIC AREAS THAT MIGHT
HAVE DIFFERENT ECONOMIC
CHARACTERISTICS BUT LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
MR MEMBERS POLY ARMY HAVE THIS
ON A COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN THE CITY COUNTY ASSOCIATION
GOVERNMENTS AND CEMETERY COUNTY
ALSO OPPOSE IF I MAY
RESPECTFULLY.
TECHNICALLY THIS BILL IF IF
THERE ARE PARTS OF THE BILL THAT
IF THEY WERE WRITTEN DIFFERENTLY.
I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY CEMEX
SUBMITS EVERYBODY THAT THE
OPPOSITION COULD CHANGE EVEN
MORE SO THANK YOU.
OKAY SEAL IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF CUPERTINO AND TULARE
AND OPPOSITION.
DAVID KING TONYA WITH THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
CURRENT LETS ME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
MISTER GORE.
HE WAS CHAIRMAN -- IN THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER FOR THE
PRESENTATION EXPLANATIONS AS
WELL AS THE AMENDMENTS AND MONEY
TO A LOT OF THAT -- NEVER THE
OPPONENTS OF MAKE COMMENTS I
THINK ARE WORTH A RESPONSE -- I
STRUGGLED WITH UNDERSTANDING
SOME OF THEM SO PERHAPS YOU CAN
TELL ME THAT MEANT IT WAS
MENTIONED BY SEVERAL SPEAKERS
THAT THIS BILL IS A SPOT ZONING
BILL.
I'M I DON'T SEE REFERENCE TO
THAT IN THE LEGISLATION CAN YOU
MAYBE SPEAK TO WHAT THEY MIGHT
BE REFERRING.
TO OR RESPOND TO WHAT THEY
REFERENCED I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THEY'RE REFERRING TO BUT IT IT'S
NOT A SPOT ZONING BILL IT
DEFINITELY.
I MEAN MAYBE THEY THINK THAT
BECAUSE AND AGAIN I DON'T WANT
TO TRADE TESTIFY WERE THEIR WHAT
THEIR LOGIC IS BUT AS I
INDICATED AND AND AS I THINK
WE'VE HEARD FROM A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION I THINK THAT.
WANT SOME OF THE OTHER BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN -- WERE
INTRODUCED IN THE SESSION NO
LONGER EXIST.
THE THE SAME ARGUMENTS THEN GOT
APPLIED TO THIS BILL WITHOUT
REALLY LOOKING AT ITS CONTENT
THIS BILL DOES NOT.
INCREASE DENSITY IT DOES NOT.
CHANGE THE ZONING POLICIES OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IT TREATS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND MARKET HOUSING THE SAME SO.
WE ALREADY HEARD FROM OUR SPINE.
SORRY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THAT.
I IN I DON'T HAVE THE DATA
STATEWIDE BUT I CAN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW IN MY DISTRICT IN
OAKLAND AND BERKELEY.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS SUBMIT.
APPLICATIONS AND IT TAKES.
MINIMUM FIVE YEARS AND UP TO TEN
YEARS BEFORE THEY GET A PERMIT
AND BY THE TIME THEY GET THEIR
PERMIT FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE
[inaudible]
PROJECT.
THERE FINANCING IS COMPLETELY
OUT OF DATE.
AND THEY HAVE TO START OVER.
SO THIS BENEFITS BECAUSE WHAT IT
DOES IS SAY WHATEVER IS IN YOUR
EXISTING ZONING RULES ONCE THE
APPLICANT HAVE SUBMITTED AN
APPLICATION.
AND YOU THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HAVE I'M GONNA USE THE WERE
DEEMED COMPLETE THERE'S A LEGAL
DEFINITION FOR THAT SO I DON'T
MEAN THE LEGAL DEFINITION I MEAN.
AS IT DESCRIBES IN THE BILL THAT
YOU HAVE GIVEN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EVERYTHING THEY'VE
REQUESTED AN EVERYTHING THAT'S
DESCRIBED IN THE BILL.
THAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS
TO ANALYZE THE PERMIT.
AND AT THAT POINT OF COURSE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN.
GIVE YOU A PROJECT SPECIFIC FEET
IT DOES NOT PREVENT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR APPLYING THE
PROJECT SPECIFIC FEET THEY JUST
HAVE TO APPLY ITAT THAT POINT.
BUT THEN FROM THAT POINT ON AS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
ANALYZING IT.
IT LOCKS BEING SENT SO MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK IS
PROJECT SPECIFIC SOMEBODY I
DON'T KNOW BUT IT JUST LOCKS IT
NOW IT DOESN'T EVEN REQUIRE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. TO PROVE YOUR
PERMIT.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD DENY
IT AND THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
BILL THAT PREVENTS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM DENYING IT
OTHER THAN ANY EXISTING.
LEGISLATION FOR EXAMPLE EXISTING
STATUTE LIKE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SO AGAIN I'M
NOT SURE WELL AS POSSIBLE SURE
IF YOU WANTED.
QUESTIONS BUT YEAH I THINK I
THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SPOT
ZONING IT'S ALREADY LARGELY.
AVAILABLE IN IN DIFFERENT CITIES
AND COMMUNITIES AND AND COUNTIES.
WHAT WHAT THIS BILL IS IS IS
FACILITATING?
DEVELOPERS TO COME IN AND AND
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF IT AND
SAY WELL IF YOU DON'T GET THIS
LUXURY COMPLEX HERE IN THIS
SPECIFIC PLACE THEN I'M GOING TO
SUE YOU.
AND AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT WENT
WHEN YOU'RE REDUCING THE TIME
FRAMES YOUR XCELERATED SOME OF
THESE THINGS -- ACCELERATING TO
A POINT WHERE THEY MIGHT BE
OVERSIGHT WHERE THEY MIGHT BE --
COMPELLED TO NOT REVIEW IN THE
WAY THEY SHOULD BE REVIEWING --
EACH PROPOSAL.
AND SO THESE ARE THESE ARE REAL
ISSUES THAT YOU KNOW.
MAYBE YOU'RE NOT CREATING THEM
IMMEDIATELY BUT YOU'RE
FACILITATING.
THAT THAT SITUATION AND AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SAYING THIS IS
THE SPOT ZONING BILL BECAUSE
IT'S YOU KNOW THE THE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
EXPLOITING THAT.
IT INCREASES ARE SUBSTANTIALLY.
SO TECHNICALLY THE BILL DOES NOT
TWO SPOTS ONLY WHAT THE ARGUMENT
IS IS IF.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALREADY HAS
SPOT SOUND BUT OF COURSE THIS IS
TRYING TO RESPECT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EXISTING ZONING.
SHE WAS ABOUT TO STE IS FOR A
DEFINITION THE QUESTION BIG
CELEBRATION AT BECAUSE SPOT
ZONING WOULD BE.
WHAT I WAS ACTUALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT WITH REGARD TO THE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS IS TAKING SPECIFIC
AREAS NAY OF IN THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL WITH A
QUARTER MILE OF CERTAIN FORMS OF
TRANSIT?
IN CHANGING THE KINDS OF
ENTITLEMENTS THERE UNDER THAT
PROVISION.
WILL USUALLY IT WILL BE DELETED
YES I'M SO THAT WAS THE CLOSEST
I CAN GET AND THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN FOR THOSE
WAS TO SERVE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. FOR THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO DICTATE THE FORM.
OF OF THE OF THE DEVELOP AN
ENVELOPE THIS BILL DOES NOT DO
THIS WHAT THIS BILL SPEAKS TO IS
TIMING AND COST.
WHICH I UNDERSTAND THE POINT
ABOUT THAT FACILITATING.
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT IS ALSO TRUE
AND THIS WAS ONE OF THE OTHER
OBJECTIONS THAT WERE RAISES THE
ISSUE AROUND FOR ABILITY HE SAID
IT ALREADY BUT I THINK IT BEARS
REPEATING.
THIS BILL IS NOT LIMITED ONLY --
TO FOR MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT
THIS THE BILL APPLIES TO ALL
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING SUBSIDIZED
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS REFLECTED
IN THE SUPPORT LISTS THAT IS IN
THE ANALYSIS OF MANY OF THE
MAJOR DEVELOPERS TO BUILD
HOUSING FOR THE FORMALLY
HOMELESS -- FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES FOR SENIOR CITIZENS FOR
OTHER AFFECTED COMMUNITIES IS
THAT CORRECT YES ON IT AS YOU
SAY THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE
ABLE TO BE MORE HELPFUL TO THOSE
THAT WANT TO SEE MORE LOW INCOME
HOUSING -- IN MORE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OFTEN MARKET DEVELOPERS
PAY THE KINDS OF FEES THAT HAVE
BEEN A HALLMARK OF THIS
CONVERSATION MOST OF THIS
MORNING.
THE GOING TO HOUSING TRUST FUNDS
LIKE WHAT WE HAD IN SAN DIEGO
WHICH COULD IN TWO THINGS ONE
BILL MORE UNITS BUT THEN ALSO
MAKE THEM HOPEFULLY MORE DEEPLY
SUBSIDIZE SO YOU'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT. 80% A 100% 120% BUT MORE
LIKE 30% OR 50% A AM I WHICH
FRANKLY IS WHAT HARD WORKING
PEOPLE EARN IN MANY PARTS OF OF
SAN DIEGO.
WHO CAN'T STILL FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE I DON'T WANT OTHER ISSUE
THAT WAS MENTIONED WAS RUN
HISTORIC RESOURCES THE SYSTEM
MEAN IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
ME?
THIS BILL WOULD IN NO WAY --
ELIMINATE OR MODIFY LOCAL A
HISTORIC RESOURCES LEGISLATION
ORDINANCES.
IT DOES NOT SO IN OTHER WORDS
YOU ARE CORRECT IT DOES NOT.
IMPACT IF A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ALREADY HAS HISTORIC
PRESERVATION ORDINANCE FOR
EXAMPLE.
OR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DESIGN
REVIEW STANDARDS OR IN THE CASE
OF CERTAIN OF OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES IF THEY HAVE COASTAL
HEIGHT LIMITS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT OVERTURN
KNOWS OR INTERFERE WITH THOSE
AND IN FACT WE EVEN PUT IN AN
EXPLICIT AMENDMENT.
THAT BECAUSE THERE WAS FEAR IN
THERE WAS CAN THERE WAS A LOT OF
MYTHS OUT THERE THAT THIS WOULD.
OVERTURN COASTAL HEIGHT LIMITS
AND SO WE PUT THAT LANGUAGE WE
DID IT WE DIDN'T NEED TO MAKE
THE LANGUAGE EXPLICIT BECAUSE IT
ALREADY DIDN'T DO THAT BUT CHEST.
BECAUSE PERCEPTION SO OFTEN.
UNFORTUNATELY RULES THE DAY WE
PUT EXPLICIT LANGUAGE IN.
SO I APPRECIATE CLEAR FIND THAT --
IT'S A DATE WITH A FORTY FIVE
YEAR REVIEW FOR STRUCTURES THAT
ARE OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD
THEY MUST GO TO A STORE
RESOURCES BOARD FOR
CONSIDERATION.
IF TEAM TO STORE IT THAT OFTEN --
IMPACTS THE WAY THAT THE
PROPERTY MAY BE USED GOING
FORWARD YOUR BILL WOULD NOT
CHANGE CORRECT -- SO LASTLY I
JUST WANT TO GET TO THE
AMENDMENTS YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
THE ANALYSIS YOU MADE MENTION OF
TOUCH.
I BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS --
INSIDE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCLUSIVE OF REMOVING THE
SECTION ABOUT SUBSTANDARD
HOUSING YEAH WITH REGARD -- TO
CODE COMPLIANCE YES -- BECAUSE
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT I COULD
NOT HAVE SUPPORTED -- ANY SORT
OF ALLOWING OF SLOW MORE SIXTEEN
OPERATE -- I THINK THE PROCESS
IS FAR TOO SUBJECTIVE ALREADY
ACTING FRANKLY THAT'S HOW IT
KIND OF WORKS BUT EXPLICITLY
STATING THAT FROM THE STATE
WOULD NOT BE SOMETHING I COULD
SUPPORT.
THAT WAS A SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE
ACCEPTING SO THAT'S DONE THE
REMAINING TWO THINGS WERE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR HEARING
OUT THE CONCERNS.
THAT I VOICE ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS -- YOU MENTION THE
PARKING REQUIREMENT YOU'RE
REMOVING THAT PARTICULAR SECTION
CAN YOU STATE ON THE RECORD WHAT
SECTION THAT IS THAT YOU INTEND
YES.
WE WILL BE DELETING [inaudible]
IT IS [inaudible]
BE.
ONE AND THE ONE IS ALL THE
REFERENCE TO THE LIFTING OF
PARKING MINIMUMS AND THE AT THAT
THERE WOULD.
ONLY BE ALLOWED A POINT FIVE
PARKING SPOT AND FORGET ALL THE
LANGUAGE ANYWAY IT WOULD BE
DELETED.
AND SO IN A COMMUNITY LIKE MINE
IN SAN DIEGO IN THE CITY SAN
DIEGO WHERE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A
PARKING MINIMUMS.
BY DOING THAT THE LOCAL RULE
STILL APPLIES SO WHAT -- IS
APPLICABLE IN SOLANA BEACH WHICH
I'M GONNA REPRESENTING WOULD
REMAIN WHAT HAPPENS ANY CITY SAN
DIEGO WOULD REMAIN THE BILL
WOULD NO LONGER TOUCH THAT YES
ANY.
CITY AFFECTED OR COMMUNITY
AFFECTED BY THE BILL.
THAT HAS A REQUIRED MARKING
PARKING MINIMUM EVEN IF THAT
REQUIRED PARKING MINIMUM IS A
QUARTER MILE FROM MERRILL STOP
WHICH IS ALL THE BILL HAD IN
THERE BUT WHATEVER EVEN IF IT
HAD THAT.
WITH THE DELETION OF THAT
SECTION.
IN ALL.
COMMUNITIES EXISTING PARKING
MINIMUMS WOULD REMAIN THE SAME.
AND AS I MENTIONED MY INTENT FOR
TRYING TO LIFT PARKING MINIMUMS
WASN'T TO PROHIBIT PARKING IF
THE APPLICANT IN THE CITY WANTED
TO INCLUDE PARKING I'VE NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
IT WAS TO HELP REDUCE COSTS OF
MARKET RATE BECAUSE PARKING
GREATLY THREE INCREASES THE COST.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF
OPPOSITION AND BECAUSE I DIDN'T
WANT TO AS THEY SAY THROW THE
BABY OUT WITH THE BATH WATER IN
LOSE THE OTHER VERY ESSENTIALLY
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THIS BILL.
I'M WILLING TO DELETE IT AND WE
WILL BE.
TAKEN OUT AMENDMENT AND DELETING
THAT SECTION THANK YOU SIR ONE
LAST QUESTION SENATOR OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
SO WITH REGARD TO VOTER ENACTED
MEASURES YES ARE YOU ALSO
MENTIONED THAT YOU'LL BE
REMOVING.
ANY SECTIONS OUT REGARD TO THAT
SO ON THE BILL THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
LIMITED IN THEIR ABILITY TO DOWN
ZONE IF THEY HAVE THAT PROVISION
ALREADY THERE ARE SOME.
AREAS WHERE EITHER BY.
BY COUNSEL ENACTMENT OR BY VOTER
ENACTMENT.
THAT -- CERTAIN LAND USE CHANGES
OR CERTAIN TYPES OF PROJECTS
MUST GO BEFORE VOTER APPROVAL.
AND THE BILL ORIGINALLY.
SB THREE THIRTY WAS ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN TO TAKE EFFECT FOR TEN
YEARS AND BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
CRISIS IT WAS.
YOU KNOW TRYING TO HELP
FACILITATE.
DEALING WITH OUR OF OUR HOUSING
IN THAT TEN YEAR PERIOD.
AND YOU KNOW JUST FOR A LIMITED
TIME SUSPENDING SOME THINGS.
BUT AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
REACTION TO THE SUSPENSION OF A
VOTER APPROVAL AND BECAUSE NOW
THE BILL IS ONLY IN EFFECT FOR
FIVE YEARS.
AND OF COURSE AS WE KNOW THE
PERIOD OF TIME IT TAKES TO GET
SOMETHING ON A BIT FOR FIRST A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO ACT AND
SECONDARILY SOMETHING TO GET ON
THE BALLOT.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF VOTER APPROVAL
EVEN BEING RELEVANT IN THE FIVE
YEAR PERIOD IS LOW SO IT WAS
EASY FOR ME TO TO JUST. TO LEAD
THAT AND I WILL BE TAKING THAT
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD TO LEAD
SECTION F..
ONE WHICH AGAIN SUSPENSE THE
VOTER APPROVAL OFFICIAL THAT
WOULD BE GONE APPRECIATING
SPECIFICALLY JUST TO DRAW A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IN SAN DIEGO WE HAVE
EXTREME INTEREST IN COSTA HEIGHT
LIMITS YES -- AND YOU HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN CLEAR ON THE
SENATE SIDE ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD AND WOULD NOT DO THERE
CONTINUES TO BE A PERCEPTION
THAT THIS BILL WHILE IT WOULD
PROHIBIT -- WHAT WOULD NOT
REMOVE THE COSTA HAD LIMITED
VOTERS ENACTED MANY YEARS AGO
RIGHT BUT IT THE BILL TO THE
MINUTE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IT ALSO PRECLUDE THE CITY
COUNCIL BY A MAJORITY VOTE? FOR
OVERTURNING THE THE CITIZENS
EFFORTS WITH REGARD TO COST
ISLAND THE ONLY REASON.
SO LET ME I AM NOT HEDGING ON
THAT AT ALL IT'S JUST THAT EVERY
CITY HAT AND EVERY.
SO SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE VOTER
INITIATIVES THAT RESTRICT THEIR
ABILITY TO DO SOMETHING SOME DO
NOT RIGHT SO IF I HAPPEN TO BE
IN A CITY WHERE THERE'S NO VOTER
RESTRICTION.
ON WHAT MY CITY CAN DO BY
MAJORITY VOTE THIS BILL DOES NOT
INTERFERE WITH ANY OF THE
EXISTING RULES.
IF THE CITY.
HAS ALREADY.
VOTER INITIATIVE THAT DOES NOT
ALLOW THEM TO CHANGE SOMETHING
MY MAJORITY VOTE THAT IS
PRESERVED IN RETAINED THIS BILL
DOES NOT TOUCH THAT.
BUT IF COURSE IF THERE IS
ANOTHER CITY THAT CAN CHANGE
SOMETHING BY MAJORITY VOTE
BECAUSE THIS DOES NOT INTERFERE
WITH WHATTHE CITY CAN DO.
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO DO THAT I
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCE OF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IF THE VOTERS
APPROVED A MEASURE SAYING THEIR
BABY MAY BE NO HEIGHT.
THOUGH CONSTRUCTION BE ON A
THIRTY FOOT HEIGHT LIMIT.
NO EXCEPTIONS THIS BILL WILL NOT
CHANGED CORRECT ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT THANK YOU I WANT TO JUST
WIND UP BY SAYING.
THAT I APPRECIATE THE
MISCONCEPTIONS WITH THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY WE DEALT WITH SOME
PRETTY HEAVY LEGISLATION IN THIS
SESSION I DO THINK BASED ON SOME
THE INDIVIDUAL CONVERSATIONS
I'VE HAD WITH CONSTITUENTS IN
OTHERS.
THIS BILL IS OFTEN CONFLATED
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
GIVES A TIME LINE FOR ANY
APPLICANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT IF YOU WILL.
THIS BILL IN NO WAY MANDATES
THAT LOCAL DECISION MAKERS MUST
OF A PERMIT A PARTICULAR PROJECT
THEY MAY IS PERMITTED AS MUCH AS
THEY MAY DENY IT.
AROUND THE DIFFERENCE IS A
CERTAINTY OF TIMING AND WRITING
T. OF COST YEAH I THINK THOSE
TWO THINGS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THE RULES DO NOT CHANGE
DURING THE PROCESS OF THE
APPLICATION BEING ANALYZED I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
VERTICALLY AS SOMEONE WHO SPENT
HIS PROFESSIONAL CAREER WORKING
IN.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS A FORMER
HOUSING COMMISSIONER I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE APPLICATION
PROCESS SEES WE'RE DEVELOPERS
ARE SEEKING TO BUILD HOUSING FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES MUST APPLY THEY
SOMETIMES ARE ANNUAL OR SEMI
ANNUAL.
IF YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU MISS SEPTIC AROUND THE
FUNDING AND YOU MUST WAIT FOR
THE NEXT ONE BUT IN THE MEANTIME
FEES IN A CONSTRUCTION COST OF
CHANGE THAT MAY MAKE A PROJECT
THAT STUFF'S GOING TO GET SOME
AWARD.
BE IN FEASIBLE WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THERE'S FEWER HOMES AT PRICES
THAT PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY
AFFORD I THINK THAT THIS BROUGHT
THIS BILL AND DID EXTENT THAT'LL
HELP FACILITATE -- BUT PROCESS
FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING PROJECTS
TO PROCEED I THINK IS BRILLIANT
I'M I'M NOT SO ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED WITH MARKET RATE
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE GUESS WHAT
THE BANKS WILL STILL BE THERE
THEY DON'T HAVE FUNDING MOUNT
THEY DON'T HAVE DEADLINES.
THEY WILL ALWAYS BE THERE AND
CERTAINLY WITH MARKET RATE
DEVELOPMENT PEOPLE ALWAYS FIND A
WAY RIGHT BUT I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE PROVIDING HERE IS THIS IN
T. OF PROCESS THAT FRANKLY
SHOULD BE THERE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE IN A
HOUSING CRISIS.
PEOPLE DESERVE A STRAIGHT ANSWER
ABOUT WHAT SOMETHING IS GOING TO
COST AND HOW LONG IT WILL TAKE
THAT IS TRUE FOR MISTER WOULD
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE USE A MOMENT
AGO DOING ADDITION TO HIS HOUSE.
TO SOMEBODY'S GONNA MASTER PLAN
DEVELOPMENT OVER SOMEBODY'S
DOING AN INFILL DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL GET HOMELESS PEOPLE OFFER
STREET.
I THINK THAT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE I'M ANXIOUS TO SEE IF THIS
IS ENACTED HOW IT WORKS BUT I
SUSPECT THAT WHEN YOU TELL
PEOPLE WHAT SOMETHING'S GONNA
COST AND HOW LONG IT'LL TAKE.
IT IS MORE LIKELY THAT MORE
HOMES WILL GET BILL AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE PRIORITY
LIST IN TERMS OF WHO CAN
ACTUALLY SUCCESSFULLY PENCIL
PROJECT.
IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND BY GOD WE SHOULD HELP THEM
SO -- I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS I KNOW YOU'RE TAKING
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENT SOME A
STATE VERY CLEARLY RIGHT NOW IF
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN FOR SOME ODD
REASON YOUR WOMAN OF YOUR WORD
BUT I KNOW IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW I WILL NOT SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I'M HAPPY IS FOR THE
BILL TODAY.
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ASKING FOR THESE
CLARIFICATION SO THAT.
IT'S ON THE RECORD EXACTLY WHAT
THE BILL DOES A REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND I THINK AS WE
KNOW.
VERY COMMONLY IS LEGISLATORS WE
ARE APPROACHED BY WAY ANY ENTITY
WHETHER IT'S LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS WHOEVER ADVOCATES WHO
SAY WE CHEST ONE CERTAINTY WE
JUST WANT.
WEEK WE DON'T MIND IF THE STATE
YOU KNOW ENACT SOMETHING WE JUST
DON'T WANT TO BE ALSO. TO HAVE
THE RULES CHANGED WHEN WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF SOMETHING SO I
THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
BILL IS TRYING TO DO AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CLARIFICATIONS [inaudible]
MR MENTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS AT FIRST IT FOR
ME -- GOING BACK EVEN IN MY CITY
COUNCIL DAYS.
THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT I
HAVE INCLUDES ESSENTIALLY THAT
THE CITY COUNCIL DISTRICT I
REPRESENTED -- WHEN I WAS A
SENIOR CITY COUNCIL MEMBER I'M
FORTUNATE THAT THE PLANNING
GROUPS IN THAT COMMUNITY GROUPS
AND IN MY DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
VERY GOOD -- THEY HAVE BEEN
REASONABLE THEY HAVE.
NOT THROWN UP ARTIFICIAL -- SORT
OF COMPLAINTS THEY'VE JUST BEEN
THOUGHTFUL AND CONSIDERATE AND
AND AND BY AND LARGE ME MAYBE
NOT IN EVERY INSTANCE BUT
OVERALL CERTAINLY -- VERY
PLEASED TO WORK WITH THEM --
DURING MY TIME AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL FOUND THEIR COM.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO TO DEVELOP
A SIGNIFICANT PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT FOUND THEIR COMMENTS TO
BE HELPFUL IN THE WORK THEY DID
TO BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL WE HAVE
A GOOD COMMUNITY IN NO SMALL
PART BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY
GROUPS -- THAT I'M FORTUNATE TO
REPRESENT.
WHEN THIS BILL CAME OUT?
MY COMMUNITY GROUPS AND THE
CHAIRS -- WERE.
PRETTY UNITED VERY UNITED LEE
OPPOSED TO IT -- AND IT WAS JUST.
CAN ONLY KIND OF UNUSUAL BECAUSE
A LOT OF THE TIME THEY DON'T
REALLY.
A PAY AS MUCH ATTENTION OR MAYBE
EVEN CARE AS MUCH WHAT GOES ON
IN SACRAMENTO BUT ON THIS.
ONE THEY WERE VERY UNITED -- SO
I HAD AT I WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING THAT OPPOSITION
DISCUSSING THEIR COMPLAINTS.
I WANT TO REALLY CREDIT -- YOU
SENATOR SKINNER FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE ON THIS BOTH
YOU KNOW AFTER APPRECIATIVE OF
OUR INTERACTIONS BUT SECONDLY
JUST THE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THE
AMENDMENTS -- AND THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE IS YOU'VE MOVED
THROUGH THIS THIS PROCESS I WILL
SAY THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SENEGAL BROUGHT UP -- A
CERTAINTY OF PROCESS THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
IN LARGE PARTS OF THE STATE --
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT LOCALITIES ARE GONNA NEED
TO WORK ON IN ALL THIS AS MUCH
AS THE STATE GOOD BAD OR
INDIFFERENT SOMETIMES WEIGHS IN
ON THIS.
A LOT OF THESE ISSUES IN WE TALK
ABOUT IN ADDITION.
YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL HAD THE
HORROR STORIES OF SOMEBODY
TRYING TO HAVE IN ADDITION TO
THEIR HOME OR DO SOMETHING HOME
IT TAKES HIM. TWO YEARS
[inaudible]
AND COMFORT STATION IN MY
DISTRICT TOOK FOUR YEARS I MEAN
IT'S JUST.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE THINGS
ARE ABSOLUTELY ABSURD AND TO
LOOK AT THEN POINT FOR
LOCALITIES AND TO POINT THE
FINGER AT SACRAMENTO I THINK ON
SOME OF THESE THINGS IS.
A LITLE BIT DISINGENUOUS -- SO
FOR ME TODAY I I'M ACTUALLY
GONNA LAUGH THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I NEED TO TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS BACK THESE MEMBERS
MOST OF THEM I BELIEVE HAPPENED
THIS MORNING I HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO MEET WITH MY
PLAYING GROUPS AND AND HAVE THEM
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE IT MAY
REMOVE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW IT SEEMS
LIKE SO THE IT'S HIGHLY POSSIBLE
MAY REMOVE THE OPPOSITION OF THE
COMMUNITY GROUPS BUT I DID WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT.
THESE WERE FROM WHERE I SIT I
WASN'T I WISH I WAS UNFORTUNATE
I DON'T REPRESENT A LOT OF AND
READ IT AND REASONABLE MESS
AROUND REASONABLE -- GROUPS WHO
JUST SORT OF CAN I COME UP WITH
COMPLAINTS IN ORDER TO BE
OBSTRUCTIVE THAT'S NOT THE CASE
AT ALL AND THAT'S WHY I'M GIVING
THEM.
GIVING WHAT THEY SAY A LOT OF
CREDENCE BUT I WILL. TO TO YOU --
I WILL SAY -- I WILL MEET WITH
HIM AGAIN I WILL I WILL MAKE
SURE THEY GET ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION SO THEY CAN LOOK AT
THIS AND REVIEW THIS AND THESE
PLANNING GROUPS CAN THEN WAY AND
AGAIN AS THIS.
MOVES FOR BUT I WANTED TO
EXPLAIN TO MEMBER AND TELL YOU
THAT I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU.
DESERVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
CREDIT.
I'LL MAKE A FEW COMMENTS AT THIS
POINT FOR SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR COURAGE.
IN MOVING FORWARD SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT IDEAS -- AND I WILL
ALSO SAY FROM MY OBSERVATION OF
HOW THIS BILL HAS BEEN PORTRAYED
I THINK THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MIS CHARACTERIZATIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL AROUND POTENTIALLY --
SAYING THIS IS A SPOT SONY BILLS
BEEN REPEATED BEFORE THAT
SOMEHOW TURBOCHARGING PRODUCTION
THAT IT SOMEHOW -- FAVORING ONE
TYPE FOR ASKING THIS YEAR'S A
QUESTIONS AND I THINK REALLY DO
HELP TO ELUCIDATE THAT THIS IS
NOT.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THIS IS A
BILL ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
DURING THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY CITIES
ARE NOT BACKTRACKING THAT CITIES
ARE DOING WHAT THEY SAY THEY'RE
GOING TO DO -- AND PROVIDING
PREDICTABILITY AND FAIRNESS AND
TRANSPARENCY AND CERTAINTY TO
THAT PROCESS I AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEEP
ENGAGEMENT I KNOW WITH EVERYONE
ON THIS COMMITTEE INCLUDING MY
STAFF AND MY OFFICE.
AS WELL AS WITH THE PUBLIC --
AND FRANKLIN TAKING SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT -- I WAS HOPING
YOU WEREN'T GOING TO HAVE TO
TAKE -- BUT I APPRECIATE THIS IS
A POLITICAL PROCESS AND THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS. TO THE OPPOSITION.
I WANT TO SAY YOU HAVE MANY
ALLIES HERE -- I AM AN ALLY OF
YOURS I KNOW THAT THE SENATOR
AUTHOR IS AN ALLY AS WELL AS
SOMEONE WHO IS AUTHORED A TENET
BILL EVERY YEAR I HAVE BEEN HERE --
AS SOMEONE WHO IS AUTHORED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNNY
MEASURES AND I THINK ANYONE LSE
IN THIS HOUSE -- WE AGREE THAT
WE HAVE TO DO MORE FOR TENANTS
WE HAVE TO DO MORE AROUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- BUT I
THINK SOMEHOW THE NOTION OF NOT
HOLDING CITIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IF WE DON'T
DO THAT THAT IS GOING TO
EXACERBATE THE PLATE. FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
IT WILL LEAD TO FURTHER
GENTRIFICATION AND THIS IS WHY --
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD -- I DO
APPRECIATE AND I SUSPECT THEY'LL
BE MANY MORE CONVERSATIONS AS WE
DO THIS BUT MY HOPE IS.
THAT WE CAN BRING TOGETHER THE
OPPOSITION AND THE SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL WE NEED ALL THE ABOVE
SOLUTIONS WE NEED MORE TEN A
PROTECTIONS WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES
THAT HAVE LAID OUT RULES TO
BUILD HOUSING OR ACTUALLY GONNA
DO THAT AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
DOWN ZONE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO CREATE MORE
TORRANCE AND BUILDING HOUSING
THEY'RE GOING TO DO WHAT WE
NEEDED TO DO DURING THIS CRISIS
SO -- CENTERS THANK YOU -- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL I
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO PRESENT A
FEW BILLS IN OTHER COMMITTEES AT
THIS POINT SO NATURALLY HE FOR
THE DIRECT VOTE BUT I DO INTEND
TO VOTE FOR AT THE RIGHT TIME.
AND WITH THAT I THINK THERE WERE
A FEW OTHER HANDS MISS EMMA.
THANK YOU -- AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION AT THE AUTHOR
HAS BEEN VERY ENGAGING -- IN
HELPING US ALL ONE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE BILL DOES AND DOES NOT
DO BUT ALSO LISTENING TO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT COME FROM VERY
DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THINK -- YOU KNOW
AS SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS THE
CENTER BECAUSE I SOMETIMES THINK
THAT SOME OF THE APPROACHES THAT
COME LEAVE US.
OUT OF THE EQUATION AND THINKING
ABOUT IT BUT YOU HAVE -- AND AND
I WANT TO CLARIFY TWO DIFFERENT
POINTS I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO -- WENT THROUGH SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT I SHARED AS
WELL BUT THERE'S TWO OTHER
CONCERNS THAT A PRODUCT THAT I'M
HOPING THAT YOU CAN RESPOND TO
ONE IS THERE -- A IN OPPOSITION
COMMENT THERE WAS SOME CONCERN
THAT THIS COULD CONFLICT WITH
THE COASTAL ACT AND I JUST
WANTED TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE --
AND YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHETHER OR
NOT THIS COULD CONFLICT WITH THE
COSTA ACT WHICH IS OF COURSE
IMPORTANT IN OUR STATE.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD CONFLICT WITH THE
COASTAL ACT AND IN FACT IT WOULD
HAVE TO BE FOR ME TO PUT
ANYTHING IN THE BILL. TO
CONFLICT WITH THE COASTAL ACT
WOULD REQUIRE IT WOULD HAVE TO
BILL KEYED AS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
BECAUSE THE COASTAL ACTORS
OBVIOUSLY VOTER APPROVED
INITIATIVE.
SO THAT THAT JUST HELPS YOU KNOW
NEED TO TAKE MY WORD ALONE BUT
THAT AS IT IS NOT KEY TO TWO
THIRDS VOTE IT HAS NOTHING IN IT
THAT IN ANY WAY INTERFERES WITH
ANY -- STATEWIDE VOTER
INITIATIVES THANK YOU AND THE
SECOND PIECE IS A AS A DISTRICT
THAT'S BEEN IMPACTED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS -- A BAY AND ALSO
THAT'S AYE HAS HOUSING -- IN THE
COASTAL AREA WE SEE EROSION AND
CLIFFS -- CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE IN THIS
BILL -- FOR SOME OF THESE AREAS --
I KNOW ONE OF THE CONCERNS
EYEBROWS LIKE WILD THE
TOPOGRAPHY HAS CHANGED -- IN
SOME OF THESE AREAS AND THEY
CAN'T REPLACE -- THE STOCK IN
THAT PARTICULAR AREA BUT CAN YOU
JUST SPEAK TO THIS AND HOW THIS
MITIGATES SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS --
FOR COMMUNITIES CERTAINLY SO.
JUST LET'S USE FIRE FOR A MOMENT
AS AN EXAMPLE SO WE HEAR NOW
VERY MUCH DISCUSSION AROUND THE
WE WE WHICH IS THAT URBAN.
WILDLAND INTERFACE WHICH IS
WHERE SOME OF OUR FIRES START.
AND THERE IS SOME CONCERN THAT.
ARE THE VERY FACT THAT MANY OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
ALLOWED FOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE
WE WE HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
INCREASE OUR SEVERITY OF FIRES
OR AT LEAST THE LOSS OF HOUSING
DUE TO FIRES.
SO NOW WHAT'S INTERESTING IS --
MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO A FIRE IN IT WHO WE
WE áREA HAVE NOT CHOSEN TO
CHANGE THE ZONING OF THAT AREA
THEY HAVE PRIMARILY ALLOWED. FOR
THE REBUILDING **** I WAS ON
THEIR BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL
DURING THE OAKLAND BERKELEY
TUNNEL FIRE WHICH PRIOR TO THE
COFFEE FIRE IN THE PARADISE WAS
V..
HI WORST FIRE IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY IN TERMS OF LOSS OF
UNITS -- BUT WE DID NOT DENOUNCE
OWN IT WHATSOEVER AND ALLOWED.
FOR THE JURISDICTION THAT YOU
KNOW TO TO REBUILD NOW THERE IS
SOME I SAY ALL THAT BECAUSE SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE THINKING
ABOUT WHETHER THEY WOULD MODIFY.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO ADD MORE
PROTECTIONS THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD PREVENT
THEM FROM DOING SO.
AND THE ONLY THING IN THIS BILLS
IT RESTATES EXISTING STATUTE
WHICH IS THE NO NET LOSS.
IN THE NO NET LOSS OWNING SAYS
IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHANGES
THEIR ZONING.
IF THEY YOU KNOW REDUCE THE
DENSITY WHERE THEY'VE ALREADY
ALLOWED A CERTAIN AMOUNT THAT
THEY WOULD JUST HAVE.
TO REPLACE IT ELSEWHERE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
SO WOULD NOT PREVENT THEM FROM
EITHER LIMITING COASTAL FOR FOR
EROSION PURPOSES LIMITING
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT OR LIMITING
WILL BE DEVELOPMENT AND AT THE
SAME TIME STILL KEEP IN PLACE
THAT WE'RE NOT LOSING GROUND IN
STOCK AND YES AREAS THAT ARE
HARD TO FIND PERFECT -- I I
APPRECIATE HOW MUCH YOU'VE
WORKED AT THIS AGAIN I THINK
COLLEAGUES HAVE SHARED THIS -- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY --
AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT EASY THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED I JUST IN
MY THREE YEARS HERE -- A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN A HOUSING BILLS
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AND NONE OF
THEM ARE THE PERFECT.
ANSWER TO ANY OF THIS A THING TO
THOSE -- IN OPPOSITION IS
PARTICULAR TRADE TENANT GROUPS
WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHAT TO DO
BUT I THINK THE NUMBER OF BILLS
WE HAVE SHOWS THAT THERE'S NOT
ONE BILL THAT SOLVES AT ALL --
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH SO QUIRK SILVA.
I WON'T BE REDUNDANT BUT SAY
THAT AGAIN JUST THIS YEAR BEING
ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE WE'VE
SEEN SOME SERIOUS LEGISLATION
AND WE HAVE -- MOVE FORWARD MANY
BOLD PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
SOME AGREE WITH AND SOME DON'T.
BUT THE INTENT HERE IS TO FOCUS
ON THE CURRENT SITUATION WHICH
IS.
NOT ONLY A HOUSING CRISIS BUT
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE DYING ON OUR
STREETS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN ORANGE COUNTY WE'VE HAD JUST
FIFTEEN NEW DEATHS IN THE MONTH
OF MAY.
WHICH TAKES US WELL OVER THREE
HUNDRED DEATHS SINCE LAST YEAR.
WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THERE IS
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL WHEN IT
COMES TO ZONING WHEN IT COMES TO
PLANNING -- BUT UNLESS WE START
TO USE MULTIPLE APPROACHES AND
GET OUR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES OUR
LOCAL ELECTED LEADERS. TO DO
MORE WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE SAME OUTCOMES -- SO AS
THIS WAS NOTED IT DOES SOME
THINGS BUT IT DOESN'T DO A LOT
OF THINGS -- BUT EVERY UP PIECE
OF THIS PUZZLE TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS -- AND TO GET
PEOPLE HOUSE ARE YOU CENTRAL --
SO I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL I WILL
TELL YOU I HAVE SEVERAL BILLS --
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THAT AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
NOTED -- WE HAVE TO TRY MANY
THINGS SOME OF THEM.
MAY NOT BE AS EFFECTIVE AS
OTHERS BUT WE CANNOT BE AT THIS
TIME REDUCING REDUCING ANY TYPE
OF HOUSING AND WE ALL TO OFTEN
HAVE SEEN.
UP PLANS TABLED UP LOCAL A CITY
COUNCILS PLANS REJECTED BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT THEM IN THEIR
NEIGHBOR HOOD OR AND SO FORTH SO
AGAIN THIS IS A STEP IN --
KEEPING THINGS CERTAIN AND
MOVING FORWARD SO I DO SUPPORT
IT [inaudible]
THE GABLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND I
JUST WANNA ALSO -- THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER APPROACH AND FOR
ALL OF FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS A LOT OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS REPORT TO ME
IT'S I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY I WANT.
TO THANK UP MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO WHO ASKED A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD AND
CLARIFIED A LOT OF THOSE THINGS
WHICH REPORT TO ME SO I'M NOT
GONNA.
RETRIED BACKGROUND I DO -- WANT
TO SAY THAT -- IT AND I THINK
YOU SUGGEST AS I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF MISINFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL REALLY DIES AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE -- YOU KNOW
I LOOKED AT SOME OF THE
OBJECTIONS TO THIS BILL IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT I'VE SEEN IN IN
OPPOSITION LETTERS.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THEIR
CONFLATING DIFFERENT BILLS AND
I'LL JUST SAY IT SEEMS LIKE A
LOT OF THESE ARGUMENTS ABOUT
AGAINST SB FIFTY AND THIS BILL
IS NOT SB.
FIFTY THEY ARE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT BELLS THEIR DIFFERENT
APPROACHES AND REALLY WHEN I
SUCH OFF MY STAFF WE WENT
THROUGH THE ARGUMENTS AND APPLY
THEM TO THE TAX INCLUDING YOU
KNOW THE TEXAS IT WILL BE READ
WITH YOUR MINUTES THEY JUST THEY
JUST DON'T ADD UP -- AND THEY'RE
NOT CONSISTENT WITH WHAT I THINK
THE APPROACH OF THIS BILL IS AND
WHAT THE WHAT WITH THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE SIZE SO.
I'D REALLY ENCOURAGE A LOT OF
THE FOLKS ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL TO GO BACK AND READ THE
TEXT OF THE BILL TO LOOK AT WHAT
IT ACTUALLY DOES BECAUSE IT'S
VERY VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
SOME OF THE ARGUMENT THAT FOLKS
ARE MAKING.
I REPRESENT A VERY SUBURBAN
DISTRICT I'M UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT
THE FACT THAT I LIVE IN THE
BURBS I LIKE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
THAT I'M ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR MY
KIDS.
AND THE SUGGESTION THAT THIS IS
GONNA SOMEHOW DESTROY THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY -- I THINK IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS IT'S NOT GOING TO DO
THAT AND I ACTUALLY THINK.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS AN APARTMENT --
I DESCRIBE IT IS RELATIVELY
MODEST IN COMMONSENSE I THINK
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOLKS TO
PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY AND
TIMING AND COST TO WHAT THE
RULES OF THE ROAD WILL BE.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING AS AS
OUR CULTURE SAN DIEGO SAID THE
FUNCTION EXPECT FROM GOVERNMENT
AND WE'RE NOT REQUIRING FOLKS
TOPS OWN.
THEIR TO DO ANY OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS SIMPLY -- ASKING
THE GOVERNMENT TO HELP US
CONSISTENT SEVERAL SO FOLKS CAN
HAVE A REASONABLE EXPECTATION
WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING ABOUT.
AND YOU KNOW I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY THE BACKDROP
OF THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING CRISIS
IN OUR STATE.
FOLKS ARE DYING ON THE STREETS
WE SAW THE NUMBERS FROM THE MOST
RECENT HOMES COUNT IN THE CITY
OF LA AND THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR CITIES.
AND SO WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING MORE I THINK THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE KNOW THAT THE
PRODUCTION PIECE.
AND PARTICULARLY THE PRODUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE
HAVE THE MOST.
SIGNIFICANT ADVOCATES HERE YOU
KNOW TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BUT WE KNOW THAT THAT'S A
KEY PART TO SOLVING THIS CRISIS
IS PRODUCING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO -- FOR THOSE REASONS
ARE GONNA BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY I AM GOING TO
RESERVE MY RIGHT ON THE FLOOR IT
IS IMPORTANT TO ME THAT SOME OF
THESE AMENDMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SUGGESTED -- ARE
ARE TAKEN BUT I I YOU KNOW I
KNOW THE YOU TO BE A PERSON OF
OF YOUR WORD AND I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW AS THIS BILL MOVES FOR
HOPEFULLY IT'S GOING TO GET TO
THE PLACE IN IN FINAL STATUTORY
LANGUAGE WHERE.
RIGHT TO VOTE FOR ON THE FLOOR
BUT I DO REALLY WANT TO COMMEND
YOU.
I THINK THAT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
THE APPROACH WE NEED TO BE
TAKING -- AND I I WANT TO BE
THERE TO HELP YOU EXPLAIN TO
FOLKS THAT THE ARGUMENTS AGAINST
THIS BILL ARE JUST NOT ACCURATE
IN THE DON'T REFLECT THE BILL AS
IT IS AND WHAT IT DOES IS TO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
IF THERE IS -- NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO A IS
THERE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB.
THREE THREE ZERO MOVED AND
SECONDED ON THE CALL -- SENATOR
SKINNER A YOU YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANKS SO MUCH AND YOU HAVE ON
YOUR CONSENT CALENDAR ANOTHER
BILL OF MINE SB EIGHTEEN AND I
ONLY RAISE IT BECAUSE THAT BILL.
WAS DESIGNED TO ASSIST OUR OUR
TENANTS AND ADD SOME TENER
PROTECTIONS IN IT WHAT
ORIGINALLY CALLED.
FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT IN LEGAL ASSISTANCE
AND EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE --
THOSE TWO THINGS WERE INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET WHICH ALL OF US
JUST ADOPTED SO THERE IS NOW
MONEY THAT WILL BE GIVEN TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
FOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO TENANTS
AND EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
SO NOW THE ONLY THING REMAINING
IN THE BILL IS A CONTINUATION OF
PROTECTIONS. TO TENANTS THAT WE
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED DURING
THE FORECLOSURE CRISIS SO THAT
IF THE TENANT IS IN A BUILDING
THAT IS FOR CLOSED ON THEY HAVE
MORE PROTECTIONS -- SO I BRING
THAT UP ONLY.
TO PUT IN THE CONTEXT OF WITH
MANY PEOPLE HAVE RAISED
QUESTIONS ROMA WHITE DOESN'T
THIS BILL SB THREE THIRTY
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER
LEGISLATION THAT DOES.
SO SB THREE THIRTY DOES WHAT THE
GREAT DISCUSSION THAT YOU ALL
HAD -- SO I WON'T REPEAT IT.
AND DE THE MOTION IS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS AND I
COMMIT TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT I
DESCRIBED AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATEAND UNDERSTAND THAT
ALL OF YOU A RESERVE YOUR RIGHT.
TO WHETHER YOU CAST AN AYE VOTE
ON THE FLOOR BASED ON WHAT THAT
FINAL BILL LOOKS LIKE BUT YOU
HAVE MY WORD AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR A VOTE.
AND WITH THAT THE THE CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHIU.
I GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
I IN THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I THE A THE BILL
PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR A OTHERS
TO ADD ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM [inaudible]
OF SENATOR DODD OF FOR SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR NECKS.
IT WAS WORTH MORE.
SOMEBODY'S COFFEE HERE
[inaudible]
REALLY.
CURRENTLY I KNOW HOW TO CLEAR
ROOM NO.
SENATOR DODD YEAH.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SB TWO THIRTY FIVE IS A
DISTRICT BUILD ALLOWED TO CITY
AND COUNTY.
OF NAPA TO EXPEDITE THE
PRODUCTION OF CRITICALLY NEEDED
HOUSING UNITS INCLUDING DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS FOR A VERY LOW
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
THE BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
CITY COUNTY TO REACH A MUTUALLY
ACCEPTABLE AGREEMENT TO ALLOW
ONE OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS. TO
REPORT ON ITS ANNUAL PRODUCTION
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THOSE ENTITLEMENTS
BUILDING PERMITS AND
CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY.
ISSUED BY THE OTHER JURISDICTION
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT HOUSING IF
CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THE NAPA BY PROJECT IS BEING
REALIZED AFTER TEN YEARS A
CONVERSATION AND COLLABORATIONS
WITH DEVELOPERS THE CITY IN THE
COUNTY DATING BACK TO WHEN.
I WAS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN NAPA COUNTY --
THEY ENTERED INTO NUMEROUS
AGREEMENTS OUTLINING FUTURE
ENTITLEMENTS ANNEXATIONS TAX
REVENUE SHARING IN THE PROVISION
OF MUNICIPAL SERVICES POTABLE
AND POTABLE WATER.
BY THE CITY OF NAPA IN LIEU LIEU
OF USING GROUND WATER.
ALL THIS WAS WORKED OUT THROUGH
A MULTI PHASE DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENT WHICH IS ALREADY UNDER
WAY.
HOWEVER AFTER EVALUATING CURRENT
MARKET CONDITIONS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE SCENARIOS A
DEVELOPER DETERMINED THAT THE
PROJECT CANNOT MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT MOVING SOME OF THE
HOUSING. TO THE FIRST PHASE OF
THE DEVELOPMENT ON LAND ALREADY
IN THAT AND NEXT TO THE CITY OF
NAPA.
WELL THIS CHANGE IT TO THE
AGREEMENT DELIVERS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MORE QUICKLY AFTER THIS
LEGISLATION THE COUNTY HAS NO
LEGAL MECHANISM TO ISSUE BOAT
BUILDING PERMITS OR OBTAIN
CREDITS TOWARDS THE CURRENT.
RINA DESPITE -- NAPA PIPE BEING
THE CENTERPIECE OF THE COUNTIES
CURRENT HOUSING ELEMENT SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE WILL ENSURE THAT
THIS HOUSING PROJECT IS ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT PENALIZING
COUNTY WORKING COLLABORATIVE THE
COLLABORATIVE WE ON THIS PROJECT.
I HAVE WITNESSES FROM BOTH THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY HERE TO
SHARE THEIR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR DODD --
FOR AUTHORING THE BILLING IN AND
HELPING US OUT WITH IT ON THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT GETTING A
PROJECT BUILT -- BUT WHEN SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE PASSES -- IT WILL
INITIATE UP UP UP UP PROCESS BY
WHICH THEY'LL START AND AND
BREAK GROUND NEXT SPRING.
SO THIS IS REALLY ABOUT GETTING
A PROJECT STARTED IT'S A NINE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE UNIT PROJECT
WHICH FOR NOW IS HUGE IT'S OUR
SINGLE BIGGEST.
SINGLE RESIDENTIAL PROJECT EVER
IN OUR HISTORY -- REALLY
IMPORTANT APP OF ITS ALSO
CELEBRATION OF A RELATIONSHIP
TWENTY CITY COUNTY.
MANY OF YOU KNOW ARE FAMILIAR
WITH NOW BUT IT'S LARGELY AN
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE SO WE RELY
ON A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CITY
TO GET HOUSING DONE IN OUR
COUNTY.
AND THIS IS A CELEBRATION TO OF
OF HOW WELL THE CITY AND COUNTY
WORK TOGETHER TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
TOGETHER. TO THAT'D LIKE LARK
FROM CITIES A FEW THINGS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SUPERVISOR GREGORY AND THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT THE CITY
OF NAPA IN OUR SUPPORT FOR SB TO
THIRTY FIVE AS MENTIONED THIS IS
A SPECIFIC BILL FOR THE NAPA
PIPE PROJECT.
AND WILL ALLOW US TO COLLABORATE
WITH THE COUNTY ON PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOUSING
IN OUR REGION -- WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTY ON OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PARTNER
WITH THEM REGULARLY -- IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN THE PRIMARY PROJECT
FOR THE COUNTY AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING FORWARD ON
THIS MUCH NEEDED HOUSING PROJECT
WITH THEM.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESS -- IN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BURIAL NJ CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCIES WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND WE SEE IT AT
THE FUTURE.
SB -- TO WHICH ENCOURAGES
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN CITIES
AND COUNTIES OF WILL BENEFIT
FROM THIS LAW.
TONY BREWING OVER THE CALIFORNIA
PURPOSE OCEAN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE ANY -- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON THE FLOOR OF THE CLERK OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CHIU.
DATE.
HI I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA AYE
KILEY.
KILEY IDLY MONS.
THE MAN I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA. FIVE THIRTY THE THE THE
BILL PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
THAT ON CENTER I APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT ALLOWING YOU TO CLOSE BUT IF
YOU GET A PERFECTLY THANK.
NEXUS OF FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SB THREE TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
HOLLY MITCHELL.
MA'AM YOU YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
IT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY
IMPRISONING SENATE BILL THREE
TWO NINE THIS BILL MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT LANDLORDS CANNOT
REJECTED TENET.
SOLELY BASED ON THEIR SOURCE OF
INCOME COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN
ANTI DISCRIMINATION MEASURE.
ACROSS OUR STATE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS RECEIVING HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ARE STRUGGLING TO USE
IT EFFECTIVELY DO THE BLANKET
POLICIES OF LANDLORDS WHO
REFUSED TO ACCEPT IT.
AT THE SAME TIME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE INCREASINGLY
TURNING TO HOUSING ASSISTANCE AS
A WAY OF SHIELDING TENANTS FROM
HOW HIGH HOUSING COSTS IN
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS -- IRONIC --
THE CENTER SKINNER BILL SB THREE
THIRTY AS WE TALKED ABOUT AND WE
HEARD MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE MORAL.
DILEMMA WE'RE ALL FACING WITH
THE HOMELESS CRISIS WE'RE ALL
FACING -- THIS IS A MEASURE TO
USE AN EXISTING FEDERAL HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO TRY TO
PREVENT THE INCREASING AND
GROWING NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
BECOMING HOMELESS BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE RENT.
EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY HAVE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND HOUSING
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE POSSESSION
OF A VOUCHER.
CITIES AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIAN OTHER STATES
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SOURCE OF INCOME
PROTECTIONS FOR ASSISTED
FAMILIES WITH GREAT SUCCESS.
BERKELEY SAN DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO
SANTA MONICA ALL HAVE SOURCE OF
INCOME PROTECTIONS AND I'M PROUD
TO SAY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
JUST PASSED AN ORDINANCE TO DO
THE SAME.
UNDER THIS BILL LANDLORDS WOULD
STILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO SCREEN
VOUCHER HOLDING THE APPLICANTS
USING THE SAME CRITERIA THEY USE
FOR ANY OTHER POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY BAR THEM
FROM REFUSING SOMEONE'S
APPLICATION JUST BECAUSE THEY
GET HELP TO PAY THE RENT.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT PUBLISHED A
REPORT THAT LOOKED AT THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF HOUSING FOR
FAMILIES WITH SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS.
THE STUDY FOUND THAT FOR EVERY
THIRTY NINE RENTAL
ADVERTISEMENTS FOR APARTMENTS
THAT A FAMILY WITH THE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE VOUCHER COULD AFFORD
THERE WAS ONLY ONE THAT DID NOT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT VOUCHER
HOLDERS FROM AT EVEN APPLYING.
YOU ALL HAVE SEEN THE I'D THE
ADS TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT ONE
BATH NO SECTION.
EIGHT WE'RE SOURCE OF INCOME
PROTECTIONS WERE NOT IN PLACE
DENIAL RATES FOR ASSISTED
FAMILIES WERE AS HIGH AS 75% OR
MORE.
IN JURISDICTIONS WITH SOURCE OF
INCOME PROTECTIONS THIS DENIAL
RATE WAS ALMOST CUT IN HALF.
THIS SITUATION FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS UNACCEPTABLE.
IF WE FOUND OURSELVES FACING
DATA THAT 75% OF GROCERY STORES
REFUSED TO ACCEPT CAL PRESS ALSO
KNOWN AS FOOD STAMPS AND PEOPLE
COULD USE IT TO BUY FOOD.
WE WOULD CRY FILE.
I'M CRYING FILED TODAY WITH
REGARD TO HOUSING DISCRIMINATION.
WE SHOULD NOT ACCEPT THE
SITUATION FOR THE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE WE GIVE OUR
STRUGGLING RESIDENCY THERE
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE'S A PROVEN
POLICY X. AVAILABLE TO CORRECT
IT.
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS HIT
HARDEST FOR LOW INCOME RENTERS
RISING RENTS LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND STAGNANT INCOMES
MAKE THIS POPULATION THE MOST
SUSCEPTIBLE TO BECOMING HOMELESS.
WE'VE HEARD NUMEROUS CONCERNS
FROM THE OPPOSITION -- I THINK
I'LL WAIT UNTIL THEY COME AND
BRING THEM FORWARD ON BEFORE I
BEGIN TO CHALLENGE THEM I WANT
TO MAKE SURE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO THEM.
THE WITH THAT -- I HAVE
WITNESSES HERE TODAY -- THAT
WILL SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL FIRST OF ALL SASHA HARDEN
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND STOCKPILE WHO
THAT AFFECTED RESIDENT AND WILL
WALK US THROUGH HER EXPERIENCE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
YES PLEASE YOU MAY BEGIN.
MY NAME IS TASHA POWELL I AM THE
LEADER OF FAIR RUNS FOR REDWOOD
CITY AND A RENTER STRUGGLING TO
USE MY HOUSING ASSISTANCE BEFORE
IT EXPIRES.
I AM HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE TWENTY NINE THE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES ACT.
WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT I HAVE
BEEN APPROVED FOR A HOUSING
VOUCHER AFTER BEING ON THE
WAITING LIST FOR YEARS I WAS
ELATED I ATTENDED THE
ORIENTATION OF THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY AND I COULDN'T BELIEVE
MY GOOD LUCK?
THE PROGRAM WOULD HELP SUBSIDIZE
MY RANT FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WELL I CONTINUE TO GET A SERIES
OF SURGERIES I'VE BEEN
UNDERGOING THAT HAVE ME OUT OF
WORK.
THE FACT THAT I WOULD NO LONGER
BE SPENDING 89% OF MY INCOME ON
RENT.
MEANT THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
PAY FOR ALTERNATIVE THERAPIES
AND PRESCRIPTIONS THAT I
DESPERATELY NEED AND I HAVE BEEN
HOLDING MY RECOVERY UP.
BECAUSE MY CURRENT LANDLORD
REFUSED TO TAKE MY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE I BEGAN TO SEARCH FOR
AN APARTMENT WHERE I COULD USE
MY SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER.
ALMOST 95% OF THE ADS AND
LISTINGS FOR AVAILABLE UNITS
CLEARLY STATE NO HOUSING
VOUCHERS WILL BE ACCEPTED.
BECAUSE OF THIS I COULDN'T EVEN
APPLY TO SHOW THEM THAT I HAVE
GOOD CREDIT.
EXCELLENT RENTAL HISTORY I'VE
BEEN AT MY CURRENT LOCATION FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS AND HAVE NEVER
MESSED AROUND PAYMENT -- PAID
LATE.
AND I'M FORTUNATE ENOUGH THAT MY
REFERENCES INCLUDE SEVERAL KEY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER.
THESE REDUCTIONS OF PILED UP AND
AT THIS POINT I HAVE TRIED TO
APPLY TO BETWEEN NINETY AND ONE
HUNDREDAPARTMENTS.
OUT OF THOSE ONLY ONE PLACES
ALLOWED ME TO FILL OUT AN
APPLICATION.
THE WEBSITES GIVEN TO ME BY THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY FOR APARTMENTS
THAT ACCEPT SECTION.
EIGHT HAVEN'T EVEN HAD ONE
OPENING IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS
SINCE I FIRST GOT MY VOUCHER.
I HAVE UNTIL SEPTEMBER FIRST TO
FIND SOMEONE TO TAKE MY VOUCHER
OR I WILL LOSE MY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE BEFORE I'VE EVER EVEN
GOTTEN A CHANCE TO USE IT.
LOSING THE ASSISTANCE WILL MEAN
THAT I WILL MOST LIKELY END UP
HOMELESS.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT IF I WAS
JUST GIVEN THE CHANCE TO APPLY
THAT MANAGEMENT COMPANIES AND
OWNERS WOULD SEE THAT I'M A
GREAT TENANT AND I WOULD FIND AN
OWNER WILLING TO TAKE MY VOUCHER.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT I CAN'T EVEN
GET THAT INFORMATION OUT THERE
SIMPLY BECAUSE I HAVE A HOUSING
VOUCHER.
THAT IS WHY SB THREE TWENTY NINE
IS SO IMPORTANT AFTER WAITING
YEARS FOR HOUSING ASSISTANCE I
WAITED FOUR POINT FIVE YEARS FOR
THIS VOUCHER.
STRUGGLING RENTERS SHOULDN'T BE
FORCED TO RETURN THAT ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST HOUSING VOUCHER
RECIPIENTS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS --
I'M SUCH A HARD TIME WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB
THREE TWENTY NINE WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO EFFORTS TO FIX OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE FACE OF
DOUBLE DIGIT INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS -- ACROSS OUR STATE.
THE BILL INSTITUTES A PROVEN
SOLUTION BY PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION AND BLANKET BANS
AGAINST APPLICANTS WITH HOUSING
ASSISTANCE THAT HELPS THEM MEET
THEIR RENT.
THE BILL APPLIES TO ALL HOUSING
ASSISTANCE DISCRIMINATION BUT
THE BIGGEST IMPACT IS FOR THE
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES
ON THE FEDERAL SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER PROGRAM.
THE BILL STILL ALLOWS LANDLORDS
TO SCREEN APPLICANTS FOR CREDIT
HISTORY RENTAL HISTORY AND THE
LIKE.
BUT SIMPLY REQUIRES THESE
CRITERIA TO BE PICKED A TO BE
APPLIED EVENLY TO ALL APPLICANTS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AFTER
WAITING YEARS IF WE JUST HEARD
TO RECEIVE IT FAMILIES ARE
INCREASINGLY FINDING THEMSELVES
UNABLE TO EVEN APPLY TO
APARTMENTS BASED ON THESE
BLANKET BANS.
AND ARE FORCED TO RETURN THEIR
ASSISTANCE ONIONS.
HOW MUCH SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
REPORTING THAT THIS IS
FRUSTRATING THEIR EFFORTS TO
SPEND RAPID RE HOUSING FUNDS AND
KEEP FAMILIES FROM FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS?
HOUSING ASSISTANCE GIVES OUR
LOWEST INCOME FAMILIES THE
CHANCE TAXES NEIGHBORHOODS OF
OPPORTUNITY BY SHOPPING FOR AN
APARTMENT ON THE PRIVATE MARKET
THE FAMILY PAYS 30% OF THEIR
INCOME.
AND THE HOUSING AUTHORITY PAYS
THE REST DIRECTLY TO THE
LANDLORD EACH MONTH.
MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON THE
INITIAL INSPECTION THAT MUST BE
PERFORMED WHEN A TENANT LEASES
UP WITH ABOUT HER -- AND THIS
PERSON THESE INSPECTIONS ARE
PERFORMED.
TO CHECK AND MAKE SURE THAT
UNITS ARE BATES MEETING BASIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS --
IT MAY CAUSE A SLIGHT DELAY WHEN
A TENANT FIRST APPLIES TO
HOUSING -- BUT THESE INSPECTIONS
ARE TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO BE
DONE WITHIN A REASONABLE TIME
FRAME TYPICALLY LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS.
AND MANY JURISDICTIONS HOUSING
AUTHORITIES ARE REPORTING MUCH
MUCH SHORTER TIME FRAMES -- FOR
EXAMPLE SANTA BARBARA HAS
REPORTED THEY PERFORM THESE
INSPECTIONS TYPICALLY THE DAY
THEY ARE REQUESTED.
SAN DIEGO HAS DEVELOPED A PRE
INSPECTION PROGRAM THAT CAN BE
DONE UP TO TWO MONTHS IN ADVANCE
OF ATTENDING EVEN APPLYING TO AN
APARTMENT.
AND THE CITY OF LA WHICH DID
PASS THIS THIS POLICY YESTERDAY --
IS WORKING TO REDUCE THEIR WAIT
TIMES DOWN FROM APPROXIMATELY
FOUR DAYS DOWN TO TWO DAYS -- SO
GIVEN THIS RELATIVELY MINIMAL
BURDEN ON LANDLORDS AND THE
ENORMOUS BENEFIT TO STRUGGLING
FAMILIES FACING THE RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OWN WITNESS TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF THE RESORT -- I MEAN
FOR THE FUTURE AND OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE ISLAND.
WE COULD GO TO THEM FIRST IF YOU
DON'T MIND SURE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MIKE
MCLAUGHLIN A VOLUNTEER WITH A A
RP.
HEY OUR P. SUPPORTS SB THREE
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
SHERMAN RECESS IDEAS ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA BOTH
IN SUPPORT.
MARILYN SHAKE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES PROUD CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
COMING WITH THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ALSO A CO SPONSOR.
LOUIS BRONTE WITH CALIFORNIA
GIVE ME REALLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL TODAY.
BRIAN -- CUSTOMER AFTER
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PLEASE A
CO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE.
SHERIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MOLLY BYNUM YOU W. ASKED ME
THREE NINE THIRTY IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
RAINY SIX CALIFORNIAS DISABILITY
RIGHTS AND CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
RETIRED AMERICANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
NOR COSTS ARE WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I AM ANDREA NO ONE MUTUAL
HOUSING AND RESIDENCE RUN
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK I'M IN
SOME PART OF THIS.
AND I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE PEOPLE WITH SECTION
EIGHT AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
VETERANS CANNOT AFFORD AND FIND
HOMES.
SO I AM IN SUPPORT.
ALEXANDRA RIDER WOULD NEED TO
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND THE
RESIDENTS AND NETWORK WITH ALL
THE TALK IN SUPPORT OF ALL THESE
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE FOUND THEMSELVES THAT A
HOME.
THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
TO CONTINUE THOSE EFFORTS.
THANK YOU HIS NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
HI EVAN MENTON WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS WERE ADDED MEMBERS WHO
ARE THE ONE PERSON ADVOCATING
FOR THE 99% MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE REAL ESTATE DEVELOPERS AND
LANDLORDS WHO.
ACTUALLY RENT A SECTION EIGHT
TENANTS AND THEY HAVE VERY
POSITIVE EXPERIENCES SO THAT
THEY VIEW THIS BILL IS A MORAL
ISSUE THANK YOU.
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE THE CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
pJOB I RING CALIFORNIA THAT
GRAYSON TO IN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SYLVIA SOLUTION ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND ON BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I CHELSEA BLOCK ONE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WAS
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION STRONG SUPPORT.
CHECK A FREIGHTER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I CHRISTIAN ALONE -- WITH PECO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- AT WITNESSES
ELECTED TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
HAVE YOU COME AROUND THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF QUEEN GREASY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
HERE TODAY IN STRONG ADAMANT
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWENTY
NINE UNDER CURRENT LAW
PARTICIPATION BY RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER IN SECTION EIGHT IS
VOLUNTARY.
UNDER SB THREE TWENTY NINE WHICH
REDEFINED SOURCE OF INCOME TO
INCLUDE SECTION EIGHT EVERY
RESIDENTIAL RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER WILL BE EFFECTIVELY FORCED
TO ENTER INTO A CONTRACT WITH
THE LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITY.
UPON RECEIVING AN APPLICATION
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL WITH A
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER.
BECAUSE HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN
MANY AREAS LACK THE RESOURCES TO
PROCESS APPLICATIONS AND INSPECT
PROPERTIES QUICKLY.
UNITS SIT UNOCCUPIED FOR MANY
WEEKS UNTIL ALL THE
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS ARE
MET A SUBSTANTIAL LOSS TO THE
PROPERTY OWNER.
I WOULD NOW LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CLAIMS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE REGARDING THIS BILLS IT IS
MOVED THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
CLAIM NUMBER ONE THIS BILL DOES
NOT MANDATE SECTION.
EIGHT THIS CLAIM IS FALSE
AMENDED THE DEFINITION OF SOURCE
OF INCOME TO INCLUDE SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHERS MEANS THE YOUR
EFFECTIVELY FORCING A LANDLORD
TO CONTRACT WITH LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITY WHEN THEY GET A
SECTION EIGHT APPLICANT.
WHAT IF LANDLORD DOESN'T LIKE
THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT WERE
AS GREAT DIFFICULTY FILLING THEM?
TOO BAD ACCORDING TO SB THREE
TWENTY NINE SB THREE TWENTY NINE
WOULD SEEMINGLY BE THE ONLY
INSTANCE IN STATE LAW WHERE
PRIVATE PROPERTY WE'RE A PRIVATE
PARTY EXCUSE ME IS EFFECTIVELY
FORCED ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
WITH THE GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE OUR
WORD FOR IT LESTER GOVERNOR
BROWN VETOED A BILL SIMILAR TO
SB THREE TWENTY NINE
SPECIFICALLY GOVERNOR BROWN.
VETOED SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
HAVE AMENDED SOURCE OF INCOME TO
INCLUDE SECTION EIGHT HUD VASH
VOUCHERS WELL SB THREE TWENTY
NINE IS FAR MORE EXPENSIVE.
IN THAT WILL AMEND SOURCE OF
INCOME TO INCLUDE ALL SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHERS.
IN HIS VETO MESSAGE REST BEFORE
TEAM TWENTY SEVEN GOVERNOR BROWN
DOESN'T USE THE WORD
DISCRIMINATION ONCE BUT HE DOES
USE THE WORD MANDATE.
THE GOVERNOR STATES AND I QUOTE
THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR
SPECIFICALLY IT FORCES LANDLORDS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS TO TAKE PART
IN ONE IS ALWAYS BEEN A
VOLUNTARY FEDERAL PROGRAM WOULD
NUMEROUS REQUIREMENTS.
THESE INCLUDE REGISTRATION WITH
THE LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITY
PARTICIPATION IN TRAINING
PROPERTY INSPECTIONS AND
MODIFICATION OF LEASES TO
CONFORM WITH FEDERAL STANDARDS I
DON'T BELIEVE A MANDATE I DON'T
BELIEVE A MANDATE TO COMPLY WITH
ALL THESE REQUIREMENTS IS
WARRANTED END QUOTE.
CLAIM NUMBER.
TWO IF YOU RECEIVE MULTIPLE
APPLICATIONS AT THE SAME TIME A
LANDLORD LED THE ABILITY TO
SELECT A NON SECTION EIGHT
APPLICANTS.
THIS CLAIM IS FALSE.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM A REALTOR
MEMBERS ON THIS ISSUE.
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT OUR
REALTOR MEMBERS ARE
PRACTITIONERS IN THE SPACE YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A REAL ESTATE
LICENSE TO PROVIDE PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT SERVICES SORE MEMBERS
DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES ON A
DAILY BASIS.
THEY HAVE TOLD US THAT IN THE
RENTAL HOUSING SPACE THERE'S NO
SUCH THING IS AT THE SAME TIME.
MEANING IF YOU GET MULTIPLE
APPLICATIONS YOU WILL HAVE TO
ACCEPT THE OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
SECTION EIGHT AFRICAN OR RISK
FACING LITIGATION.
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH THIS IS THE
FIRST RENTAL HOUSING BILL THAT
CA ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED IN THIS
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
SEE OUR SOUND COMMON GROUND AND
IS NOW NEUTRAL ON EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO THE RAN CAT
BILL.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE THE JUST
BECAUSE BILL.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE ASK
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS BILL AB
FIFTY THREE THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK BILL AB SEVEN
TWENTY FOR THE RENTAL REGISTRY
BUILT AND NUMEROUS OTHERS.
SEE ARE ALWAYS PURSUES COMMON
GROUND IF THERE IS ROOM TO REACH
CONSENSUS ON A BILL.
HOWEVER THIS BILL SIMPLY NOT
WORKABLE IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM AND WILL PROVIDE
INSTABILITY IN THE RENTAL
HOUSING MARKET IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OR NO VOTE
ON SB THREE TWO NINE THANK YOU.
THOUGHT MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RUN
KINGSTON REPRESENTING THREE
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS
THE APARTMENT SITUATION
CALIFORNIA'S SOUTHERN CITIES.
ALL SOUTHERN A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY EAST BAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION -- ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES AND THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY WE TO JOIN IN OPPOSITION.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON DIFFERENT
POINTS THAN THE PREVIOUS WITNESS.
NUMBER -- ONE THE FOCUS IN IS
BEEN NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS HAS BEEN THAT -- THERE
IS UNNECESSARY DELAY AND RENTING
THE RENTAL UNIT IF.
IF FOR THE SENATORS COMING UP TO
RANK TWO UNIT AND IS QUALIFIED
WANTS TO RENT THE UNIT THE
FOLLOWING DAY SHE MAY DO SO.
BUT IF IT'S A SECTION EIGHT
TENANT -- APPLICANT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE IT DOES TAKE THIRTY TO
FORTY FIVE DAYS WE'VE DOCUMENTED
MULTIPLE PLACES MORE ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IF IT WAS TRUE.
AS NOTED THAT IT ONLY TOOK ONE
DAY TO DO THE INSPECTION AND
EXECUTE THE CONTRACT THAT
QUICKLY WE WOULDN'T HAVE A
PROBLEM AND IN FACT.
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT SB FIVE
TWENTY ONE DOES BY ANTHONY
PORTANTINO HE PROVIDES A TAX
CREDIT. TO BACK FILL THE
FOREGOING REVENUE AS WE ARE
WAITING FOR AN APPLICATION WE
THEREFORE BELIEVE THAT THE
SECOND POINT -- THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE IF IT SAID THAT.
THE INSPECTION WAS DONE THE
FOLLOWING DAY THE CONTRACT WAS
ENTERED INTO.
THE TENET COULD IMMEDIATELY
AKHET TAKE OCCUPANCY THAT
WOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM THE SECOND
ISSUE IS IF WE CO JOINED OR AS
WE LIKE TO REFER TO IT IS DOUBLE
JOINING.
THE TWO MEASURES -- SO THERE'S
THE TAX CREDIT NOT FILLING --
THE FOR GONE RANKED.
WE WOULD HAVE SOMETHING TO TALK
ABOUT IN THE THIRD AND FINAL
POINT -- THAT WE SEE AND IN THE
PROVIDING THIS TO BE A PROBLEM
IS THAT NO ONE HAS SEEN WHAT THE
CONTRACT LOOKS LIKE THE CONTRACT
AND WE HAVE A COPY OF IT.
IT'S FOUR HUNDRED PAGES LONG
THAT THE LANDLORD HAS TO ENTRY
INTO -- TO BE ABLE TO QUALIFY
THERE IS SOMETHING.
THERE THAT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS WE DO
NOT WE ARE NOT ATTACKING THE
TENANT AT ALL THE APPLICANT IF
YOU WILL.
THIS IS.
THERE IS A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM THAT
IS -- VERY PRESIDENT THAT THE
PROGRAM IS BROCADE FIX THE
PROGRAM WERE HERE HAVING A TALK
WITH THE SENATOR AND PROPONENTS
IN AND ADDRESSING THIS
INAPPROPRIATE WAY. FOR THE TIME
BEING UNTIL THESE THINGS ARE
SOLVED WE TO JOIN THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THE ONLY BE WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
HERE AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AS WELL -- FOR FOR
OUR ASSOCIATION IT'S IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE PARTICIPANTS THAT ARE
ENGAGING THE PROGRAM IS ABOUT
THE PROGRAM ITSELF THE UNDER
FUNDING AND UNDER STAFFING -- OF
THE PROGRAM AND WE YOU KNOW A
LOT OF OUR OWNERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM WOULD
SAY THAT SECTION EIGHT
PARTICIPANTS ARE GREAT TENNIS OF
ALL THE RULES.
BUT WE GO BACK TO THE PROGRAM
BEING UNDERFUNDED -- MOST THE
TIME AND UNDERSTANDING AT THE
LOCAL HOUSING -- AGENCY. FOR FOR
US WE ACTUALLY WOULD.
ALONG WITH A LOT OF OUR
COALITION PARTNERS WILL BE ABLE
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION.
IF THERE WAS INTENT LANGUAGE
THAT WAS -- ACCEPTED THAT WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE BILL WAS NOT A
MANDATE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM -- FOR THOSE REASONS WE
FOR NOW WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
IF YOU COULD -- SAY YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND ASSUMING
YOU'RE A POLICY THAT THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE POSING.
AT WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE WANT TO LIVE WITH THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WE BELIEVE
WE CAN COME OFF OPPOSITION IF
INTENT LANGUAGE CLARIFIES THAT.
THE BILL IS MANDATING THE
ACCEPTANCE OF A SECTION EIGHT
APPLICANT BUT DOES NOT MANDATE
YOU TO ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
WITH THE HOUSING AUTHORITY TO
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE THE PROGRAM
BUT WE CAN WE COULD -- GO TO
NEUTRAL IF IT WAS -- ADDED THE
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT WE PROVIDED
THANK YOU.
KATE BELLAMY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION ALSO
POSE UNLESS AMENDED BECAUSE OF
THE MANDATE THANK YOU.
STEVE CARLSON FOR THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES FOR THE REASONS STATED
WE'RE MR CHEN MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OPPOSE FOR
SIMILAR REASONS THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION MISTER
KILEY.
I JUST SOME CLARIFICATION ON
THIS -- PROPOSAL TO ADD IN TEN
LANGUAGES WE HEARD FROM A FEW
FOLKS THAT SO.
HOW WOULD THAT WORK EXACTLY IF
THE BILL WERE TO SUGGEST YOU
HAVE TO TAKE SECTION EIGHT FOLKS
BUT NOT MANDATE PARTICIPATION IN
THE PROGRAM I THOUGHT THAT YOU
THOSE TWO ONE HAND IN HAND?
AND THAT THAT'S QUESTION IS
DIRECTED AT ANYONE WHO.
MADE THAT SUGGESTION SO ARE YOU
ASKING ABOUT THE NATURE OF THEIR
INTENT LANGUAGE YEAH I HEARD A
FEW OF THE FOLKS IN OPPOSITION
SAY THEY COME OFF IF THERE WERE
SOME INTENT LANGUAGE SAYING WE
DON'T WANT TO MAKE.
ME HOW ABOUT I SHARE THE INTO
LANGUAGE WITH YOU MAILED OUT
CLEAR FIVE EXCELLENT SO FIRST OF
ALL -- THE INTENT -- LANGUAGE
PROVIDED -- TO NOT TO ME
DIRECTLY BUT TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BY THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
A WE GOT HALFWAY THERE HALF OF
IT WAS ACCEPTED IT'S IT'S A
PARAGRAPH IN.
PERMISSION TO READ I'LL BE HAPPY
TO SHARE IT WITH YOU PLEASE.
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ENACTING THIS ACT
TO PROVIDE A PARTICIPANT IN A
HOUSING VOUCHER PROGRAM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE A
THOROUGH AND FAIR VETTING WHEN
THEY SEEK HOUSING.
THAT'S THE SINCE I ACCEPTED.
NOTHING IN THIS LEGISLATION IS
INTENDED TO COMPEL OR OTHERWISE
REQUIRE A LANDLORD OR PROPERTY
OWNER TO PROVIDE HOUSING TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL NOR REQUIRE PROPERTY
OWNER TO SIGN A CONTRACT
COMPELLING PARTICIPATION.
AND THE FEDERAL STATE OR LOCAL
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE IN FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL HOUSING.
SUBSIDIES PROGRAM.
ECCENTRIC CETERA THAT'S THE
LANGUAGE I'M NOT GONNA ACCEPT
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS TWO FOLD.
THE THE LANGUAGE THAT STATES.
DOES NOT REQUIRE IN ORDER TO
SIGN A CONTRACT COMPELLING
PARTICIPATION IS BASICALLY A
POISON PILL WHICH WOULD NEGATE
THE ENTIRE PREMISE OF THE BILL.
SECONDLY IT'S NOT NECESSARY ON
AND I APPRECIATE WE'VE GOT YOU
KNOW A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
BETWEEN ATTORNEYS WE SEE THAT ON
A REGULAR BASIS.
BUT THE SINCE SENATE JUDICIARY
ANALYSIS.
PAGE EIGHT ITEM FIVE CLARIFIES
THAT THIS BILL ARE ONLY
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION AND
THAT LANDLORDS RETAIN ALL OF THE
RIGHTS.
WOW THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
LANDLORDS FROM DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST THE TENETS ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR PARTICIPATION AND A
HOUSING VOUCHER PROGRAM
LANDLORDS REMAIN FREE TO REJECT
ANY TENDENCY APPLICANTS FROM
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
PROVIDED THEY DO SO ONE
OTHERWISE LAWFUL GROUNDS THAT
ARE NOT BASED ON A PARTICULAR
ANA PARTICIPANTS RECEIPT OF A
HOUSING SUBSIDY.
AND SO I BELIEVE IT IS VALIDATED
BY THE ATTORNEYS IN THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THAT NOW
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL PROHIBITS
A LANDLORD.
FROM NOT ACCEPTING.
A SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER IT
SIMPLY SAYS THAT YOU CAN'T.
ADVERTISE THAT YOU WON'T EVEN.
ACCEPT THE APPLICATION IT
DOESN'T SAY THAT YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO RENT TO THEM.
I I THINK I AGREE WITH THAT THE
THE SENATOR I IN AS MUCH AS THAT
IN TEN LANGUAGES TO REJECT WITH
ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATE ANY.
BY YOU KNOW EFFECTIVE THE BILL
IS IN MY DO YOU DISAGREE WITH
THAT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION THAT
THERE'D STILL BE THE BILL STILL
SERVE SOME PURPOSE OF THAT
INTENT LANGUAGE IS THERE.
BUT THE US BEING FOR FOR CA ARE
THE INTENT LANGUAGE -- WE AGREE
TO THE CENTER THE THE INTENT
LANGUAGE THAT'S BEING OFFERED IS
IS ANTITHETICAL TO THE TO THE
CODIFIED PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
SO IS SO IT WOULD IT WOULD IT
WOULD -- DO NOTHING IN OUR
ESTIMATION.
HEY YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE
A LOT OF WHERE -- THE OPPOSITION
COMES FROM THE WHAT I WOULD
OBJECT TO IS THE FORCED
PARTICIPATION IN A PROGRAM THAT
ADDS A WHOLE LOT OF NEW --
REQUIREMENTS SOME OF WHICH ARE
APPARENTLY QUITE INTERESTS
ACCORDING TO THE TESTIMONY I'D
IMAGINE THAT A LOT OF THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH AND A LOT OF HUMOR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I I ALREADY HAVE VERY HIGH
STANDARDS FOR THESE SORT OF
THINGS FOR INSPECTIONS AND SO
FORTH SO.
HI.
YOU KNOW ARE THE REQUIREMENTS OF
PARTICIPATION THE PROGRAM ARE
REDUNDANT OR IS THERE ANY
AVAILABILITY UNDER FEDERAL LAW --
TO WORK WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THEY ALREADY HAVE HIGH STANDARDS
TO ELIMINATE SOME OF THOSE
REDUNDANCIES.
SO THE THAT WITH RESPECT TO THE
INSPECTIONS THE INSPECTION IS
SOMETHING ADDITIONAL THAT'S
REQUIRED BUT THE STANDARDS THAT
ARE INSPECTED FOR ARE THE BASIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS THAT
ARE ALREADY REQUIRED OF
LANDLORDS. TO MAINTAIN THEIR
APARTMENTS WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ACCEPT HOUSING ASSISTANCE --
TENANTS AREEVEN ABLE TO MOVE IN
AND OUT WHILE LANDLORDS ARE
REMEDYING.
PROBLEMS THAT COME UP IN THE
INSPECTION SO LONG AS THEY'RE
NOT AND AN ABSOLUTE LIFE
THREATENING CONDITION -- AND
THEN LANDLORDS DO ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET SORT OF BACK PAY --
FOR THE TIME IN BETWEEN -- IN
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT THAT'S
BEEN TALKED A LOT ABOUT AND
THOSE OBLIGATIONS ESSENTIALLY
WHAT LANDLORDS AGREED TO WHEN
THEY SIGNED THAT CONTRACT IS.
TO RESPECT THE TENANTS RIGHTS
FOLLOW THE RULES OF THE PROGRAM --
MAINTAIN THEIR UNITS AT THEIR
THEIR BASIC OBLIGATIONS OF
LANDLORDS CURRENTLY -- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE FOUR HUNDRED PAGES
THAT'S REFERRED TO WAS ABOUT
THAT MAY BE THE LENGTH OF THE
CONTRACT IF YOU APPLY ALL THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT APPLY
TO THIS PROGRAM.
BUT IT'S A FAIRLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AGREEMENT SAYING
WE WILL TAKE YOUR PAYMENTS WE
WILL YOU KNOW COMMUNICATE WITH
THE HOUSING AUTHORITY WE AGREE
TO RESPECT TENANTS RIGHTS AND
MAINTAIN OUR UNITS.
HOW [inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF AND
AS A METAPHOR I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
THIS BILL AND I WOULD ASK MY
COLLEAGUES SUPPORT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
I WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER IF
YOU SAW CRAIGSLIST AD FOR
DEPARTMENT SAYING THAT NO PEOPLE
OF COLOR MAY APPLY.
THE NO VETERANS MAY APPLY.
THE POOR FOLKS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
APPLY WE WOULD NOT ALLOW THAT IN
THIS STATE AND YET IT IS REGULAR
THAT YOU SEE THIS NO SECTION
EIGHT MAY APPLY.
MONEY IS MONEY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE IT COMES
FROM AS LONG AS THEY PAY THEIR
BUT NO ONE IS BEING ASKED TO
TAKE A HAIR CUT NO ONE HAS ASKED
TO BE TAKING A FREE MONTHS RIGHT
THAT IS NOT WAS OCCURRING.
WHAT IS SIMPLY BEING ASKED THE
PEOPLE DO NOT DISCRIMINATE ON
THE BASIS OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
PARTICIPATION A PROGRAM THAT IS
MEANT TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
HOMELESSNESS -- THAT MAN I'M
JUST WRITING CATCHY NAME WHEN
YOU GET A TEST I MEAN FOR BUT I
DON'T IS A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD NOT MEANT
TO THIS YOUNG LADY -- SEVENTEEN
YEARS IN THE SAME APARTMENT.
AND YET YOU CAN YOUR CURRENT
WHAT PROPERTY OWNER WILL NOT
ACCEPT SECTION EIGHT AND YOU
HAVE YOUR I'D ALMOST AHUNDRED
PEOPLE YOU'VE ARE COMPLEX YOU
APPLY.
TO THIS ILLUSTRATES THE POINT OF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IF MS MET IN THE SENATOR WAS
ASKING YOU TO RENT TO SOMEONE
THAT WAS A DISASTER OF A TENANT --
THAT WOULD BE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT BUT THIS SIMPLY SAYS
THAT YOU CANNOT ADVERTISE TO SAY
THAT YOU CAN'T DO THAT BUT YOU
DON'T SPECIFICALLY DISCRIMINATE.
AND I DON'T KNOW ANOTHER
SITUATION WHERE THIS IS EVEN
CLOSE -- FOR US TO CONSIDER THAT
WOULD BE THE CASE CAN LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITIES DO BETTER NO
QUESTION I SERVED ON HOUSING
COMMISSION FOR MANY YEARS WE
WORK HARD TO TRY AND REDUCE THE
REGULATORY BARRIERS.
TO PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM
AND WE SHOULD ALL GO BACK TO OUR
OWN DISTRICTS AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY HOUSING AUTHORITY'S BEING
AS CONSUMER FRIENDLY -- AS SOME
OF THE BETTER ONES THAT WERE
MENTIONED -- IN TESTIMONY BUT
GUYS WE HAVE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL YOU WOULD NOT STAND FOR
SUPPORTING A LANDLORD WHO CAME
IN HERE AND SAID I WANT THE
RIGHT IN THE CABIN AND EXPRESSED
ABILITY IN THE STATE TO SAY I
WILL NOT RENT ABOUT PEOPLE.
NONE OF YOU WOULD VOTE FOR THAT
HOW ON EARTH COULD YOU EVER
SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT SUGGESTS
THAT YOU CANNOT YOU COULD PUT
OUT AN AD THAT SAYS I WILL NOT
BEEN TO POOR PEOPLE.
I MOVE THIS BILL AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THE SENATOR IS
RIGHT ON THIS LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
MR TIP.
IS YOUR IN A I I'M I'M REALLY
TROUBLED BY THIS BILL AND AND
AND HOW.
I WANTED TO LEAST RAZOR A COUPLE
ISSUES -- ONE YES MONEY MONEY IS
MONEY AND IF SECTION EIGHT IS
SUCH A CONVENIENT.
AND FAIR PROGRAM FOR PROPERTY
OWNER.
COURSE MOST PEOPLE WOULD TAKE IT.
SO SO WE HAVE ASK HERSELF WHY IS
IT THAT A LOT OF PROPERTY OWNER.
WOULD RATHER NOT TAKE SECTION
EIGHT HOUSING IS T BECAUSE OF
THE THE BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS
THAT.
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH -- TO TO
MAKE AN IBM MAY BE WORTHWHILE
AND AND ALSO.
THE OF THE THE IDEA THAT.
WILL HAVE TO BE COMPELLED.
INTO INTO DOING SOMETHING THAT
THEY DON'T WANT IS IS IS IS VERY
TROUBLING IT'S LIKE IT'S LIKE
GOING TO A A PHYSICIAN'S AND AND
SAY.
DO YOU HAVE TO TO TAKE -- MEDI
CAL PATIENTS EVEN IF WILL ONLY
PAY YOU.
A BUCK FOR TREATMENT. EIGHTY
MINUTE IT'S IT'S A MINUTE THAT
THAT THAT'S HOW I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL IS IS LIKE WE'RE
FORCING.
PEOPLE INTO DOING SOMETHING THAT
THEY'LL LIKE IN IT IN TERM OF OF
OF DISCRIMINATION NO I DON'T I I
DON'T.
THINK THAT.
WE HAVE A A PROBLEM OF OF
PROPERTY OWNER DISCRIMINATING ON
THE BASIS OF RACE OR OR GENDER
OR IN CLASS BUT NO.
WE DO HAVE SOME COMMUNITY THAT
DOES ADVERTISE SOMETHING TO THE
EFFECT OF THIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
ONLY ALLOWS.
SENIOR CITIZEN BILLS THAT.
OUR FIFTY FIVE A ORDER MAY APPLY
IF YOU'RE NOT WITHIN THE AGE
GROUP THAN THERE IS SOME SORT OF
SUCH PREFERENCES AS TO WHETHER.
YOU FIT INTO THE COMMUNITY.
SO IS SO IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF
ACTUALLY PEOPLE CREATING
PREFERENCES YES.
THERE ARE 	C THERE ARE
MOBILE HOME PARK AND IN MY A
DISTRICT THERE ARE APARTMENT
COMPLEXES IN MY DISTRICT THAT
DOES.
HAVE.
PREFERENCES ON THE TENANT ON THE
KIND OF TENNIS TODAY.
ONE OF BASED ON AGE BECAUSE THEY
WANT A COMMUNITY JUST BEFORE SHE
IS IT IS IT.
AND SO I I I I THINK THAT IF IF
THE A. V..
THE INTENTION OF THE AUTHOR IS
TO ME. TO MAKE SURE THAT A THIS
BILL DOES NOT MANDATE PEOPLE
FROM DOING DO WHAT THEY DON'T
WANT.
THEN SHE SHOULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER.
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS.
MISS QUIRK SILVA -- SENATOR.
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR UP FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD ALSO I TO
THOSE WHO SUPPORT AND ALSO
OPPOSE THAT SOUNDS KIND OF AN
INTERESTING BUT I THINK THAT --
THE MEMBER FROM -- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
GARDEN GROVE TALKED ABOUT
PREFERENCES AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE PREFERENCES
ABOUT.
WE WANT TO HAVE AS FRIENDS WHO
WE WANT TO HAVE HIS NEIGHBORS
WHO WE WANT TO OF YOU DON'T LIVE
NEXT.
TO AND I DO THINK THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION -- FOR OWNERS
TO THINK ABOUT SO EVEN THOUGH
THEY MAY NOT APPEAR TO HAVE
BIASES WHY IS IT.
SO RAMPANT THAT PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO TAKE SECTION.
EIGHT I HAVE MY OPINION ABOUT
THAT AND I DO KNOW IN THE PAST
OVER YEARS I'VE HEARD THINGS
ABOUT SECTION EIGHT THAT MAY BE
TRUE OR NOT LIKE -- THAT'S WHERE
ALL THE SECTION EIGHT PEOPLE
LIVE SO THERE PROBABLY IS SOME
TYPE OF APARTMENT OWNERS WHO ARE
WILLING TO TAKE IT AND THEN OF
COURSE YOU HAVE SECTION EIGHT
PEOPLE LIVING IN THERE.
BUT MANY TIMES WE DON'T KNOW
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL BUSINESS AND
WE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T -- AND WE
WOULDN'T KNOW IF THEY'RE SECTION
NADER NOT UNLESS SOMEBODY IS
EXPLICITLY TELLING PEOPLE THAT
THEY ARE.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER
IS THIS DISCLAIMER THAT SAYS NO
SECTION EIGHT I HAVE A SON WHO'S
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD AND I JUST
WENT OUT TO READ HIS VERY FIRST
APARTMENT WITH A ROOMMATE IN LOS
ANGELES.
AND HE LOOKED THROUGH MANY MANY
OF THOSE ADS AND I LOOKED ALONG
WITH HIM -- FIRST COST WAS A
HUGE -- BUT THEN SECOND HAVING
RENTAL HISTORY AS A TWENTY TWO
YEAR OLD WAS ANOTHER BARRIER.
AND RIGHT AWAY AS WE WERE
LOOKING THROUGH THESE ADS I WAS
SURPRISED TO SEE HOW MANY
SECTION.
EIGHT DISCLAIMERS WERE ON THERE
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID I AM
STILL -- CONCERNED ABOUT THE
MANDATE IN THE INTAKE BUT ON THE
PART WHERE YOU SAID THE SENATE
JUDICIARY [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MENTIONS.
THE CONTRACT.
RIGHTS ON ITEM.
FIVE YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE
WANT SPECIFIC LANGUAGE I KNOW
YOU WANT THE INTAKE LANGUAGE THE
SECOND PART OF IT -- THE SENATOR
IS TAKEN THE FIRST PART AND ON
IT'S BEEN SAID THAT IF YOU AT
THE SECOND YOU WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION.
BUT I THINK RIGHT TO THIS SAYING
THAT.
IN ESSENCE YOU'RE OPENING UP THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND THEY
STILL HAVE THE CHOICE TO CHOOSE
THE SECTION EIGHT PERSON.
OR NOT -- SO I THINK THAT THAT
THEY ARE NOT SAYING IF THERE'S
THREE APPLICANTS YOU HAVE TO
CHOOSE A SECTION EIGHT IS THAT
CORRECT.
JUST AS CORRECT THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE TO CHOOSE THE SECTION EIGHT
THERE I RECENTLY SEEN BY
REMOVING THE SECTION EIGHT YES
THERE WE MORE APPLICATIONS TO GO
THROUGH.
AND SOMEBODY MAY FIND SOMEBODY
THAT'S A A BEFORE -- BUT IT
DOESN'T SAY YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THEM SO DOES NOT TRUE THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY BUT IF THEY DO
CHOOSE TO TAKE THEM.
THEN THEY WOULD HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH GOING THROUGH THE
ORIENTATION AND GOING THROUGH
[inaudible]
THE INSPECTION.
SACRAMENTO THAT IS CORRECT BUT
ALSO WHEN ANYBODY IS RENTING A
NEW APARTMENT UNLESS I'M
COMPLETELY WRONG -- MARKET RATE
ANY TYPE OF APARTMENT THERE ARE
CERTAIN OF KIND OF SCENARIOS
THEY HAVE TO COMPLY WITH WHETHER
IT BE PAINTING CARPET ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT YOU WOULD DO
TO PREPARE FOR A NEW PARK
APARTMENT IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT THAT'S CORRECT IT IN
ADDITION TO AN ANNUAL INSPECTION
REQUIRED -- OF ALL RENTAL UNITS --
BY YOUR LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITY
YOU KNOW WHETHER I HAVE A IT AS
A NEW TO THIS COMING IN OR NOT
I'M REQUIRED TO HAVE AN ANNUAL
INSPECTION -- BITE MY LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITIES SO THAT TOO
IS CORRECT.
MATT AGAIN IN SOME WAYS IF YOU
TURN THE OF THE SCENARIO AROUND.
I DON'T THINK AN ANNUAL
INSPECTION IS REQUIRED OF JUST A
REGULAR.
IS THAT NO IT IS.
IN IN SOME JURISDICTIONS IT IS
IT DEPENDS ON LOCAL REGULATIONS
ARE FOR EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES.
THE CITY REGULARLY INSPECTS ALL
RENTAL UNITS TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE THEM MAINTAINED AND OUR
MEETING BASIC.
HEALTH AND SAFETY SO WHETHER YOU
YOU.
PREFERRED EXPECT A INSPECTION OR
NOT I DO THINK THERE IS SOME
GOOD NEWS TO THAT IN THE GOOD
NEWS WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOUR PROS
AND CONS IS YOU DO WANT TO GET
INTO THE APARTMENTS THAT YOU
WILL SEE THAT YOU ARE.
RENT TEEN AND MAKE SURE THAT IN
FACT THEY'RE NOT ONLY SAFE BUT
THERE'S ISSUES IF THEY NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED THAT MAYBE A RENTER
HASN'T EVEN BROUGHT UP TO YOU --
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS THAT YOU CAN
CORRECT BEFORE IT BECOMES A HUGE
LITIGATION ISSUE SO THAT A LONG
WINDED WAY I DO SUPPORT THIS I
WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR -- I KNOW
THAT SHE IS TAKEN SERIOUSLY THE
INTAKE -- AND HAS CHOSEN PART OF
IT -- YOU HAVE GIVEN.
FROM THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE --
COMMITTEE THE ITEM THAT YOU
BELIEVE.
VERIFIES THAT THIS IS NOT A
MANDATE -- THAT AGAIN AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT THE
NARRATIVE AND IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE BELIEVE SO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT BY AND LARGE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EVERYBODY
RUNNING TO THE SENATE.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND LOOKING
FOR THAT ITEM TO PROVE IT.
WELL IT'S DOUBLE REFERRED SO
THEY CAN RUN TO THE SIMILAR TO
WHAT I CAN SAY IS FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE OPPOSE IT REALLY IS UP
TO YOU TO LOOK AT THAT.
ITEM AND MAKE SURE THAT -- YOU
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE USING THAT
LANGUAGE TO TO YOUR MEMBERSHIP
BECAUSE THIS IS BEING EXPLAINED
IN TWO VERY VERY DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND SO WHERE IS THE TRUTH AND I
THINK THAT IT IS UP TO YOU TO
SAY WE ARE PART OF AN
ORGANIZATION AND A MEMBERSHIP.
THAT SAYS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WE WANT TO
HOUSE PEOPLE THESE VOUCHERS --
CAN BE A TOOL TO GET PEOPLE ON
HOUSING AND THIS BILL.
IS NOT PERFECT BY ANY MEANS BUT
IT WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO USE
THESE AND IF WE TAKE OFF THE
DISCLAIMER YES YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE APPLICATIONS BUT THEY
ALREADY DO NOW SO IT'S STILL UP
TO YOU TO CHOOSE THE BEST
APPLICANT THAT YOU FIT.
FEEL FILL OF FITS INTO YOUR
HOUSING.
OR RENTAL SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MR DEBORAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- SO I
DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS WHAT I
DID JUST ONE RESPOND -- TO SOME
COMMENTS FROM THE VICE CHAIR --
I I THINK I APPRECIATE SOME OF
THE POINTS YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE
BUT WOULD JUST SUGGEST YOU YOU
KNOW WE HAVE -- LAWS AND AND
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS IN
THE STATE THAT PROHIBIT PEOPLE
FROM DISCRIMINATING ON THE BASIS
OF RACE AND OTHER
CHARACTERISTICS IN.
ASIAN OF RENTAL HOUSING ANOTHER
THANKS RIGHT AND SO WE'RE NOT
SAYING TO IN THE STATE THAT YOU
HAVE TO RENT TO BUY PEOPLE OR
YOU HAVE TO RENT TO JEWS ARE YOU
HAVE TO RENT.
TO OTHER FOLKS BUT WE'RE SAYING
IF YOU CHOOSE TO PUT YOUR
PROPERTY ON THE MARKET IN AND
TURNED TO THE RENTAL MARKET THEN
YOU CAN'T DISCRIMINATE BASED ON
THOSE CHARACTERISTICS AND SO. TO
ME THIS IS FALSE VERY MUCH IN
LINE WITH -- WITH A
STRAIGHTFORWARD ANTI
DISCRIMINATION MEASURE IT SAYS
THAT IF YOU WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE RIGHT TO RENT
IN THE STATE AND ENTER INTO
BUSINESS THEN YOU NEED TO DO SO
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST A CERTAIN
CLASS OF FOLKS -- AND AND I WILL
SAY I AM SENSITIVE -- TO TO TO
THE OPPOSITION IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT MAYBE THERE'S SOME
DIFFERENT CONCERNS -- I AM
SENSITIVE TO OF BURDENSOME
GOVERNMENT MANDATES ON THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND THINGS THAT
ARE GOING -- TO YOU KNOW BE
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR FOLKS TO
COMPLY WITH BUT I AM I AM
PERSONALLY -- STRUGGLING TO SEE
THAT HERE IT DOESN'T SEEM TO ME
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
OVERLY BURDENSOME IT JUST SEEMS
TO ME THAT -- RATHER THAN AN
OUTRIGHT REJECTION UP FRONT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE A A FAIR LOOK AT
THAT PERSON CONSIDER THEM ND
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE AND
I I AGREE WITH AS AN ATTORNEY
GREAT THE ANALYSIS THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE YOU TO RENT TO THAT
PERSON OR OR OR OR LEAST.
ABOUT PERSONAGES SAYS YOU CAN'T
CATEGORICALLY DENY THAT CLASS OF
FOLKS THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN
APPLY SO -- I'M HAPPY TO TO TO
CONSIDER THAT MORNING OR IF
TERE ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
TO RELIEVE SOME OF THOSE BURDENS
AND OTHER WAYS I'D BE VERY
INTERESTED TO KNOW THAT BECAUSE
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT -- TO
YOU KNOW NOT UNNECESSARILY
BURDEN FOLKS BUT I WOULD JUST
TELL YOU AS I SAT HERE AND TRY
TO LISTEN TO THIS TESTIMONY VERY
CAREFULLY.
I'M STRUGGLING TO SEE SOMETHING
THAT SEEMS LIKE AN UNFAIR BURDEN
ON ON THE PRIVATE SECTOR -- AND
AND VERY OPEN IF YOU HAVE
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT THINGS THAT WE
COULD DO -- TED TAX WOULD LIKE
THAT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW I
WILL TAKE YOUR WORD THAT THERE
IS AN OBJECTION TO THIS CLASS OF
TENANTS.
ON THAT IT'S JUST THE THE
PROGRAM ITSELF AND AND THE PROMS
ASSOCIATE WITH IT SO MAYBE
THERE'S SOMETHING WE CAN DO.
TO AS A AS A LEGISLATURE'S A
STATE TO TO MAKE IT SO THAT MORE
FOLKS ON SECTION EIGHT CAN CAN
GET INTERPRETER RENTAL HOUSING --
AND FIVE DISAGREE A LOT WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DIEGO AGAIN.
YOU KNOW AT THIS TIME WHEN WE'RE
FACING -- THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING IN THE
STATE TO TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
PH<c.cyan>. TO GET A TO HOUSING</c>
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA COME IN A
CHIP IN THE MONEY I MEAN THAT
JUST SEEMS TO TURN AWAY FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO HELP BRING FOLKS OFF
THE STREET.
THAT JUST SEEMS -- TREMENDOUSLY
SHORT SIGHTED TO ME SO WANTED TO
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO THAT -- IF THERE'S
SOMETHING I'VE MISSED PLEASE LET
ME KNOW BUT AS I SAID I MEAN I
JUST.
IT DOESN'T SEEM UNDULY
BURDENSOME TO ME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MIGHT.
HELP -- YES NO TO AND THING
THINK SO MUCH FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND AND
FOR US IN MEMORY QUIRK SILVA AS
WELL -- AND FOR ALL THE OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS -- I
THINK WE WOULD -- AT THIS
JUNCTURE JUST IT JUST AGREE TO
DISAGREE I MEAN I THINK -- YOU
KNOW WITH RESPECT TO THE I I
THINK THE MAIN CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE IS THAT.
THIS BILL DOES EFFECTIVELY
MANDATE EVERY RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY OWNERS DISPENSATION
EIGHT IF THEY GET AN OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE SECTION EIGHT APPLICANT
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THAT APPLICANT
AND THEREFORE THEREFORE
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAMS AND
THAT TO SIGN A CONTRACT.
WHICH KNOWN AS A HAPPY CONTRACT
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS
CONTRACT.
AND CONTRACT WITH THE LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITY -- AND THAT
COMES ALL SORTS OF INSPECTIONS
AND OTHER REQUIREMENTS -- SO
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE -- WITH
RESPECT -- TO OWNERS
REQUIREMENTS -- SO GIVE YOU TWO
EXAMPLES I TRY TO BE BRIEF -- SO
FOR INSTANCE THIS MORNING WE
JUST HEARD FROM THE MEMBER IN IN
LOS ANGELES -- VOLUNTARILY
PARTICIPATES IN SECTION A
PROGRAM -- AND HE WAS TOLD ME AS
A MULTI FAMILY BUILDING -- AND
HE WAS TOLD BY A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE HOUSING AUTHORITY WHO'S
MAKING AN INSPECTION.
THAT -- AN OUTSIDE WALL SO IT'S
A MULTI FAMILY BUILDING ON THE
OUTSIDE OF THE WALL SO THERE'S A
THERE'S A WALL THAT ON ONE SIDE
IT'S INSIDE THE SAID THE SECTION
EIGHT UNIT.
BUT ON THE OUTSIDE IS THE
EXTERIOR ON THE OUTSIDE OF THE
WALL THERE WAS SOME GRAFFITI AND
HE WAS INFORMED BY THE LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITY REPRESENTATIVE.
THAT THE LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITY
WOULD BE SUSPENDING RENTAL
PAYMENTS TO THE LANDLORD ON ALL
THE SECTION EIGHT UNITS NOT JUST
THAT PARTICULAR UNIT.
AND SO THAT WE SEE IS INCREDIBLY
ONEROUS NOW OF COURSE THAT
BERRIES FROM LOCALITY TO
LOCALITY SAYS JUST ONE LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITY -- AND SO WE
SEE THAT IS VERY ONEROUS ANOTHER
THING THAT'S NOT BEING MENTIONED
IS THAT ALL RENTAL INCREASES
HAVE TO PASS THROUGH THE LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITY -- WE
OBVIOUSLY HERE AT C. A. R. R.
NEUTRON A. B. -- FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WHICH IS ESTABLISHING A RANK
CAP UP AND MAKES TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR WERE NEUTRAL ON THAT
MEASURE AND WE'RE NEUTRAL ON IT
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT IT OFFERS A
BALANCED APPROACH BETWEEN TEN A
PROTECTIONS.
AS WELL AS OFFERING A LANDLORD A
FAIR RATE OF RETURN UNDER THIS
BILL WE FEEL AS THOUGH IT
CREATED DOUBLE STANDARD WE ARE.
A MAIL RECEIVED AN OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE SECTION EIGHT APPLICANT
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THAT APPLICANT
THEY HAVE TO SIGN TO HAVE
CONTRACTED LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITY AND COMPLY WITH ALL
THOSE PROVISIONS.
INCLUDING PASSING RENT INCREASES
IN AND HAVING THE RENT
ESTABLISHED BY THE LOCAL AS A
FORTY ITSELF LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITY GETS ESTABLISHED THE
RENT.
SO.
IN THIS AREA WHERE YOU HAD A BE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO IN EFFECT
NEXT YEAR AND YOU ALSO AT THIS
BILL IN EFFECT YOU COULD HAVE AN
INSTANCE WHERE LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITY SAYS.
HEY WE'RE ONLY GONNA GET LET YOU
HAVE THE RENT CPI PLUS 1% WERE
JUST CPI FOR CPI PLUS 2% WHICH
RUN CUT RENT WHICH WOULD RUN
CONTRARY TO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WHICH IS CURRENTLY AT 7%
PLUS REGIONAL CPI.
AND SO THAT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
BURDENSOME BECAUSE AGAIN.
ANY RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER SO IF
YOU HAVE AN ELDERLY COUPLE THEY
OWN ONE SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCE.
AND THEY GET IN OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE SUCH NEED APPLICANT
BASS TAKE THAT APPLICANTS WITH
HOUSING AUTHORITY SAYS YOU HAVE
TO SET THE RENTED CPI THEY HAVE
TO DO THAT.
AND THAT COULD BE X. REALLY
BURDENSOME FOR THEM AND SO
THAT'S WHY THIS IS VERY MUCH A A
LOCAL ISSUE AND AND AGAIN THIS
THIS IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
SECTION EIGHT BECAUSE WE DO SEE
THE PROGRAM IS.
AS HAVING POTENTIAL BUT AGAIN
IT'S A FLOOD FEDERAL PROGRAMS
IT'S IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THE STATE LEGISLATURES
CURRENTLY TRYING TO INTERJECT
ITSELF INTO THAT AND MANDATE A
FLOOD FEDERAL PROGRAM -- WE
ACTUALLY SEE IS MORE SOUND
ALTERNATIVE -- SB FIVE TWENTY
ONE WHICH AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED -- BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
A TAX CREDIT TO INCENTIVIZE MORE
LANDLORDS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM.
AND SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE OUR ANY
OUR NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
REALTORS IS CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH CONGRESSIONAL BILL TO GET
DELEGATION CURLY WORKING WITH
CONGRESS AND WITH HUD TO TRY TO
IMPROVE.
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL -- AND SO WE WE
VERY MUCH ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THOSE EFFORTS BUT FEEL THIS BILL
IS SIMPLY NOT WORKABLE -- AND WE
DO FEEL THAT A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED WITH
RESPECT TO OUTRAGEOUS RENTAL --
PRICES -- AND HOMELESSNESS AND
THINGS OF THAT SORT WE FEEL AS
THOUGH WE ARE BEING CONSTRUCTED
PARTICIPATED IN -- YOU KNOW
WORKING WITH.
YOURSELF ON AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WORKING WITH -- THE CHAIR
ON A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WHEN WORKING ON OTHER MEASURES
THE JUST CAUSE BILLY BE --
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE WORKING ON
NUMEROUS MEASURES BUT WE FEEL
THAT THIS BILL IS SIMPLY NOT
WORKABLE AND IT IS GOING TO
CREATE.
A MANDATE FOR A BIT FOR A A
PROGRAM THAT WAS DESIGNED TO BE
VOLUNTARY WHICH IS WHITE HAS
THAT CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION
OTHER ONEROUS REQUIREMENTS.
AND WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE.
BY FOUR TERM GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN WHEN HE SAID THAT THIS
BILL DOES CREATE A MANDATE -- TO
THE CHAIR OF A MAN.
DISAPPEAR AS YOUR QUESTION
ANSWERED OR YOU.
OKAY MANAGEMENT KEEP IT BRIEF
THE ONLY THING -- AT IS --
PARMER CONCERN TERMS THE MANDATE
IS TO CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
THE PERSPECTIVE APPLICANT
BECAUSE THE PROCESS PAYS ALL THE
SOCIAL TO FEES.
AND THEN THE OWNER IF THEY DO
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE SECTION
PROGRAM IS LEFT. TO LET THE
APPLICANT KNOW THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THE LOCAL
HOUSING AUTHORITY.
WERE CONCERNED THAT THAT ALSO
OPENS UP LITIGATION EXPOSURE FOR
US -- SO THAT'S WHY WOULD WE
WANT THAT CLARIFICATION WITHIN
TELLING WHICH BUT ALSO THE AT
YEAH I JUST IT'S THANK THANK YOU
FOR THAT I APPRECIATE I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION ON
SOME OF THE OTHER HOUSING
MEASURES THAT WE'VE HAD -- MOVE
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE IN
THROUGH THE EIGHT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE -- AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE TO ME THAT THE REAL -- AREA
OF EMPHASIS NEEDS TO BE ON
FIXING THE PROBLEM AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND SO -- YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO ME SEEMS
REASONABLE TEAMS APPROPRIATE IT
SEEMS FAIRLY MODEST.
AND YOU KNOW WITH THERE'S
ANYTHING WE CAN DO I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO TO HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT I THINK OTHERS WOULD
BE IF THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO.
TO TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM WORK
BETTER FOR MORE FOLKS SO THAT
MORE FOLKS WAS SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS CAN GET INTO HOUSING IN
A WAY THAT WORKS. FOR FOR THE
OWNERS OF THE HOUSING I THINK
THAT'S GREAT BY -- YOU KNOW
SEEING SEEING AND LISTENING TO
THE TESTIMONY TODAY I THINK WHEN
A SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NUMBER SCORE SO HAS ONE MORE
QUESTION.
YEAH JUST ON THE POINT THAT WAS
JUST BROUGHT UP RELATED -- TO
THE RENT INCREASES.
CONTROL HE WANTS IT THAT WAY --
RELATED TO OUR YOUR BILL THIS.
GENTLEMAN JUST SAID.
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
VOUCHER SAYS ONE THING BUT RIGHT
SO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE --
WITH REGARD TO THE PAYMENT
STANDARDS ON SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS THERE'S AN IMPORTANT
REASON THAT THOSE ARE IN PLACE
WHICH IS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
GOVERNMENT FUNDS ARE NOT BEING
USED TO ESSENTIALLY OVER PAY.
FOR PRIVATE APARTMENTS THAT'S
VERY DIFFERENT THAN SAYING THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY MANDATES WHAT
A LANDMARK IN CHARGE SO ABOUT
HER COMES WITH A PAYMENT
STANDARD MEANING THAT'S THE
MAXIMUM RENT THAT -- THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY IS GOING TO PAY FOR A
GIVEN APARTMENT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT'S
THE MAXIMUM RENT THAT A LANDMARK
IN CHARGE THAT MEANS THAT WHEN
THE VOUCHER HOLDER THEMSELF IS
SHOPPING FOR APARTMENTS.
JUST LIKE WHEN I'M SHOPPING FOR
AN APARTMENT THEY HAVE TO FIND A
PLACE THAT THEY CAN AFFORD
WITHOUT VOUCHER -- SO IF THERE
IS RENT BEING CHARGED OVER AND
ABOVE THAT PAYMENT STANDARD THAT
JUST MEANS THAT THAT WILL NOT BE
A UNIT THAT THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY CAN PAY FOR UNDER THAT
PROGRAM.
SO IT'S A IT'S A IT'S AN ISSUE
FOR THE TENANT NOT NECESSARILY
FOR THE LANDMARK.
ALL RIGHT AND JUST WHAT JUST ONE
MORE -- NOT QUESTION BUT ON THIS
BILL WOULD TAKE OFF THE
DISCLAIMER OR THE LANGUAGE.
ON WHEN SOMEBODY'S LOOKING FOR
AN APARTMENT SAYING THAT YOU
CANNOT -- THAT THEY DON'T ACCEPT --
SECTION DATE BUT IS THERE A
POSSIBILITY. TWO I DON'T KNOW IF
IT WOULD BE IN THE APPLICATION
OR SOMEWHERE ELSE I'M NOT TRYING
TO MEND IT WELL WE'RE HERE BUT
JUST AS AN OPTION IS. TO LET THE
LANDLORDS KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
FORCED TO TAKE IT.
SECTION.
EIGHT HE SAID I'M SAYING THE ONE
PART IS JUST SAY THEY'RE NOT
DISCRIMINATING.
THAT OFF THAT OUT I THINK IT
GOES BACK TO THE TO THE TO THE
AS THE REPRESENTED FROM KERR
SAID WE HAVE TO AGREE TO
DISAGREE WITH INTERPRETATION OF
THE LAW.
AND IT'S OUR ARGUMENT THAT IT IT
IS NOT A MANDATE [inaudible]
ANA.
AND I KNOW THE CAR IN THE
APARTMENT SO SEE ATION IT'S BEEN
A GREAT DEAL OF TIME -- DOING
WORKSHOPS EDUCATING -- APARTMENT
OWNERS AND LANDLORDS ABOUT
CURRENT LAW.
I WOULD HOPE THAT IF THIS WERE
TO BECOME LAW THAT THEY WOULD DO
THEIR DUE DILIGENCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT LANDLORDS ACROSS THE STATE
WHO WHO PAY FEES AND LOOK TO
THEM -- TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON
HOW CURRENT IN NEW LOS IMPACT ON
THEIR ABILITY TO DO BUSINESS
WOULD INFORM THEM OF THAT BUT
AGAIN I THINK IT GETS BACK TO
THIS CORE ISSUE.
IT IS NOT A MANDATE AND WE'RE
CLEAR THAT THE LANGUAGE SUPPORTS
THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION I KNOW MANY OF YOU
HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THIS
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS AND
AND LET ME SAYAT THE OUTSET.
I'VE BEEN A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL SINCE THE BEGINNING I VERY
RARELY CO AUTHOR BILLS THAT COME
THROUGH THIS HOUSING COMMITTEE
BUT THIS IS ONE THAT I DO THINK --
AND AGREE WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO IS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND LET ME JUST FIRST
ADDRESS I THINK A FEW
MISCONCEPTIONS I LET ME JUST
READ FROM THE ANALYSIS.
THE AUTHOR THIS BILL HAS STATED
IN HER HER OWN ANALYSIS OR HER --
FACT SHEET THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE LANDLORDS TO ACCEPT ANY
TENANTS WITH HOUSING ASSISTANCE
DOES NOT PROHIBIT LANDLORDS FROM
SCREENING FOR SUITABILITY DOES
NOTHING TO PREVENT LANDLORDS
FROM SETTING THEIR RENTS.
A DESIRE LEVELS THERE WAS AN
EXAMPLE I THINK OUR VICE CHAIR
IT'S SUGGESTED THAT SOMEHOW THIS
BILL WAS A CAN TO FORCING --
SOMEONE PROVIDE HEALTH CARE AT A
DOLLAR THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT THIS BILL SAYS.
THAT YOU SHOULDN'T DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST SOMEONE IF YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO A YOU HAVE -- THE
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE YOU SHOULD
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST SOME AND
MISS QUIRK SILVA I DO THINK HAD
RAISED.
THE CHALLENGE AROUND THE
NARRATIVE AND AND LET ME SUGGEST
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO
THINK ABOUT THE NARRATIVE.
CURRENT LAW SAYS YOU CAN'T
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST SOMEONE
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE OR THEIR
GENDER OR THEIR NATIONALITY BUT
YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED. TO RENT TO
SOMEONE BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE
THEIR GENDER OR NATIONALITY IT
SIMPLY SAYS GIVE THEM A FAIR
SHOT.
DON'T HAVE A SIGN ON THE DOOR
THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T EVEN SUBMIT
YOUR APPLICATION.
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOLKS TO SAY
PUT ASIDE WHATEVER.
STEREOTYPES YOU MAY HAVE AROUND
SECTION EIGHT HOUSING APPLICANTS.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY THAT PORTION WITH
THE FEDERAL ASSISTANCE AND THEY
HAVE.
OTHER ABILITIES POTENTIALLY TO
PAY FOR THE BALANCE BUT GIVE
THEM A FAIR SHOT -- AND IN MY
MIND THAT'S ALL THIS DOES I HAVE
FULL FAITH IN THE RENTAL HOUSING
INDUSTRY THAT IF THIS WERE TO GO
INTO EFFECT.
THE MEMBERS OF THE ROW HOUSING
INDUSTRY WOULD BE EDUCATED ON
ALL OF THESE NUANCES OF THE LAW
AND THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND.
THAT THEY CAN'T PUT A SIGN UP
THAT SAYS THOU SHALL NOT APPLY.
THEY NEED TO GIVE PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY.
BUT THEY CAN MAKE A DECISION AS
THEY WOULD IN ANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCE.
REGARDLESS OF SOMEONE'S RACE OR
RELIGION OR NATIONALITY OR ANY
OF THE OTHER ENUMERATED
CATEGORIES THAT ARE PROTECTED
UNDER CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS AND SO I
KNOW THAT'S A CONCEPT THAT'S
BEEN A BIT DIFFICULT.
FOR I THINK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO GRAPPLE WITH BUT
THAT'S WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE --
AND WITH THAT I AM.
HOPING THAT THIS COMMITTEE DOES
MOVE THIS FORWARD WITHOUT
FURTHER DISCUSSION.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE AUTHOR OF
ANY FINAL COMMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IF I MAY ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES RAISED IN A VERY
BRIEF CLOSE MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU IT IS BEEN A RICH
DEBATE -- BOTH IN THE HOUSE OF
ORIGIN ON THE SENATE FLOOR --
SENATOR HERTZBERG HELD UP THE
FOUR HUNDRED PAGE DOCUMENT ALL
CONTRACT AND IT NOW IS THE FACT
THAT PARTICULARLY WITH SOME.
NEW CHANGES BEING PUT FORWARD BY
OUR CURRENT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THERE'S REALLY
SOME CAUSE FOR CONCERN I'M FOR
ALL OF US WHO ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM ABOUT
SOME ELEMENTS THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD BE ADDED IN THERE BY OUR
NEW FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION SO I
THINK WE DO HAVE WORK. TO DO AND
I CONGRATULATE THE NATIONAL
REALTORS ASSOCIATION HOPE THAT
WE ALL CAN OUT WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT CONTRACT REALLY
REFLECTS THE CORE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
ARE ALSO A TIP MY HAT TO ALL OF
THE HOUSING BILLS THAT CAR IS
SUPPORTIVE OF ON AS I BELIEVE
YOU SHOULD BE -- THEN I BUT I
MUST KNOW BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
DISINGENUOUS TO REFERENCE A VETO
FROM A FOUR TERM GOVERNOR OF THE
BILL THAT ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS FROM OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE YOU WERE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION TO FROM THE
BEGINNING ANYWAY -- WITH REGARD
TO SUSPENSION OF PAYMENTS.
I MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT
ONLY OCCURS AFTER REPEATED
NOTICE AND THE EXAMPLE OF
GRAFFITI WAS AN INTERESTING --
ONE IT IN YOUR PRIVATE RESIDENCE
IN MANY MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS
THE STATE RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THE NEIGHBORING CITY
OF WOODLAND ALL WE HAVE EXAMPLES
OF GRAFFITI BEING.
VISIBLE ON AN EXTERIOR WALL WITH
THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
INFORMED THE HOMEOWNER THAT THEY
HAD AN OBLIGATION TO REMOVE THE
GRAFFITI WITHIN A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF TIME OR THEY WOULD BE FINED
BY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND SO THE GRAFFITI EXAMPLE I
THINK WAS INTERESTING BUT LET ME
BE CLEAR THAT SUSPENSION OF
PAYMENTS DOES NOT OCCUR.
UNTIL REPEATED NOTICES HAVE BEEN
ISSUED ALSO WITH REGARD TO
GRAFFITI I I AM A LANDLORD IN
THE MUNICIPALITY THAT REQUIRES
ANNUAL INSPECTIONS.
AND THOSE ANNUAL INSPECTIONS.
NOT THE SECTION EIGHT INSPECTION
THE REGULAR ANNUAL INSPECTION
ALSO WOULD HOLD ME ACCOUNTABLE
WITH REGARD TO GRAFFITI SO THAT
WOULD BE AN ISSUE JUST AS A
REGULAR LANDLORDS -- WHETHER YOU
ARE TAKING A SECTION.
EIGHT TENANT OR NOT.
SENATOR PORTANTINO'S BILL IS A
GREAT IDEA I HAPPILY VOTED FOR
IT LET ME BE CLEAR THAT THE TWO
BILLS ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WHAT REGARD TO
INSPECTIONS I THINK ALL OF US
HAVE A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
TO UPHOLD THE KIND OF INTEGRITY
OF THE USE OF PUBLIC FUNDS AND
THAT WE WOULD WANT INSPECTIONS
USED. FOR PRIVATE PROPERTY WHERE
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE
USED TO PAY THE RENT WE WOULD
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
GUARANTEEING THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE BEING SPENT.
IN HABITABLE -- PREMISES I THINK
THAT'S OUR COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY.
AGAIN WITH REGARD TO THE DELAYS --
THAT IT REQUIRES AYE.
A HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE BASED ON
OUR DIRECT CONTACT WITH HOUSING
AUTHORITIES THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY ASSOCIATIONS ICAL
SPONSOR OF THE BILL I WILL
RESTATE WITH ONE OF MY WITNESSES
SAID IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY IT'S
ONE BUSINESS DAY AFTER RECEIVING
THE REQUEST.
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY TURN AROUND
IS VERY QUICKLY INSPECT UNITS
WITHIN THE SAME DAY OR THE NEXT
DAY -- DEPENDED UPON THE BILL
ABILITY OF THE LANDLORD IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THEY DO TEND TO
HAVE LONGER INSPECTION TIMES I'M
AWARE THAT AND HAVE STATED
REPEATEDLY -- TO THE OPPOSITION
WHO HAVE CHOSEN TO MEET WITH ME
THAT I'M -- IT WANTING TO ENGAGE
IN ORGANIZE A MEETING TO SIT
DOWN WITH LA -- TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEIR STRUCTURAL BARRIERS
MAY BE TO EXPEDITED INSPECTIONS
ALTHOUGH EVEN FOR LA THERE MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT THE MAJORITY OF
THE INSPECTIONS ARE FINALIZED
WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS.
I THINK WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
THIRTY IN SIXTY DAYS WE ALL
THOUGHT ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE LANDLORDS HAVE.
A TURN AROUND TIME UPON WHICH
THEY HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE AT HEARING TO THE
INSPECTIONS THAT THEY HAVE
REPAIRS THEY HAVE TO MAKE.
THAT'S UP TO THE LANDLORD WITH
WITH REGARD TO THE REPEATEDLY
WITH WHICH THEY GET THE WORK
DONE TO ALLOW THEIR UNIT TO
QUALIFY FOR SECTION -- EIGHT
THIS BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED
IT'S GOING TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY -- FOR ANOTHER --
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE O WEIGH IN
ON THE QUESTION OF WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S A MANDATE I AM RELYING
ON THE INTERPRETATION LANGUAGE
OF THE ATTORNEYS -- WHO WHO
STAFF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND I STAND BY THEIR
COMMITMENT THAT THIS IS NOT A
MANDATE A PERSPECTIVE ALSO?
OF THE PROPONENTS AND COAL --
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
I RESPECT AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE ON BEHALF OF THE
REALTORS IN APARTMENT OWNERS
ASSOCIATION THAT IT IS NOT THEIR
INTENT TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
POOR PEOPLE AND I HOLD YOU TO
THAT COMMITMENT.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
CAN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO AND LA
COUNTY WAIT ANYWHERE FROM EIGHT
TO TEN YEARS TO GET A SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHER.
THEN DON'T LOSE THE PRIVILEGE.
BECAUSE IT THEY TIME OUT.
AND THEY AREN'T ABLE TO FIND A
SINGLE UNIT THAT WILL ACCEPT IT
WITHIN THE THIRTY OR SIXTY DAY
PERIOD OF TIME THEY HAVE. TO
FIND A LOCATION WITH THAT I ASK
FOR RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER GLORIA IS OUR SECOND THE
MOTION [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY. TO PASS MOTION
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
JUDICIARY TO SHOOT HI DAVE.
NOW GABRIELLE GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY [inaudible]
THE POINT.
IMAN.
IMAN I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I YOU HAVE THE FIVE
VOTES YOUR BILLS OUT WILL WAIT
FOR ADAM MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YES -- MISTER DEEP -- OF MAY I
ADD ON SOME BILLS I AFTER RUN
REAL QUICK SALARIES IT IS IT
OKAY IF I ADD ON OF TWO BILLS
FOR SURE WE HAVE WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL THAT I NEED TO PRESENT
THAT I WILL PRESENT INCREDIBLY
QUICKLY ON BEHALF OF THE SENATOR
COME TO EUROPE -- BUT YOU WANT
TO ADD ON NOW AND THEN AND I WAS
A SURE IF IF -- WANT ONE WE DO
ADD ON'S RIGHT NOW AND THEN I
WILL PRESENT THE FINAL BILL AND
THEN WE'LL GO FROM THERE THAT'S
OKAY THANK YOU RICHARD
[inaudible]
BUT IT.
OKAY I FILE ITEM [inaudible]
THAT.
MISTER DAVIS OKAY I'M GONNA I'LL
TAKE FORTY FIVE SECONDS.
THE END OF GERMAN.
SO COLLEAGUES TO SENATOR THE
CENTERS ILL SOME PRESENTING THE
SB SIX ELEVEN I HAD TWO PAGES OF
A PRESENTATION I'M GOING TO CUT
IT DOWN TO TWO SENTENCES.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH THE
HOUSING OLDER PERSONS
EFFECTIVELY TASK FORCE AS PART
OF THE STATE'S MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING WE ALL KNOW THE CHALLENGES
FACING SENIORS.
AND HOUSING THAT'S WHY YOU
SHOULD SUPPORT THIS BILL THE
CENTER IS ACCEPTING THE MASON
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED IN
THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO SOME WANT
TO THANK THE AMAZING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK -- WITHOUT
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER FOR VERY
QUICK PRESENTATIONS BY WITNESSES.
YEAH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CASEY O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR STATE
TREASURER FIONA MA -- I CAN TAKE
THE HIT WE LOVE YOUR SUPPORT
APPRECIATE EVERYONE BEING HERE
THANK YOU.
MEGAN ROSE WITH LEADING EDGE
CALIFORNIA I WILL SEE MY TIME TO
JACKSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
YES.
HELLO MY NAME'S JAZZ ABREGO NAME
PRESIDENT TELUGU RESIDENTIAL
MANAGEMENT.
A SUBSIDIARY OF OUR PARENT
COMPANY TELUGU IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
TELUGU IS THE NATION'S LARGEST
AND OLDEST COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS TELUGU HAS EMPOWERED
PEOPLE WITH TE BASIC TOOLS ALL
AMERICANS NEED. TO BUILD A
BETTER LIFE INCLUDING WELL
PAYING JOBS INCREASED ACCESS TO
CAPITAL EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
TELUGU HAS WORKED FOR MANY
DECADES WITH GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND REGULATED PROGRAMS TO
DEVELOP BEAUTIFUL RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES THAT PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE SAFE ENRICHING
ENVIRONMENTS FOR FAMILIES IN
SENIOR CITIZENS IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OUR BUILDINGS ARE AFFORDABLE TO
EVEN THE LOWEST INCOME SENIORS
NON PAYING MORE THAN 30% OF
THEIR INCOME TOWARDS THEIR
HOUSING COSTS EACH MONTH'S.
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY HAVE MONEY
LEFT OVER FOR FOOD MEDICATION
AND HEALTH CARE COST
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS BILL HAS A SUPPORT SUPPORT.
WE'RE GONNA GET IT OUT THE
COMMITTEE IN THE NEXT THIRTY
SECONDS [inaudible]
BASICALLY.
WHILE IT WOULD BE A GOOD START
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO SIMPLY BUILD
MORE HOUSING WE NEED TO FIND
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
BRINGING HOUSING HEALTH CARE AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. TO OUR OLDER
ADULTS.
THIS THIS BILL SEEKS TO BRING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER FROM
ACROSS THE STATE TO BRAINSTORM
AND INNOVATIVE HOUSING SOLUTIONS
FOR OLDER ADULTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE GAY
PLEASE.
THANK YOU -- MANIA WITNESS IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RAINY HICKS OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
OF CALIFORNIA LINES RETIRED
AMERICANS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS FROM GREEN MEMBERS.
THIS IS TERRY MCNICHOLS PLEASE
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
DO BEST AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN AGING AND LONG
TERM.
LONG.
TERM -- CHIU.
CHIU I DEEP.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I HIGHLY.
HIGHLY HIGHLY MON.
THE ONE I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI THAT MEASURE IS
OUT LET US GO THROUGH THE REST
THE ROLE.
START AT THE TOP FILE ITEM ONE
AT ON MEMBERS TO SB SIX BELL.
DEEP BY I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
IS OUT SB.
TWO SORRY FILE ITEM TO SB
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN GABRIEL [inaudible]
GABRIEL MORNING [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
FILE ITEM. FIVE OF FILE ITEM FOR
SB TWO THIRTY FIVE DODD.
CHIU HI.
I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB THREE TWENTY
THREE WHITE HOUSE SKI.
MADAM SECRETARY.
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
HERE.
FILE I'M SIX SB THREE TWENTY SIX
HELL [inaudible]
GABRIELLE -- GABRIEL I
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
UP HILL ITEM SIX WHILE I'M.
SIX SB THREE TWENTY SIX HEALTH
CURRENT.
I QUIRK SILVA HI.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB THREE TWENTY
NINE MITCHELL I THINK THE ONLY
ONE LEFT IS MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
MR MAIENSCHEIN ON THE MITCHELL
BILL.
NUMBER OKAY FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
THREE THIRTY SKINNER. FOR MANY
MEMBERS TO BUY SHOES I AM
MAIENSCHEIN.
FOLLOW NINE SB FIVE THIRTY TWO
PORTANTINO THE APPS MEMBERS. TWO
HI CHIU I DATE I DEEP I
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
SILVER HI.
AND LESS ITEM FILE AND TEN SB
SIX ELEVEN COPIER I THINK THE
ONLY MISSING MEMBER WAS MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN THE SUMMATION.
HI MICHELLE AT NIGHT AND WE HAVE
WE HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I CHIU HI CHIU I DID I DID I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA. SIX OF A LEFT EARLY
YES ADELINE ST.
I KNOW IT'S WRONG FEEL -- LET'S
ROLL THROUGH THE FIRST
EXCITEMENT FOR MR MAIENSCHEIN
FILE ITEM ONE SB SIX BELL MR
MAJOR. NINE NINE FILE AND TO SB
THIRTEEN LIKE HUSKY MISTER MAJOR.
HEY FILE ITEM FOR SB TO THIRTY
FIVE DODD MISTER MENTION.
NOW I'D.
FALLEN FIVE SB THREE TWENTY
THREE WHITE KOWSKI MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
pSIX HILL MISTER MANTRA.
I THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
FOR THE DAY WE ARE NOW